thank you I'd like to call the hearing
to order
for the first uh resources Recreation
development committee uh first uh well
let's all stand first before we get to
the pledge I'd like moment of
silence uh for
Suzanne Suzanne Smith who pass the
away
and I can't speak too
much thank
you I ask
the vice chair us and Pledge of
Allegiance please join with me in a
pledge to flag I pledge Al to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the rep for it
stands
indivisible all right first uh bill on
the docket is House Bill
and
fortunately this is the first time I've
actually seen the bills
in uh in printed
form because uh we haven't had a chairs
meeting uh since they since they came
out
uh requiring a Bo owner to who is not
the operator to notify law enforcement
and file an accident report report in
certain circumstances representative
McDonald chair is your the floor is
yours thank you uh Mr chairman good
morning members of uh resource
Recreation development my name is
representative John McDonald and I am
from Cal district 6 which is the
communities of wolf BR T and Broner
Hampshire uh this is a fairly Common
Sense Bill uh that I'm surprised hasn't
been brought to the committee's
attention before this and it just makes
some minor changes on captain D we will
talk to some of the incidents he's
observed uh within Mar mature buau but
it just makes the uh owner of the boat
required to file an accident report in
the event the operator doesn't file the
report um and that's that's basically
what it's all
about are you is that your testimony y
it's very simple common sense and
reasonable bill I think thank you very
much your excuse thank you
uh excuse me is there any questions by
members I'm I'm retra I'm in retraining
I'm
old uh were there any questions for
members of the uh of the
committee representative
Darby thank you Mr chairman sorry I
agree this is a common sense bill um I
noticed that you know as I read the bill
there's three main parts uh you know of
the existing law that is um that's being
and one part that's being amended so um
you know if you're in an accident you
have to stop help and exchange
information you have to immediately
notify Marine Patrol or um or uh police
or someone if Marine Patrol is not
present and you can't exchange with the
uh uh with uh uh
the other party um and then you have to
file a report within 15 days this bill
as I read it says that if the um if the
uh the party that was in that caused the
accident hasn't filed the report within
15 days then the owner has to file the
report instead but the thing that I'm
wondering about is the immediate
notification so the you know if we look
at um didn't I don't have there it is
line 12 of the existing test text says
immediately notify Marine patrol officer
or other officer but this bill says um
if they haven't filed the report in 15
days then you have to file the report I
wonder if the um if the owner as soon as
they are aware that the that the um
incident hasn't been reported should uh
should have to immediately notify Marine
Patrol um so that the 15-day period
doesn't have to elapse
thank you for the question
representative
um this has been in effect for as long
as I can recall this particular RSA and
we worked closely with the remol to try
to figure out the best way to move
forward and this is what they suggested
uh I think that's a good idea that you
mentioned I just would like to have
Captain dunlevy answer your question see
how that would work for the Department
itself we could thank
you
any any other questions from the
committee thank you Mr chair um I just
wondered if there's a story behind the
bill if there's uh someone who came to
you or what was the Genesis that
way I'm sure Captain dun liy has many
stories uh because he and they're all
true uh because we talked about this
bill in previous sessions and I'm sure
he'd be glad to relay those stories to
you thank you
any other questions from the committee
members seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you for your time
Captain dun
Levy good morning Mr chair honorable
members of the committee it's good to
see you my name is Tim Dunley and I come
before you today uh representing the
department of safety uh Marine Patrol
unit uh we come today uh supporting this
bill um as representative McDonald
indicated we've see this as being
somewhat of a long overdue and a common
sense
bill in circumstances where we have had
boating accidents in the past where
sometimes the operator is not the owner
um perhaps they're impaired perhaps for
whatever reason they become
incapacitated perhaps they've suffered
personal injury they're not capable of
filing the report as required by
law um the current statute says that
when that happens the owner is
responsible for filing that
paperwork the problem we're having is
those boat accidents that occur
sometimes in the middle of the night
sometimes in a remote body of water
where there aren't anybody isn't anyone
around to observe
it um perhaps there's some sort of
criminal activity associated with it
whether it be the condition of the
operator or or the circumstances by
which the accident
happened we find boats up on shorelines
in the trees with no one around the next
morning and often times we've learned
that the owner is oftentimes the
operator um and those reports aren't
being made to us in a timely fashion to
invest truly what happened we get a
piece of paperwork 15 days later and
it's a surprise to us so this statute
requires the operator to notify us
immediately when they can and if they
cannot it's putting the onus on the
owner we've had circumstances where
people make phone calls come and get us
our boats high and dry on the
shoreline um we need to get out of here
and the owner is present um so this is
just putting more responsibility on the
owner once they become aware of the
incident whether they're there or not to
notify us the timeline for filing the
reports is not changing we are looking
for that immediate
notification once they become aware of
it so to uh perhaps answer
representative Darby's question of
earlier
um we're not increasing or decreasing
the time they have to file the report
it's to make notification to law
enforcement officials that the incident
has
occurred and once they become aware of
it that's when they need to notify
us and that that change and I I'll
reference the
line line 19 and 20 is if the owner of
the vessel uh once they become aware of
it forth with will notify um
immediately that's the the the purpose
uh of this bill and uh I'm happy to
answer any questions that you may
have any questions from the
committee any questions from the
committee I just want to read this
briefly now that I understand the um so
just like have one minute one second to
sort of read this I do have another
question um it says immediate
notification of um you know to Marine
Patrol does that would would calling
Marine Patrol um suffice for immediate
notification absolutely sir okay thank
you Captain I have a question yes sir
how easy is it for an owner to verify if
a report was done or not are these
reports immediately public uh
information accessible to
everyone um as the owner of the vessel
certainly it would be uh there may be
some information in the report as to
passengers and that sort of thing that
would need to be redacted it would not
be public information but the fact that
the incident occurred and the vessel
involved uh would be public information
and so they would and certainly the way
this statute is written uh any
culpability on behalf of that owner
would be something the state would need
to prove uh should they be in violation
so uh this is not just an arbitrary
action on behalf of Marine Patrol to
charge an owner because they don't have
paperwork and didn't know about it
there's obviously some culpability there
that we would need to
demonstrate thank you
Captain thank you Mr
chair um so I and just tell you the my
the line that I'm concerned with um the
the qualifying Clause of if the operator
this is on line 17 if the operator is
physically or mentally incapable of
making report or fails or refuses to
make the
report um do do dot then the owner has
to forth with notify so the fourth with
notify makes sense to me the thing that
I'm concerned about is that um
the the notification is based on the
report the failure uh to file the report
and the report's not due for 15
days
I I see what you're saying
um
so we would we would not as long as that
operator
um I may take just a moment uh I think I
follow
you does the fact in line
19 say after after learning of the
accident again the state would have to
prove that owner has learned of the
accident um cover your
concern I believe it would yes thank
you any other questions for Captain dun
Levy seeing none thank you for your
testimony Captain thank you very
much is there anyone else who would like
to testify on HB 1046 FN I have no more
cards up here one more time anybody want
to testify on HB 1046
FN seeing none I'll close the hearing on
HB 1046 FN at 10:00 we have HB
1301 wake surfing on public bodies of
water enjoy your
break just one uh one thing before uh
before we break I've passed the gavel
over to the vice chair because but the
clerk and the my clerk and the backup
clerk are not going to be here so I
guess I'm the third I'm the backup to
the backup so so I'll be doing the
clerking and uh the uh sh and the vice
chair will be filling it for me shows
you how useless the chair actually
is
so so that's that's why if you wonder
why what I'm doing well I'm the clerk as
well
so it's a more important job thank
you see
that
e
I see many people here that probably are
going to testify on HB 1301 if you are
you need to fill in one of those pink or
red cards and it would be appreciated if
you could bring them forward so we'll
know how many you're going to testify
thank
you
representative
Darby need to do
M yes
I was asked to repeat if you're wanting
to testify can you fill in one of these
pink cards and bring it forward thank
you
thank
sorry
one that's
all
it's 10 o'clock I'm going to call the
hearing on HB 1301 relative to wake
surfing on public bodies of water water
to order and our first Speaker uh
representative Darby thank you Mr
Darby thank you Mr chair um chairman
manulo honorable members of the
committee thanks for making it out after
the storm last night and thank you for
allowing me to introduce House Bill 1301
to you this morning based on the online
testimony it appears this bill solicits
significant passion on both sides of the
issue and many misunderstandings so I'll
attempt to clarify as briefly as
possible first the intent of this bill
is to balance the opportunity to wake
surf with other top opportunities to
enjoy the lake while also considering
environmental concerns I would expect
water bodies with responsible wake
Surfers who observe the Marine trade
guidelines to have no additional
regulations imposed as a result of this
bill instead it targets those Lakes
where conflict already exists due to
Reckless wake
surfing this bill is modeled after
existing New Hampshire laws permitting
restrictions on horsepower speed and ski
craft which protect a Lakefront owner's
property the lake ecosystem and
establish uses on water
bodies to begin 25 residents or Property
Owners must submit a petition to the
Department of Safety to request a
hearing if they want to impose wake
surfing limitations or restrictions note
this is more than double the number
required to petition for ski craft
restrictions next the petitioners must
send certified mail to all Property
Owners as well as those with deed access
informing them of the public hearing on
the requested limitations or
restrictions in speaking with Chris
Casco a lawyer with the hearings Bureau
at the department of safety he stated
this was an appropriately High
bar given the effort required by the
department to conduct such a
hearing all sides will get an
opportunity to present their perspective
at the public hearing which will be held
near the subject water
body and the condition commissioner must
take multiple factors into account
before approving the petition including
impacts on the shore and Wildlife size
and depth
of the affected Lake areas establish
uses of the water body as well as and
importantly ensuring access and
appropriate use of public water
bodies once a decision is made those
aggrieved by the Department's ruling can
appeal clearly the process is thorough
and 25 Lake residents alone cannot ban
wake
surfing in addition to the misconception
that a small group of property owners
can prohibit wake surfing enjoyed by
broad Community the bill also does not
ban wake boats it does not attempt to
Define these popular watercraft which
are used for numerous water activities
and instead relies on definitions in
existing statute for wake surfing the
bill also will not add burden to the to
to the burden of Marine Patrol or the
department of safety note that the bill
does not contain a fiscal note and as
mentioned the department has an existing
Heroes Bureau for related purposes and
the Marine Patrol will simply include
enforcement of wak surfing Rec
restrictions with existing parols for
safety speed and compliance
regulations some online testimony raises
concerns that this bill will pit
neighbor against neighbor over the
petition petition process based on my
experience animosity between Lake
residents currently exists as wake
Surfers have little motivation to
consider the concerns of others on the
lake I predict this bill will have the
opposite effect encouraging Advocates
and objectors to work together on a
compromise to permit responsible wake
serving and avoid a timeconsuming costly
petition
process the general court has seen
numerous wake surfing bills over the
last few years HB 137 in 2019
established a commission to study wake
boats which produced the final report in
2020 HB 115 passed in 2021 was based on
the recommendations of that commission
it defined wake serving and introduced
Common Sense safety
regulations this bill resulted from
another suggestion by the commission
members to use the structured hearing
process of RSA
541a while many hope the responsible WG
surfing Outreach and education process
promoted by the Marine trades
Association would encourage
self-regulation by the wake surfing
Community limited engagement or other
factors have seemingly undercut its
Effectiveness as anecdotal complaints
from Lake users continue to
increase but what is the harm of wake
surfing why can't we just let people
enjoy the lake the way they choose
unfortunately the side effects of WG
surfing can NE negatively impact others
and the
environment restrictions can be
appropriate when the activities of one
group impinge on the rights of another
of
others the impacts were clearly
documented in the commission's final
report including damage to private
property and water quality from
excessive weights generated within
several 100 ft from
Shore reduced enjoyment by swimmers
kayakers and other lwi impact water
water activities for example causing
waiting children to be knocked over and
near caping of smaller boats and danger
to Wildlife such as noon Lon nesting
locations and vast spawning
grounds more recently several studies
have
introduced excuse me have identified
sediment disruption resulting from
downward angled wake boat propulsion
systems reaching 20 ft and resuspending
previously trapped phosphorus
contributing to increasingly frequent
cyanobacteria
blooms while those most familiar with
the lake its residents are in the best
position to identify areas with the
greatest vulnerability and recommend
limitations to protect against these
threats I'll conclude with a couple of
brief personal stories from over the
last year we all remember the record
rainfall of July um last year
2023 after rescuing my neighbors wooden
dock from literally floating away and
reporting a pondon boat that had floated
off its boat lift and down the Lake to
collide with another neighbor's dock I
was flabbergasted to see irresponsible
WG Surfers on the lake pounding already
swamp docks and shorelines I have a
picture of that if you're interested
later in the summer I was canoeing
across the narrow lake with my dog
riding Lookout when a wake surfing boat
exercised their right of passing 150 ft
from my bow the next few moments were
frantic as I attempted to navigate a
4-ot wake keep the canoe's bow pointed
into the waves calm my frantic dog and
maintain balance to keep us from dumping
but this is not about me I have heard
from many many others with similar
experiences leading me to conclude that
Outreach and education alone are
insufficient to break the bad habits of
those who uh wake surf
irresponsibly thank you again for your
time and attention this morning I
genuinely believe this bill will help
everyone enjoy our beautiful lakes and
ponds by encouraging the wake surfing
Community to collaborate with others
that share the lake I'm happy to answer
any
questions thank you representative any
questions for the
representative seeing none thank you for
your testimony thank you
again The Honorable Pam price from
sopy
do I have to push it on here good
morning um thank you all uh for
welcoming me here today and it is an
honor to be back in this Hall um my
name's Pam price I was a representative
in this very body from 2002 to
2010 uh from the city of nsha now a
full-time resident in the for almost
five years uh in sunap New Hampshire um
I I was a member of the 2019 commission
to study wake boats and I'm here today I
should say I'm here today in opposition
to House Bill
1301 we did conduct an extensive s uh
study over the course of nine months and
we found no strong evidence of problems
that required legislative correction
during that study we studied invasives
we studied Wildlife we studied wave
action and we studied water
quality um the water sport industry
Association did recognize that there was
a problem with those who dislike the
activity and they conducted an extensive
public awareness
campaign um and that's been done in
conjunction with the Department of
Safety over the last couple years and uh
yet there continues a move to try to
Outlaw the sport of wake surfing so what
does House Bill 1301 do um the
representative who uh sponsored and
introduced the bill did say that 25 or
more residents or Property Owners of a
town that has a lake Pond or a river can
petition the department of safety to
restrict
activity uh only the abutters are
notified and anybody who's more than a
quarter of a mile away receives no
direct notification so so what you have
are the um wishes of a few who might
regulate the activity of
many does the department have the
Personnel to handle the hearings is this
in the public interest to
have uh restrictions made or is it in
the interests of a few New Hampshire has
long opposed the expanding of the
petition process because it will create
a patchwork a regul potion and I do
believe it would pet neighbor against
neighbor and those on the water versus
those off the water the public trust
Doctrine which I'm sure you all are
aware of ensures that all public
waterways in the state of New Hampshire
are held in trust for the use and
benefit of the people of the state this
is done to ensure access to the public
to use our Waters
reasonably our lakes in New Hampshire
are key to the outdoor recreation and
the
economic economy of this state to
restrict access would send the wrong
message people are going to wonder if
you can restrict one thing now what will
it be
tomorrow uh and it
may
uh have people decide to Vacation
elsewhere or buy property elsewhere my
family personally owns a towboat three
Generations enjoy tubing and water
skiing and wake surfing on our beautiful
Lake sopy in the
summer the public awareness campaign has
changed our uh Behavior we push
ourselves even further from Shore than
the 150 fot Rule and we regulate our
music uh volumes to restrict access
today um I think is premature
but what we have observed this last
summer uh it was extremely rainy summer
there was very little boating activity
but we've witnessed over the past few
years an increase in violations people
who are mostly safe passage coming too
close to us my husband was almost hit by
a jet skier in the water last year uh
after he had fallen um we see very
little Marine Patrol on our Lake and if
the legislature really wanted to do
something then I think it would behoove
everyone to get together and look to
increase funding for the department so
that they can enforce the laws that we
have currently before we pass a new
law and thank you very
much thank you anyone have a question
brother represent yes representative
wolf
representative wolf I didn't recognize
you how are
you you're from Newbury I'm from copy
anyways
yeah excuse me um thank you for taking
my question you uh
noted that uh the activities of tubing
water skiing and wake surfing correct do
you make a distinction
within those
three um I'm not sure I understand your
question do we operate the boat
differently based on the three do
you accept that there is a
distinction of the effect that those
three types of activities have on the
lake uh I personally don't believe there
are a difference certainly um the wake
is larger when you're wake
surfing but I don't believe that um the
overall impact is any
different thank
you any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony very much I
did circulation thank you thank you
David Neils uh New Hampshire
Dees
good morning committee chair Ren Zulo
members of the R&D committee my name is
David Neals I'm the uh Chief aquatic
biologist and director of the jod Conor
luminology Center at Dees I thank you
for the opportunity to testify in HB
1301 this morning DS doesn't take a
position on this Bill Hower we have a
few comments that we offer to the
committee in consideration of the bill D
DS staff myself in particular as was
mentioned earlier uh were also involved
in some of the past legislation
regarding wake Sports and particular uh
participation on the 2020 wake boo
commission the bill as you all know as
proposed would offer a petition process
to regulate the activity of wake surfing
on certain water bodies Dees prefers the
approach taken terms of regula
potentially regulating the activity over
the use of certain types of watercraft
on water bodies such as wake boats uh we
think it's much easier for the safety
patrol to also recognize the activity
vers um The Vessel Craft um as we've
testified in previous years we know that
all types of boats can produce small or
large waves and that's largely dependent
on how they're operated however the uh
specific activity of wake surfing uh
requires that larger waves be produced
in uh in regards to other motorized
water sports the larger water wave and
the larger waves U associated with the
activity presents an environmental risk
especially with regards to shoreline
erosion and sediment resuspension both
which can increase nutrient loading into
our surface
waters we also know that um wake surfing
uh has a potential to introduce exotic
uh invasive species as an additional
environmental threat which is associated
with the activity because often times in
order to do the activity they have to
add additional water which is ballast to
uh create the waves that they need to
Surf DS notes that there have been
several recent studies uh that have
documented that it's important to
consider factors such as the distance to
shore which the activity occurs and the
depth of the water in which the activity
occurs in order to minimize shoreline
erosion and sediment suspension
specifically the literature uh notes
that a 4 to 500 foot setback is needed
from shorelines in order to uh create or
have a way power equal to a um a
motorboat cruising at 150 ft from Shore
that's been documented in the literature
Additionally the literature supports the
idea that um sediment suspension
typically occurs at depths of 20 fet or
less uh when this activity occurs and
that it can lead to a temporary increase
in the phosphorus in the water column by
20% in conclusion Dees suggests that
those factors should be considered
should be taken into consideration um in
this bill as part of the proposed
petition
process uh so that wake surfing uh can
occur with minimal environmental
harm thank you any questions from Mr
Neils
representative W uh can you cite
specific uh documentation for those
uh damages that you talk about there's a
study I believe from is it
Minnesota one of the studies was
completed in I think it was 2020
University of Minnesota St PA St
Anthony's Falls laboratory
correct and that produced several
outcomes uh some of which are
quantitative that you can uh look at the
power and energy of waves from various
distance based on the watercraft type
yes followup followup is it possible to
regulate wake
boats operating as they
do at a diff at various
depths how would one do
that I think the are you talking about a
specific area of a lake based on the
depth of the water yes um certainly Maps
could be produced we have Beth themetry
Maps which are depth maps for all the
Lakes um I respect the idea that that
would present somewhat of a challenge to
the Department of Safety and regulating
that um but as the maps were produc or
if they were produced certainly the
public could be made aware of their
presence and the general areas where the
activities should be performed
does that answer your
question yes to a degree follow
up let me ask first Mr Wolf anyone else
have a question of the
speaker if not okay one more the
representative will would that be
similar to what is known as no rafting
zones to find an it's def no rafting
zone is
defined as an area correct could
limiting weight boats be defined in a
similar
manner that I'm C I'm certainly could be
defined by a map or on um in writing I
think the challenges would be to put
that into effect on the water um
certainly that's done now with 150 foot
rule and um very respectful the Marine
Patrol people that understand that
distance and are instruments that you
know would allow them to to site dis
distances that that's one potential way
of doing it and again the the presence
of maps would give the general public an
idea of where the activities are okay to
be performed thank you
sure yeah anything else for
the
speaker representative Ren zul I would
ask
uh captain dunlevy
uh you heard the some of the questions
from uh representative wolf uh would you
have anything that might
uh bear on that you know questions of
uh we might be able to do you know thank
you Mr chairman again Tim dun Ley with
the Department of Safety Marine Patrol
um with respect to water depths uh and
mapping those are things that certainly
are a significant challenge
when you have a restriction in place for
whatever reason that restriction comes
to be uh it's a very specific location
or a specific body of water when you
start dealing with depths um that every
body of water has a depth at say 20 fet
is being thrown around today um last
summer is a good example what's 20 feet
in May at 20 feet in May maybe 25 ft in
July depending upon the body of water so
there's a lot of fluctuations there's a
a lot of variables that go into uh
mapping depth and and having a specific
depth a restriction based on a specific
depth um and certainly the challenge of
publicizing maps if you will um for the
general public uh is is a
challenge thank
you any further questions for Mr
Nails seeing none thank you for your t
testimony so those today will know how
we're conducting this hearing I have a
whole bunch of cards on my desk as you
can see we're going to alternate one for
one against until we' have equaled those
and then I have extra cards then we'll
call up the rest of those people but
we're going to go back and forth so you
may wonder why are we calling people
like we're calling them so now you know
okay so uh speaking in support Andrea
Laro of New Hampshire
Lakes thank
you good morning uh I'm Andrea lamro uh
president of New Hampshire Lakes thank
you for this opportunity to speak uh we
are here speaking in support of this
bill New Hampshire Lakes we are a
Statewide nonprofit um organization our
mission is is to restore and preserve
the health of our Lakes we represent
about 275 local groups and uh a couple
thousand uh
individuals and again thank you for this
opportunity to speak we are in support
of this bill and I know you're going to
have a long morning so I'm really going
to get to the point uh representative
Darby laid out a number of reasons why
we support this bill um I want to say um
we believe that the sport of wake
surfing can be a very Family Fun
inclusive um loow impact sport um when
conducted in areas that are away from
sensitive ecological um places such as
critical fish habitat uh loon nesting
and as far away from Shore and as deep
as water as
possible uh I would like to think that
most of us in this room um are on that
same page um I know a lot of wake
surfing uh in the community a lot of
wake Surfers do uh conduct their
activities as far away from Shore in as
deep as water as possible and you know
away from sensitive areas um so I
applaud that um that is happening in the
community but referencing what
representative Darby said um education
is not enough um you know there are
plenty of people in this room today that
wake surf um that aren't educated or
don't um comply with the voluntary
education program um I live on my family
has a place in the lake my husband's
family has a place in the lake we do all
all sorts of water sports and we do it
you know in a responsible manner like
most everyone in this room probably but
we have myself included have tried to
talk with others on the lake that aren't
recreating in a responsible way and um
I've had instances where I haven't made
much progress so I do think that the
establishment of a petition process um
that is inclusive and includes public
hearing like we do for other activities
on the lake can be an opportunity Unity
to actually bring Community together to
have to bring wake Surfers and non-w
Surfers together to have more Community
conversations these conversations are
already happening in communities but
they need to be happening more um so I
do believe that this could help um no
one wants regulation at the end of the
day and hopefully that this having the
potential for this to exist this you
know a petition and a regulation to
exist um will encourage folks to work
more closely together my final Point um
that I wanted to make is there's um we
are supportive of this bill because it
is protective of water quality and
ecological health and there's been a
number of speakers thus far who have
reference the growing body of studies
talking about the impacts of the
activity of wake surfing in Shallow
close to shore in sensitive areas on on
the health and quality and um I do have
a study a very nice literature review
that summarizes um a handful of studies
um and I'm happy to I have one printed
copy here I'm happy to provide it or
email the uh committee afterwards with a
link to this literature
review if you email it with an
attachment I think that would be great I
and everybody will get it well thank you
for your time um and I'm happy to answer
any questions any questions for our
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you speaking against the
bill John Wy of New Hampshire Marine
trades Association
John
good morning everyone uh my last name is
Wally for the record thank you um just
want to point out two quick things about
WG surfing um first I think the idea
that wake surfing boats need to have
large wakes is a
misconception wake surfing started back
in the 1950s with 12 foot surfboards and
you don't need a big wake you just need
a safe boat designed in board boat to
Surf so in turn some of these challenges
will be eliminating people off of B ways
that have reasonably small wakes that
use a boat that they can water ski
behind and do all these different things
and also too water depth is a critical
element surfing you can't surf in water
typically less than 15 feet it's just
the wave doesn't work so you wouldn't be
able to Surf anyways so you wouldn't go
into those protected areas that people
are so concerned about so just want to
point that out up front so good morning
Mr chairman in the committee my name is
John Wally I'm the general sales manager
at Silver Sands Marina and the president
of the New Hampshire Marine trades
Association I stand before you as a
representative of that group many of
whom at the we Bo show in Boston today
and cannot be here um we are opposed to
House Bill
1301 New Hampshire relies on summer
tourism and recreational boating is a
big contributor bills like H bille 1301
will fracture L communities create
confusion where you can and cannot wake
surf and ruin our familyfriendly
reputation we have in New
Hampshire according to a national study
boating and fishing are our top
contributors in New Hampshire and
roughly $1.4 billion dollar goes into
our annual income supporting 6,000 jobs
many of whom are in this room
today New Hampshire has a strong boed
culture but we also have some recognized
challenges with a large number of B
registrations typically over a 100,000
in abnormally high water level last year
there was definitely an impacted and
negative perception from wiger
boats house SP 1301 establishes a
Banning process on individ individual
bodies of water these bodies of water
are held in public chust for all to
enjoy not the few this impacts a lot of
people and wake surfing boat as
mentioned before is very popular it's
exceptionally low impact it's safe and
fun for all ages
inabilities allowing 25 people to sign a
petition in an effort to ban New
Hampshire families from enjoying
themselves and our tourism guests poses
significant challenges increased
congestion on certain lakes or wakeing
will be allowed or will not be allowed
will ship boats from one Lake to
another tensions between neighbors will
also happen it
will when will these hearings take place
during the summer when people are around
during the winter when a lot of our out
ofate second home owners are not around
and won't have a say in the matter how
will boers learn the process what will
happen to families who have made
significant investments in their boating
products with their families will they
have to sell that
stuff people turn to boating and water
sports for enjoyment exercise or
released from screen time with their
kids in family bonding are we trying to
say no to
that we are aware that some boter mostly
due to inexperience do not operate bubat
correctly with the safe passage laws
which is 150 fet education and
enforcement is a
key the New Hampshire Marine trades
Association partners with the New
Hampshire Marine Patrol Ed educating our
consumers on our current laws and our
best practices of the New Hampshire Lake
responsibility campaign now if you went
to boat ramps all over the lake you'll
see about a 2 by3 foot sign that says
boat a safe distance from each other
surf offshore keep your noise levels
down do not make repetitive passes in
front of the same house over and over
and over again be respectful of your
neighbors that's been a massive campaign
we've sent out um tens of thousands of
dollars have been spent on Advertising
every boat that goes in the water from
many marinas has a hang tag on those
steering wheels reminding people
annually to be good behave be good to
your neighbors be just a good person all
around on the lake and support our clean
water
Zacks we also have a new bill being cify
with the Senate s SP 431 which really
basically focuses on the Marine trades
acts and also the Wake responsibly
campaign into focusing on driving people
to understand this is the best practices
and this will become hopefully a
law we also recognize too that the
immense challenges that could be opposed
on our M Patrol 60 to 70 officers was
pretty much the norm 15 or years ago I
think Tim can back that up today we're
down to 25 or less it's going to create
immense amount of strain on having to
add additional laws into place and
potential bans if I'm a consumer and I'm
going to take my boat on vacation from
Massachusetts and I have a rental home I
take my boat to the lake I show up and
next thing I know I can't use my boat
the way I'm choosing to how will I ever
know that is my airbn V or my VRBO or my
rental going to tell me there's no
weight something on this Lake that's
going to affect economics that's going
to affect rental costs and it's going to
potentially ruin my week so that's a
concern I like to also look at the
environment which as many New Hampshire
Brees Association
members we're on the water the water is
our environment to make having Sals and
selling boats it's important to us but I
want to point out that cob bacteria
blooms happen on both bodies of water
with boats and without this year it's
been documented Aquatic and vasive
species can be carried into bodies of
water not just by boats trailers have
water that go into the frames and they
can carry that water from Lake to Lake
canoes kayaks paddlecraft Ducks geese
fishing gear even scuba equipment can
carry C or excuse me aquatic evasive
species from one late to the next if
it's not properly
cleaned sediment displacements can
happen it can't just it's not just from
waser boats people swimming people
walking on the bottom anchoring trolling
through shallow water fishing even ice
prev even ice prevention equipment such
as aquatherm and bubblers and not to
mention wind ice and water waves that's
Silver S Maro we have a large Beach and
every year I look at the ice damage that
just pounds on our beach and pushes it
all up and as we spend about two or
three days typically out with a tractor
smoothing that all out best we can
because it's pushed the ice back so far
onto our Shoreline it's even sometimes
damaged our
lawn to ban and restrict is not the
solution we really need to focus on
education and I think that's the most
important thing having people understand
what is a reasonable limit offshore
being respectful of our neighbors that's
really the New Hampshire way that's what
we've always done and I can tell you
that everyone on a leg typically knows
somebody else on a leg and I know this
been situations in the past where it's
been contentious and challenging but we
need to work together to find a better
solution thank you for your
time thank you any questions for our
speaker representative
Bale um yeah I just have a question
excuse
me a quick question about um how will a
boter know whether or or not they can go
on a certain Lake um don't boers already
research where they're going to go to
see if they can wake surf there or not
never been an issue you can wake surf on
any Lake mean other than the fact that
you know in the situation based off a
current law of 150 ft from Shore you
imagine that's double so if if a body of
water is less than 300 feet wide you
can't travel down that body of water at
speed you have to go at an idle speed so
there's there's currently no
restrictions or bans of any kind of wake
surfing or wake surfing boats does that
answer your question yes thank you
okay representative L
montin morning thank you for taking my
question um well given that there may be
some Lakes where it's impossible to
follow the safe guidelines for Wake
serving State guidelines state state
guidelines for what would be a safe way
to Waker that some Lakes may make that
impossible um couldn't you see the the
benefit perhaps of that Lake
should the community petition and are
successful to say that wake boarding
would not be allow wake surfing would
not be allowed because it would be
impossible to do it in a safe
way I think there always a safe way
whether it's legal or not I think is a
bigger question question you know
um the challenges that that concern me
is that we we turn into these elitist
private Lakes which is exactly what we
don't do in New Hampshire we've always
been a place for for uh people to come
and enjoy themselves I mean that's why
we move here in liia right I mean I know
there's a lot of people that have moved
from Southern States and in retirement
when their jobs are no longer at
employment and now too with through
covid with being able to remote in from
work and you choose to move to New
Hampshire because it's a great place to
live and recreate um I think people want
to be on buys of water that they can
choose the activity that they want to do
I think it's a a disappointing thing
when you have to find out that 25 people
on your Lake petition to potentially ban
whatever you love if I found 25 people
on my Lake that wanted to thought that
you
know canoes were dangerous out past 150
ft from Shore because that's in a you
know higher level speed of voting I
guess I kind of think about would I
bicycle down i93 it's not really
appropriate you know but that that's the
same kind of thing we're talking about
potentially petiti a petition plan to
potentially restrict someone from doing
a certain
Activity thank you representative
will thank you for your testimony you're
welcome um you said something at the
very beginning about 15 feet depth yeah
typically the way boats are designed
wave surfing boats need some what they
call it kind of
push and a wave typically doesn't have
that strength or power if it's not in a
certain depth of water so it has to be
at least 15 feet to physically work
typically yes to work effectively yes
and that may be on different boats I
mean they're not all the same so thank
you you're welcome
so can I continue Along on this another
question okay thank
you I've been a boater for over 60 years
on sun water skiing Aqua planing in the
old days sure
Etc the wake boards wake boats have come
in
recently and you've just specified that
they need a certain depth would you and
your group be cooperative to
controlling or
recommending a depth map where those
boats could effectively go you've just
said they need 15
feet so we draw a map and commissioner
dun Levy gets more money to uh enforce
it but we have those type of things now
sure and I think the problem is depth
and the wave that is created by the
shallow
depth I I have some concerns about that
in that I I don't know how you
properly get the information out to the
public number one number two I think the
minute you put a more congested number
of people into a hight trffic area it
poses danger you know like I have a
10-year-old daughter and there's moments
where she wants to go wake serving and I
have to tell her no because it's either
too busy on the water it's the wrong
time of the day there's a lot of things
as a parent that I have to think about
and if in a certain situation
where hypothetically if there was a lake
that was very shallow and had one
designed spot that was set up for depth
of water that was appropriate for
surfing in a lot of people's eyes
and then that was in the heart of the
lake and there was 10 people out there
WG surfing and you had that one person
who tap blows off which has happened in
the past um changing the stereo texting
on their phone whatever and they drive
through a congested area of water
similar to what happened to Mr Price and
a boat Travels by them at a close range
and it could cause significant damage or
injury to somebody or a boat um I think
that's why people make choices to surf
in areas that they feel is
appropriate environmentally speaking
because we all actively use these
waterways we're not Reckless people we
recognize that a lot of us have homes on
these same shorelines and most of the
time if I take my daughter surfing I'm
going in front of my mother's house
because she wants to see the kid
surf so um I think it's just there's
unintended consequences that I think can
happen with
everything thank you sorry didn't answer
your question abolutely
any other questions for our speaker
representative R thank you Mr chair and
thank you Mr W for taking my question
you made a comment earlier that I wanted
to explore um and correct me if I got it
wrong but the current 150 fet from Shore
um do you think wake boats have the same
impact on Shore at that distance as
other
boats I think that they do and through
studies we found that they have a
similar impact um I don't recall the
study exactly but when we were studying
um the definition of wake surf boats
there was a study I believe his name was
Kurt or Kirk gouty and he was an MIT
Professor he did a big study in Florida
and they had sticks in the water and
they had boats traveling at certain
speeds and different weights and and
they were able to document the level of
the water as it passed by these sticks
and showed that
a a surfing boat or the wake surf
activity 200 feet from Shore had an
exceptionally similar impact of a
traditional boat at a similar range
which is why Senate bill um Senate Bill
431 is something that we're so focused
on trying to improve and trying to bring
the light okay follow up Mr chair you
mentioned 250 feet but to but in New
Hampshire it's 150 that's safe passage
so we recognize that there's an
improvement that could be made by
extending that further along okay so um
because I I have a place at a lake and
there was a wake booat that went by my
property it was the only boat on the
lake sure totally swamped the shore sure
so I'm wondering when you made your
comments about the um rights of people
to recreate on a lake and the investment
they've made on the boats I mean I'm
there okay I enjoy it too but do you
think that should take presidence over
the Environmental Protection of the
shoreline no and I think that's why the
200 foot setback is appropriate and I
think too you know
um I think it really comes down to the
individual you know like if myself you
know I have neighbors that tube and
sometimes they're kind of Reckless and
there having fun and I recognize it's
the weekend and they're trying to have
their kids have a good time um I made a
point to cruise out there and say Hey
you know maybe we could go not in circle
so much and go a little bit deeper out
or go in a different spot um I've also
had um um a boat go by my mother's house
and it literally snapped her dock lines
and the dock lines weren't old you know
they were 38 double braided dock lines
and she called me kind of in a panic and
said hey uh one of the boat lines is
broken and it's banging off the dock and
and they weren't weight surfing so I
think it's really challenging to point
your finger at one specific activity or
one Reckless person
um we all know that you know this one
bad egg got there that's going to ruin
for everybody and that's not that's not
fair to the general public okay one one
more question Mr one more all right
thank you um so you're aware I mean
we've had a petition process in statute
for years in fact uh former US
Congressman Charlie bass was the one
that introduced it U many many years ago
um when he was a state representative or
maybe a state senator but um so this
petition process
is it's not the people on the lake that
are making the determination they're
just making a request that that be
examined by the department of safety
through a hearing
process um so do you do you trust the
department of safety to make a um a
reasonable uh resolution to that
petition whether it be dismissing it or
agreeing to it I mean do you think they
would be able ble to make a a fair
judgment if a petition were to come to
them restricting weight surfing on a
lake I do yes I mean I think they're
they're the ones that are probably the
most knowledgeable of on waterer
activities over anybody um I just going
back to your prior statement I think you
said know it's not just people on water
bodies that would petition did you just
say that I'm not trying to I don't want
to get confused uh no I'm just saying
that there would be a petition coming to
the to the Department of Safety but they
would make the judgment and I mean I've
hear your opposition to the bill but at
the end it's the department of safety
decision and is that a decision that you
would consider reasonable and valid
depending on their expertise I would yes
okay thank you thank you Mr
chair thank you representative McHugh
thank you Mr Mr chairman thank you Mr
wle for coming to share with us your
expertise we appreciate it um in regards
to those petitions and the petitions
that have been sent to the Department of
Safety before is it is it possible to
generalize and say that they're all the
same and they would you know make the
right decision every time or there might
be political pressures or divided
neighborhoods or divided Lake
Associations so my I guess my question
is um is it really possible to address
that hypothetical
question personally I would say it'd be
very challenging I think when you look
at the scope of different sizes of legs
too you know you take a lake
on I can't think off top of my head a
very small Lake but I I'll use merry
meeting Lake in Alton it's relatively
small I don't I don't know the number of
homes on it but 25 people on that L may
be
10% 25 people on Lake lisaki maybe 0.1%
you know the lakes are so unique they're
so vast it's challenging that you know
you could get 25 people on Lake Baki by
going to the marath town docks and bump
it into them on a Saturday afternoon um
I think we have to believe that at the
end of the
day our public waterways are a gift to
all the people that don't have the
luxury to own resident land or homes or
property on those waterways and to
restrict them from doing
anything this just can I feel like this
just creates a challenge down the road
for someone doesn't like tubing someone
that doesn't like water skiing someone
that doesn't like loud music on a Ponto
B I mean not the I don't waste him when
time it just it poses future challenges
follow
up thanks uh just one followup or kite
surfing ice surfing or whatever would
you believe that my one of my very best
friends a full-time resident and
property owner on Silver Lake in Madison
uh emailed me on this and he's a guy I I
trust quite a bit and he said uh a wake
boat came by and P I think he said
punctured my standup paddle board and I
haven't gotten into it the details not
sure how that could have happened um but
even he is reluctant to pit neighbor
versus
neighbor on on this would you and and
actually the solution was as you
mentioned would you believe uh that he
asked the person would you mind just not
circling between the small island right
off my property and the shoreline just
keep it outside the Cove basically and
that was a pleasant I think that's the
way to go I'll I'll leave you with this
one story my parents have a a small swim
raft my dad built back when I was a
little kid and probably 10 years into
being in the water the Alton Bay
fireworks my mother has a home at 10:00
at night when it ends everyone leaves
Alton Bay it's a basically like going
down the highway in a heavy traffic load
everyone's going basically what I would
call wake surfing speed or 10 miles hour
or less well one night a chain
broke because of that there was nobody
WG surfing at night on the July 3rd I
can promise you this was 25 years ago so
things happen wave activities happen
wind waves happen happen boat waves
happen it's if you look around on most
of our Shor lines they're Rocky from
thousands of years of wind in water
crashing against these long before any
boat was ever
introduced thank you re I just want to
make this uh announcement if anyone's
here for the bill that's supposed to
start at 11 but it won't uh
1401 about the transfer of Silver Lake
Park we've been advised that the SP
sponsor is going to ask to withdraw that
bill so you're welcome to hang around
till this hearing finishes and speak on
the bill but I thought if you're waiting
you should know that the sponsor is
going to ask to withdraw it thank you
any further questions for our
speaker seeing none thank you for your
test for your
time speaking in support of the bill
Warren
Emily Webster New Hampshire
thank you very much committee members
for the opportunity to speak before you
what I'm passing around is a map of the
lake that I am going to
address my name is Warren Emily and I
own a lakefront property on Lake wiip
pocket in
Webster I've had that property for 28
years and so I kind of know the ins and
outs of the
lake I'm here to speak in favor of this
bill
1301 and i' like to do this by sharing
our experience on Lake wiip pocket
because we can talk about things in
general terms but isn't it equally
appropriate to hear of somebody's
experience about a wake booat on a lake
lake wiip pocket in Webster is a glacial
Springfed Lake an oligotrophic
Lake uh we know it's oligotrophic
because we've been VAP participants for
the past 28 years and we test the water
on a regular basis and we have not had
any excess bacteria we've not had any
mil foil our mineral contents are steady
it's a lake you could almost drink the
water from it's a 230 acre lake so it's
a moderate size and there are of course
hundreds of lakes that qualify in the
state of New Hampshire like
that its maximum depth is 67
feet its average depth is 19
ft and I show the map around because I
want to say that the lake can be divided
depthwise into two
parts the third of this of this more
shallow end has a maximum depth of
usually 16 or so feet of course that
varies with rain and so on so forth but
it's around that onethird of the Shallow
Lake where virtually all of the
residences on the lake
exist The Watershed is very clean we
have no agriculture in the area we have
no businesses we have no
industry and so over the years the
quality of water has depended upon the
residents around the lake to make sure
their septic systems are clean and we
check on this on a regular basis um that
the vegetation around the lake is
appropriate the runoff is not excessive
from roads and so on and we've been
knock on wood remarkably successful in
this
so what's going on what's my point here
I want to bring you back a couple of
years ago actually it was the summer of
2020 we were enjoying our Lake one of
our long-term Lake owners purchased a
wake
booat a well-respected member of our
Lake Community 2020 you'll recall was
the beginning of the co we got to stay
inside we can't go anywhere we can't do
anything so I understand the reason for
maybe purchasing uh a structure like
this or um a boat like this because what
else are you going to do you're not
going to go anywhere everything's closed
the movie theaters are closed so I think
in good conscious he bought this Lake
boat because he had some teenagers and
he said you know what are they going to
do at least they're going to be around
and we can watch them and it's a nice
clean
activity so he began to run his wake
booat up and down the shallow portion of
our
Lake every time that happened uh we
around the lake experience at least one
to two foot waves crashing ing on the
shore causing the erosion all the things
that you've heard about impossible to
swim small craft was jostled or turned
over and of all things we had our one
and only cyano bacteria infective
infection in the lake that
summer uh we could argue whether or not
the Wake booat had anything to do but I
will tell you this when that wake booat
went by within minutes the wave hit the
shore and the water turned totally murky
you could not see the bottom and that
murkiness lasted for 24 36 hours no one
would go in the water to swim the
fishermen said we can't fish here and
that really was a direct result of the
scum which is carved Up From the Bottom
by the activity of the Wake
boat so I'm really making a plea here
for the size and the depth of the lake
we're talking about makes a huge
difference in terms of what these w wake
boats can inadvertently
do well that created a huge conation
among Lake owners virtually all said we
don't want these wake boats because look
what they're
doing damaging our property and
preventing us from enjoying the water
but of course the lake owner said look
you know I made all this money
investment in this boat it's great it's
safe it's out there where you can see it
it's good activity for our families and
so on and so
forth no no one could resolve the issue
it was rancorous it was tight it was
very very sad friends not talking to
friends my point is to try to resolve
something like this on a personal basis
is fraught with failure so what happened
to Lake wiip pocket the lake owner sold
his property and took his wake booat
with him and so we didn't have him on
the lake we've had an occasional visitor
wake booat in the meantime but it hasn't
really created the same upset of the
water quality that we had that
summer so my conclusions are these I
think small lakes or moderate sized
Lakes are the most vulnerable to wake
surfing activity just because of the
nature and the physics and the energy
that these boats can create and disrupt
the water and disrupt uh the surrounding
surroundings so if our experience is any
indication I want to say again leaving
the decision for should we allow should
we have a wake booat on this lake or not
is a powerless decision because it can't
be
enforced uh maybe the lake owners around
will say yeah we probably shouldn't do
this but it doesn't prevent somebody
from Massachusetts or some other City
saying hey this is a cute little Lake
let's just put our boats in and go and
we would have um the residents would
have absolutely no say in whether or not
that would happen the way things are now
like when a pocket locked out because
the owner whether he just said I can't
stand to hear my neighbors talk like
this went somewhere else whatever his
motive was bless his heart he's probably
doing the boat somewhere else but to the
benefit of the lake itself it was to our
advantage that he decided to take his
craft
elsewhere so the last thing I want to
say I believe and now it could use some
tweaking perhaps but House Bill
1301 uh I think has a potential for
solving the partisanship issue by
creating a nonbiased
commission to make a rational and
fact-based
decision about the use of wake boats on
any given water
body based on the critical factors that
are enumerated in item four in the
bill thank you very much Mr chairman I
appreciate the opportunity to give my
story and I hope that puts a real life
perspective on what lots of lakes around
the state are faced with I'm happy to
answer any questions do you have any
questions representative mchu thank you
Mr chairman thank you for coming to
share your story with us it's really
tough when the nice welcoming culture of
our Lakes region is divided with friends
not talking to
friends and essentially it sounds like
forcing this property owner to take his
leisure life elsewhere that's a shame
and I'm very sorry that happened and I
hope that those friends are friends
again and talking again and I wish on
you that that will never happen again my
question is do you think that a a a
government or or or a petition process
by the
minority of the property owners a
relatively small minority is going to
cause that same problem
again I think it potentially could yes
but creating a petition simply expresses
the thoughts of some very concerned
people it's not those people that are
going to make the decision but will able
be able to submit the issue to what I
again I said would be a dispassionate
group who can objectively look and from
the perspective both from The Boat
Owners we got to provide a place for
these Boat Owners to run their boats
because they're great fun and good
vehicles and uh entertaining at the same
time to preserve the quality of the
lakes that are most vulnerable obviously
people living around the lake and say we
don't want them on our Lake because it's
our property but we're talking about
really the future health of the lake not
just for our generation but if the uh
Lakes are really ruined ecologically
what's the future of tourism in New
Hampshire if we don't really kind of put
a framework around where these boats can
really function and not
jeopardize I think the health of the
Lakes so my point is that the um the
non-biased hopefully commission would be
able to take the numbers and decide yes
wake boats are okay here but they're not
okay
here one followup thanks for the
followup um thanks for taking the
question then it's a great point you
brought up about the Ecology of the lake
because we I think we're all generally
concerned about that um let's look at
one of those ecological issues and think
about what could banned next what about
fishing from your dock or over fishing
from your dock I mean there are per you
know limits and permits and things like
that but what if the boers don't want to
be in front of the you know caught up in
the in the fish lines or just don't want
to have to avoid them and they petition
to Outlaw fishing is that is would that
be a problem and would you how would you
feel if you had to hire a lawyer to
defend your right to fish off your dock
in front of I think I would be very
upset about that because fishing off the
dock is as old as the hills and honestly
what adverse effect does that have on
the Ecology of the
lake you know I mean we talk about lead
sinkers and all that and we've all
abided by that pretty much that's just
common sense but when an activity really
jeopardizes the health of the lake in a
long-term way I think that's a different
issue especially when there are places
where these amazing Vehicles could be
used in a more ecologically friendly
way representative of a
thank you Mr chair um I just have a
quick question and that's of do you know
of lakes or ponds where wake surfing or
wake boats are already
banned I do
not I think the uh gentleman speaking
before me said that there are no
restrictions at the present time in any
body of water in the state of New
Hampshire for the use of Lake boats
that's that's what I heard the answer to
your question is no I don't know of any
thank you for taking my question
representative run thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
you described a it seemed like a
prolonged period of time on lake wiip
lake wiip pocket where residents were
having some serious conflicts um do you
think that if this bill were to pass and
residents were able to P petition the
department of safety for a hearing and
have um what Mr Wally agreed would be a
uh reasonable and fair decision that it
would have truncated the period of
conflict and and maybe emotions wouldn't
have gotten so so severe I would
appreciate your definition of the word
truncated before okay well for instance
if it had taken let's say two seasons of
conflict with a neighbor um do you think
if this bill were to pass and Neighbors
from the from the onset were able to
petition the department of safety for a
hearing that having the conflict only
maybe be for you know a few months a
year at the most before an objective uh
decision was rendered that it would have
been easier for those neighbors to abide
by that or at least have less harsh
feelings against each other I think
people would still have their own
feelings about wake boats and activity
but if it were prescribed by law that
they were not wake Boats were not
permitted on a certain body of water it
would take away in great measure the uh
backstabbing and the snide comments
because people would say well this is
what I really think it's like politics
you talk politics but can still go out
and drink a cup of coffee afterward but
this is the law and this is what we're
going to need to abide by I think it
would really
amarate uh in the long run the
rangerous discussions that otherwise
people would have especially if one of
those individuals owned the Wake boat
that creates
a it creates a a mix of constant
conflict I'll see it that way thank you
very
much any other questions for our
speaker seeing none thank you very much
for your
testimony next to speak in opposition
Jody grimus NH hmta
Jody
thank you very much I'm G to kind of
talk and speak if that's okay uh for the
record my name is jod grimus I work with
for the record my name is Jody grimus
and I work with the New Hampshire Marine
trades Association as well as the water
sport industry Association that are here
in opposition to this bill um since the
posting of this hearing I have been
Fielding as you I'm sure calls and
emails from very frantic families who
fortunately cannot be here today because
they are working um about their concerns
about this bill so I have taken the
Liberty
of printing out their testimony there's
about 200 letters here I couldn't get to
them all there would be more I would try
to do that over the
weekend um just to make sure that it
their comments and their testimony and
their opposition is held and there are a
lot of New Hampshire families there are
a few from Massachusetts and other
states but
predominantly they are New Hampshire
families why are they so
concerned can we talk about about that
hearing process for a minute um that
hearing process is in statute is in
statute for certain things it is in
statute for um whether or not you want
to look at a particular body of water
and not have petroleum Motors on it
maybe it's an electric motor paddle
board pedal craft kind of
Lake um maybe it's a no wake zone if
there is a sensitive area on a lake body
that is concerned about wakes I would
suggest they go through the no wake zone
petition because that packs all boats
not just one doesn't single out any type
of activity it deals with one boat uh
one one for all
boats in talking and looking up the
petition
process the Bureau of hearings does more
than just watercraft type hearings the
Bureau of hearings handles all of the
motor vehicle um statutes and rules and
hearings at the Department of Safety
if you look at the
bill this bill
prioritizes commissioner shall hear all
petitions as soon as possible after they
are submitted when will they be
submitted when will they be heard will
they be heard in the December time frame
January time frame because those no wake
zones by law required to be in June July
August so that people are there this
doesn't have that requirement so you
could have these hearings in February
when nobody's around nobody has any idea
what's happening
again second you are asking the
commissioner to give these hearings the
priority so is it a priority over the
DWI hearing the hearing at the
department of safety for fatal accidents
for youth operator problems for reckless
operation are we going to
prioritize the petition to take
law-abiding citizens off a body of water
is that more important than those
alcohol uh DWI interlock ignition
hearings Etc there are a lot of hearings
that are done at the department of
safety this being the priority I would
question and I would ask your
consideration looking at the department
of safety's hearings in 2023 there was
one hearing relative to a
petroleum-based motor um question on a
body of water one I can tell you this es
with what I saw on the online testimoni
of 650 people opposed and 388 supported
I would suggest you're going to have a
lot of hearings that are all of a sudden
going to get prioritized over anything
else in 2022 there were six hearings
relative to watercraft three on Moorings
two on rafting and one
on something else SE
planes so I would suggest and I have
spoken with the commissioner's office
they are not prepared to take on this
bill they do not have the resources I
would asked that you might want to talk
to them about whether or not there's a
fiscal note required for this bill
because it is a significant change in
what the department of safety Bureau of
hearings has to do again they do not
just deal with watercraft hearings I
would hope they would prioritize that
reckless driver in suspending their
license over
this um again a lot of people could not
come today
I'm sorry about that they're very sorry
they're very nervous about it um I think
you have to think about a lot of things
when it comes to Safe passage do you
know that New Hampshire has one of the
the broadest safe passage laws in the
country Most states have 100 foot safe
passage some have less than that they
have all the same boating but New
Hampshire does we have 150 I think
Vermont has 200 there's a couple of
other states that have stronger if you
want to talk about safy passage let's
talk about safe passage for all boats
stop singling out one activity and you
really can't single out one boat even as
the Department of Environmental Services
said because quite honestly you can wake
surf behind a lot of different boats
I'll bring pictures it is not just one
toe booat it can be a lot of different
boats so there's a lot of issues that I
think still and I'll follow up in
writing with any other questions that
may have but when it comes to as as
prior testimony disturbing the sentiment
of the bottom anybody that brings up an
anchor takes up half the lake bottom
with them everybody that takes up an
anchor takes up the bottom of the lake
so are we going to stop boating are we
going to stop anchoring are we going to
keep singling out where does it stop
again a lot of families are very
concerned about what this bill is going
to do to their Recreation their time
frame everybody works hard they like
little enjoyment it's their their mental
health break and we're going to take
that away so please oppose the bill I
will leave this for you I will follow up
with anything else in writing and I
appreciate your time there's a lot of
other people behind me so I'll leave it
at that you take
question does anyone have a
question representative
Ron thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um at
the beginning of your remarks you
mentioned about um that this B may
require or may may hold public hearings
in the winter when many residents aren't
aware that um there is a hearing that
may impact their ability to use a wake
booat but you brought us a whole stack
of testimony on this bill and we're in
the end of January and I'm wondering
wouldn't these people know about a
hearing if they knew about this hearing
I don't know that to be the case quite
honestly ly um it's taken a lot of
effort to try to let as many people know
that this is taking place this hearing
do I know that they're going to know
about a little lake or some Lake
somewhere I don't know that I don't have
the ability to track all of that okay
follow up M um and I I just mainly
comment these are all printouts of
online testimony we can see that so you
could have saved a lot of paper that's
okay I just I had gotten frantic calls
saying will they look at that and I go I
have no idea I don't know if if members
go into the online testimony system all
the time or not I think it depends on
the member so quite honestly I want I
I'm doing my fair share no I I
appreciate it it's just most of these
only have one sentence on them so it's
uh just want I I do go into online
testimony and uh just one more question
when when you're talking about the the
boats or possible regulation of boats
depending on the outcome of a hearing
with the Department of Safety do you see
a difference between the impact of a
wake boat compared to other
boats no because
again there can be folks driving other
types of boats that are not doing so
appropriately and can create impact so
whether
it's uh the cabin crews are going by the
this the that um there's a million
different things that we have all seen
on our Lakes where people are just not
operating appropriately that can cause
impact and so if they're not currently
obeying the current laws we need to
educate them and we need to give Marine
Patrol the ability to enforce those are
the issues that we need to address
versus picking out individual sports or
boats for this type of restruction okay
thank you Mr chair any other questions
for our speaker yeah
thank you for your testimony do you have
excuse me do you have copy of your of
your
testimony thank
you speaking in support of the
bill I hope I say your last name
correctly Colleen toret
Colleen good morning um I just wanted to
express my concern um on Arlington pond
in Salem New
Hampshire um Arlington Pond is very long
very narrow Lake um there's only like
one really big part of the lake that you
can
actually ski safely because of the
activity that we have there's so many
people out in the summer especially with
the co um everybody wants to be outside
and I agree and I love activity and I
love seeing everybody out having fun the
only problem with our leag is that the
depth of our leag is has an average of
10 feet so I went around with my son's
uh fishing boat and I put the depth
binder on and everywhere where the boats
go mostly and I don't know if people
have their look at their dep HS but
you're looking at five feet so a regular
boat you know can handle that but with
the ballister um the boat drops and as
you know those boats I can hold the
water which makes the boat go down so
that they make the big waves for the
wake surfing which is what they want
they want the big wake um to have fun
and which is awesome but I just think on
Allington fond we're experiencing a lot
we have the Sino bacteria Bloom um we're
really seeing a lot more erosion and I
just think that they should look at the
lakes that they go on and and just find
the lake that is
deeper that can handle the lodge
waves and not dragging on the bottom
because every lake has Sun bacteria
Bloom but they're disturbing it and we
didn't get to swim all last summer but
yet the boats were still out there I
have videos that they were still out
there because it's a choice you can swim
in a lake if there's nobody saying you
can't go out and swim with sign now
bacteria Bloom but by choice you know we
didn't because you know I don't want to
take a chance but you know they were all
still out there we have five or six
boats at a time and it's absolutely
impossible for them to stay at least 150
feet from Shore because our lake is so
narrow and we don't have the depth
because it's you can go around and
anyone on the lake can go around the
only part of our Lake actually is deep
is the center that would mean one boat
at a time could go down the center of
our Our Lake because it's 20
feet and then over by the DM but again
we have numerous like people are out I
mean people are anchoring like you said
um you know people trying to do other
things as well so it's it's becoming
unsafe as well they can't handle Arley
can't handle it and I feel bad because I
have people and I don't want to cause
problems like I have on our Lake that
our friends that have these types of
Vats it's just that unfortunately our
lake is too it's not deep
enough and that's all I would like to
say thank you any questions for the
speaker representative R thank you Mr
chair um did you know that Arlington M
Pond also serves as a municipal drinking
water source for the town of Salem and
that if blooms are encouraged in the
lake um either through sediment
disruption or erosion or other means of
having phosphorus enter the lake that it
um demands an immediate cessation of
that water draw and the town of Salem
has to go to other sources for their
Municipal Water our lake is a secondary
source keny lake is a primary we also
have a h pipeline that comes from
Manchester New Hampshire which supplies
water so um they take our water but they
don't necessarily use it it goes into a
treatment plant before
it is ever it goes directly into like a
treatment PL does not go directly into
anyone's
drinking are you aware that that
treatment may not remove cyanotoxins
that may be present in the water I can't
speak for the town of Salem but I um
I don't know the answer to that question
I just know that our pond is a it is a
manmade pond and it was brought that we
are a secondary water source but again
we have the pipeline coming from manesa
New Hampshire so I don't know how much
they use it but we are still considered
a um secondary water source so it's up
to the town of Salem which they are um
addressing this issue as well we are
working
watered and stuff like that but um as
far as you know the depth of our pond is
the biggest concern because every lake
has thel bacteria blooms I just think
the boats need they need I think um it
was brought up before they need at least
feet I just want to repeat again for
those that might have come in um for the
11:00
hb401 f
about the Silver Lake Park Transfer the
sponsor of that bill is going to ask to
withdraw it so if you're waiting for
that I thought you'd like to know you
can stay and speak but the sponsor is
going to withdraw
1401 when we get to it after this
hearing next speaking in
opposition Ethan helier water sports
industry Association
Ethan
thank you chairman and members of the
committee my name is Ethan helier and I
serve as a Midwest government Affairs
manager for the water sports industry
Association wsa is the leading voice in
toad water sports we work to strengthen
and Grill boating as well as uh protect
the interests of recreational boers
across the country we develop best
practices maintain Waterway access
rights as well as educate and PR promote
safety for those on the water such as
wake surfing wsa represents over 450
member companies which include the
manufacturers of boats Marine Engines
marine accessories as well as dealers
throughout the United States today I
voice my concern in opposition to house
built 1301 this bill threatens Granite
sater's rights to its public Waters wsa
believes that focusing on Boer Ed and
supporting the New Hampshire Marine
Patrol is a logical and fiscally
appropriate approach to enhancing safety
on the water in fact the State
of the State of New Hampshire is a
leader in proactive safe boating
practices the wsa is Wake responsibly
education initiative has been adopted
throughout the granite state and even
appears on voter registration renewals
this message focuses
on responsible operating and courteous
behavior for all those who enjoy the
water wake responsibility is supported
by boers marinas and dealers alike wake
responsibly also focuses on forging
Partnerships with State Marine law
enforcement posting and maintaining the
signage at boat ramps as well as
engaging with community members through
dealers at other means integrating the
simple uh education based changes into
everyday boating makes all the
difference in conclusion uh the Water
Sports industry Association believes
that house bill 1301 threatens to
inhibit public access to the state
waters and does not uh appropriately
address or increase water safety I urge
you to consider uh opposing this
legislation thank you and I'll stand for
any questions any questions for the
speaker representative Iran thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question this is the same question I
asked Mr um Wall-E but do you think that
a decision should should the residents
um be successful in submitting a
petition for a hearing with the
Department of Safety do you believe the
department of safety can make a
reasonable and fair judgment on any
restrictions to wake boats in a body of
water chairman of members I do trust law
enforcement however I would say and one
of my larger concerns with this bill is
just creating a patchwork Statewide um I
don't like to speak in anecdotes but I'm
going to throw one out here really
quickly uh say we all live on a block
the speed limits 30 miles an hour and
there's someone that comes by every day
at 45 are we going to lower that speed
limit to 15 or are we going to put up
one of those signs that says your speed
maybe pull this person over have a
conversation I think it's best to focus
on you know educating that driver or
Boer as opposed to having these
patchworks pop up around the
State okay thank you thank
you representative
wolf do you think that there is a
possibility
of
a hate to use the word
restriction but uh of a place of use so
that we don't go into this Pat for quilt
of Regulation that but it is a
Statewide educational looking at the
science of where it is and having the
same thing same rules Statewide as
opposed
to individual Lakes chairman of members
yeah I you know your current law I
believe is 150 foot offset so any part
of the lake that's less than 300 feet
you know wide they shouldn't be you know
operating there at all um as the water
sports industry Association we are in
favor of 200
we've done two peerreview research
studies that have shown that if you're
if you're 200t or more from Shore um
you're going to have the same impact as
a wind driven
wake one follower have you done any
studies in regard to depth chairman
members uh no there's no current study
on that right now um in one of the peer
reviewed studies generally he said um
this is one that was um made by Endicott
Fay uh and he said in his study that um
as long as you're within 10t or more
deeper of water um you know generally um
his modeling says that you know you're
in deep enough water and I I would say
on that too is that it's important to
recognize as other speakers have have
said that there's no recreational
benefit to being in shallow water
there's no recreational benefit to carve
the shoreline you know generally
speaking wake Surfers are just looking
for space to be able to do their
activity
so to someone who I would see in shallow
water I I would just as a fellow Boer I
would just you know recommend to them
hey you should you should go out farther
in the lake it's just you're going to
have a better experience and I I
generally think most of them know
that thank you thank you any more
questions I don't see any do you have a
copy of your testimony uh Mr chairman
members I will get uh copies of this
thank you make sure you guys have
it and thank you for your testimony
thank you speaking in support of the
bill Autumn O'Brien
Autumn hi thank you I too live on
Arlington Pond um and we actually
established a water shed committee this
year because last year during the season
we had over 119 days that we were unable
to swim in Arlington Pond due to Sino
bacteria so as you can imagine there was
only about a two- we period throughout
the whole summer that did not have an
advisory people do still choose to swim
which is their choice unfortunately for
pets it's an issue children it's an
issue and so it is a real concern of
ours and the reason that prompted this
committee during the time of this
committee since the end of last summer
we have been reviewing all kinds of
information to try and help us with the
CYO bacteria issue and what is the best
thing that we can do for our Lake one
thing that has repeatedly come up and
again there are a lot of studies out out
there in regards to wakeboards and what
that does to the environment with
erosion on the shore and so forth and
I'm sure I think I've heard some earlier
say that there are also studies that
there aren't any impact um as the
gentleman mentioned earlier I can only
speak to my experience as a resident of
Arlington Pond um Colleen earlier told
you that our pond is uh very it's small
it's a 269 ACR body of water I believe
but most of the areas are 300 feet on
average in areas from sh to shore we
also have several islands and Lon
Sanctuary um the problem is that the
area is not big enough for these boats
as well as she mentioned earlier the
average depth being 10 feet there are
areas that are 39 ft but I too have a
depth binder so we go around and look at
the depth of the lake it has and is
causing issues between neighbors um
because we do have like probably every
Community social media where people go
on and say this one did this this one
had loud noise this one went too fast
Etc and there is a lot to be said for
wanting each resident to be able to make
an educated decision on the way that
they operate a watercraft or a boat how
they bring their guest out who they
allow to use their boats unfortunately
ly we do not have a lot of that and when
one side is trying to educate the other
side and they're very passionate about
their opinions it does cause conflict so
the reason that I am in support of this
is as are other people in the room in
support is because I don't feel that
it's my job as a resident of the lake to
determine who should and should not be
able to use what they can on the lake um
we can use our experience I know that
people have had to to replace their
walls I know that the island is much
smaller the large island is eroded all
the way around um in the past few years
where as wake boards have become more
popular so we can only attest to what we
see ourselves in our own Community I
would like to see it so that as a
resident we are able to petition the
state to look further into this issue
which is I assume what started though
I'm not educated on the ban of one and
two Cedar watercraft on certain bodies
of lake under so many 75 Acres or
whatever it is Arlington Pond is one of
those Lakes where we cannot purchase or
use those type of watercrafts on our
lake so at some point there were people
on our Lake that were certainly opposed
to getting rid of those and then there
were people that were in favor of
getting rid of those but ultimately by
the state establishing guidelines future
generations and the people today no one
is arguing no one is inclin conflict no
one has problems with the law that says
we are not allowed to have these types
of watercrafts on our body of water so
if this bill then allows us as a
community to reach out and establish
future laws we may all be in Conflict
now but two years from now five years
from now if the state decides on this we
won't have that conflict and myself just
like many others that are opposed and in
favor of this bill we want to protect
our I of water I mean not living on a
lake and paying what we pay for our
lakefront homes and the taxes and the
upkeep and everything we're doing to not
be able to use or swim in our Lakes for
90% of our season is problematic and
without changes happening in every area
of protecting the environment that is
going to continue to happen more and
more and more so that we really won't be
concerned about what type of things are
on our Lake because we won't be able to
use them as we have in the past and so
they'll become bodies of water like
canaby Lake Park which is our drinking
source that has no swimming in it so
again I'm only speaking for my personal
um experiences on our lington that is a
smaller body of water that has a very
low depth and I have would not be able
to tell the difference on the wake
boards on our Lake of whether it's 10
feet or 100 feet because the weights are
still the same they're still huge and
they're still bashing into the waters
the walls they're still hitting the
small children on the shore and causing
them to move um it's become a safety
issue as well as a environmental issue
on our Lake thank you any questions for
our
speaker Mr Wolf represent wolf have you
uh talked to Marine Patrol about the
distances as Marine Patrol ever come
over to look at that we do have Marine
Patrol they're not out as much as they
were in previous years um they do pull
people over for a lot of different
things we've certainly had again because
of social media almost everybody in the
community is aware as soon as a Marine
Patrol bro boat is brought into the lake
uh because it spreads like wildfire so
everyone behaves while they're there
it's just the way that the world is so
but of course people are I shouldn't say
all people because on our Lake in
particular we have 200 300 Lakefront
residents and right now there's I think
13 houses being built on our lake so we
are having a lot of new people come into
our Lake that take the class and for the
six hours at the fire station and all of
a sudden they're they're they have the
nicest boat and they're coming out here
and they're wake surfing we would love
to be able to enforce that more but
quite frankly we do not have P Marine
Patrol there often enough to do that
which causes yet another conflict
between the
residents any other questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony I have seven cards left of all
people opposed to the bill your time
goes from one minute to five minute um I
want all of you to have an opportunity
to speak but can you please not repeat
what other people say
I'd appreciate that and um if you can
hold to your time would all appreciate
that too so first up oppose KL jger
Carl how you doing
everybody uh I also live on owton pond
uh but I oppose the bill uh number of
items I wanted to kind of point out uh
the 25 residents are Property Owners
everybody keeps talking residents but it
also says Property Owners uh I do know
there's a few people on the lake that
have a lot of properties so one person
could actually
represent more than one vote of trying
to get uh a commission to take a look at
it so I think that's incorrect uh one
vote one person should be one vote I
also think 25 is a very low number um to
go
after and then in the line of I I know
it was disgusted and I'll just say it
quick you only are going to notify
people on the lake or deed people uh for
years I lived down in Connecticut I did
was didn't live on a lake I drove my
boat to I tow my boat to uh a water body
to actually do the enjoyment on it uh
those people aren't actually going to
get notified of the
hearing so kind of question that piece
of it uh the another one is really the
bill is only going to get addressed at
small lakes uh sunap or Winn pasak if
someone were to push it 25 people were
to push it they would have to
notify everybody every person on that
lake with a certified letter that's a c
ly timec consuming effort it's likely
not to happen yet at the same time if
you look at a sunup or Winn pasak
there's a lot of little CES on that Lake
little Coes that could be the same size
as Arlington Pond those Coes are going
to see the same they're going to see
boats in there so but the likelihood
that this thing is going to get a
Committee hearing on a wiip basaki or
sunap is really low I would suspect just
because of the effort to try to notify
every person on that
Lake um
and then the bill talks about
commissioner it doesn't talk about a
committee it talks about a commissioner
making a decision so when as I read the
bill it's one person making that
decision and one person is difficult you
know you can now get political
situations involved or personal
situations to make a decision that if
that commissioner happens to live on the
lake and doesn't doesn't have a doesn't
wake surf he might say oh no problem
what is you know there's with that I
look at the rules as to what the
commissioner should look at you know
it's it's water size it's its depth but
it doesn't give any definition of what
that is is it you know 10 feet is it
something that is 500 feet apart it it
it leaves it very much open to one
person's opinion versus another person's
opinion to make the decision if you're
going to have have a rule it should have
specific items specific you know noise
level in DBS wave wave height in
feet uh instead of just general because
it just makes it
difficult and then in the line of if I
say I get 25 people or I get a commiss I
get a hearing and it rules against
me do I get to go just put in another
request
a day later and ask for another hearing
and ask for another hearing and ask for
another hearing wait until the
commissioner changes ask for another
hearing until I get the answer I want to
get there's not there's nothing to stop
someone from constantly reasing the
commission to review the same Lake now
if you if you're GNA allow that then can
you know someone with a that wakes surf
ask the commission multiple times over
and over and over and over to revise the
revise the
Restriction so something to think
about and then as I said I live in
Arlington Pond we moved up my wife and I
moved up she's also in support of uh not
in support of this bill uh we moved up
like four years ago we researched the
lakes in New Hampshire to find a lake
that allowed no water sports we wanted
and the size of the lake we wanted there
is lakes in New Hampshire like canopy
that doesn't allow water sports uh you
can't swim in the lake so it's really
difficult to wake surf uh we moved up
here we bought a house hundreds of
thousands of dollars and we do have a
wakeboarding boat and it would be
extremely upsetting if suddenly we
couldn't use that in the way we want to
use that and I'll say it's my wife and I
were're both retired wake surfing is a
sport I'm going to say good for old
people people uh it is it is the boat
goes 10 miles an hour the water is soft
at 10 miles an hour as our bodies are
getting older and I'm sitting here in a
brace uh what I can do you know an older
person can do wake surfing is very
non-challenging on the body where wake
boarding water skin tubing is very
difficult if you're to ban wake surfing
on the lake my use at a lake other than
puts and around and looking at pretty
houses is gone that's that's the main
thing I do on the lake is wake
surfing uh and add in a line of the wave
size I have an older boat one of the
earlier gentlemen said wake surfing
started back in the 50s or 60s when
there was small boat smaller boats I
have a 2004 wake surfing boat if I fill
my ballast all up my wake is way smaller
than a new wake boarding boat that's
bigger a bigger boat puts out with no
ballast on so they just drive around and
they can create a bigger weight than my
wake boarding boat does when I have all
the ballasts in and I can wake surf
totally fine behind it um so Banning an
entire
sport again is is really discriminating
against someone with an older boat or
someone even with a newer boat that
doesn't put all the ballast in uh you
know you get someone with a little kid
out there they they need very little
wake for that little child to wake surf
all of a sudden you're going to ban that
child from wake surfing behind a you
know a wave that's one or two feet tall
um so that's where I said if you were to
do something you should Define what is a
biger too big a
wave
um and then I you know in the line of
buying the house if you were to do
something you should kind of grandfa
Grandfather homeowners in or boat owner
in uh you know like like I said we moved
out of state up here we love New
Hampshire uh we spent hundreds of
thousand dollars on a house we have a
boat uh some of these boats mine not but
some of these boats go as high as 150
plus, for these boats all of a sudden
one day I'm not going to be able to use
that boat for the entertainment I want
to use it
for and I will also say we're talking
wake surfing you know there's a lot of
people commenting on wake board
boats but the boat can create the wave I
can put a bigger boat on the lake and I
can create as big a wave or bigger wave
than even you know the wake surfing
boats there's nothing to restrict how
big a boat do I put a 30 foot boat on
the on the
lake let's see uh I think
that's probably everything I all my
points thank you anybody have a question
for this
speaker s seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you you have a copy of
your testimony sir sir yeah uh do you
have a to to your testimony you wish
should submit a copy of this if you'd
like that would be fine that just to you
uh just pass it
up it's for the record thank
you speaking against Lori ball
Lori
good morning my name is Lori ball I'm
the representative state representative
from Salem I also live on Arlington Pond
which I understand was the Catalyst um
to this
bill uh thank you for allowing me to
speak I oppose this bill it reminds me
of the culture differences when we first
started with snowboarders and people
didn't want snowboarders on the mountain
because they were going to ruin the
mountain so it was snowboarders versus
skers while I commend the um the bill
and its efforts to protect the
environment I have a lot of concerns
with how the bill is
written I do agree that it pits one
neighbor against the
other
um we have been on the lake for 18
years we've been wake surfing on the
lake for 18
years and in those 18 years I only seen
a problem in the last couple years last
few years with one or two residents who
have much larger boats that put out a
much larger wake our boat does not do
that I will mention that when we
purchased our home uh 18 years ago and
we have 450 ft of Waterfront including a
Sandy Beach we had no erosion on the
actually I take that back when I
purchased it inside the bulkhead there
was a lot of erosion there were no
wakeboard boats on the on the lake at
that time only pontoon
boats we remedied that by digging out
behind the bulkhead and putting in rip
wrap so the water could come through and
filter back out we've not had any
erosion we live across from the island
that they're talking about we are on the
largest section of the lake we get the
most pounding including our beach no
erosion I get more erosion in the winter
from the wind that blows all the sand
across my
yard um another thing is Arlington Pond
was mentioned that we are a dam so our
water is lowered every year exposing all
the edges to wind throughout the winter
months so that causes erosion as
well which is why we end up with these
um conflicts between neighbors because
we all see things
differently I have a concern with this
bill because it allows Property Owners
within the town not the property owners
who AB but the lake but everyone in the
town can put forward this
petition and it can be put forward by
residents though that means anybody who
rents so again like the last gentleman
said if you have one person that owns a
large number of properties they can
easily put together 25 people they don't
even have to live on the lake it could
be a person who owns an apartment
building five miles away from the lake
and they can put in a petition to ctail
the activities on the lake even though
it has nothing to do with them they
could be doing it at a spite because
Arlington Pond does not have Public
Access so there's a reason for them to a
motivation for them to do that the idea
that 25 people plus one can stop an
activity on the lake is really
disheartening to
me uh the door more importantly it
opens uh the bill more importantly opens
the door for more bills being filed
against other activities on the lake as
I mentioned Arlington Pond gets lowered
in the winter time so that means 25
people can come up here and say we say
we want to put in another bill but this
time we want to curtail uh snowmobiling
because after all the snowmobiles have
to go up and down the sides of the lake
and that's going to cause um the
embankments to become
eroded after that you'll have someone
come in and say we want to stop fishing
because do you know how many birds we
find stuck in the fishing lines all
along the trees along the
islands because the fishing line is
thrown it gets caught in the trees then
we find the um the blue herring was
caught in one and died so we'll have
other people coming in and saying
there's another environmental reason to
now curtail the activities on the lake I
just believe that this bill opens the
CLE worms that we don't want to
open the bill is also at odds because
it the the petition can go can come in
from anyone on the lake but then only
those within the quarter mile of the
lake are even aware that the petition is
happening but what if you did have
people who live on the other side of the
ra of the
town and they use a lake as well then
they would not be know that this is
going on because they would not be
notified I find the bill vague because
it doesn't lay out the parameters that
the commissioner is going to um consider
what are the guidelines and it doesn't
it doesn't give you any of that but
pleasa doesn't refer you to where to go
find that information so you're kind of
shooting arrows in the dark and people
are throwing in petitions they don't
know even if things are um the way
they're supposed to be or or not the way
they're supposed to
be it also concerns me that I'm just
wondering when it comes to all of these
petitions and all of these hearings
what's becoming secondary if this
becomes the primary that the
commissioner is going to be looking at
what's being put on the side what's not
what hearings are not taking place
the biggest thing that I find with this
bill honestly is we're focusing on an
activity wake
surfing when the reality is what I'm
hearing is people are trying to say it's
the waves that are causing the
problems so stopping the wake surfing
doesn't eliminate the waves we're still
going to have the people on the lake
with the big boats creating the big
waves
and given that um with today's
technology and the fact that these
people are paying well over $100,000 for
their boats I think someone is going to
come up with a really good idea on how
to use that wave in another way that
doesn't fall under wake surfing so I
think then you're going to be back here
again to try and figure out okay well
now what do we do they're not wake
surfing but we still have these three
and four foot waves coming in so this
bill really doesn't address what's at
the heart of the issue
with that being said I'd like to say
that I would I would not I would oppose
this
bill I I commend its intent but I don't
think it's ready for prime time I think
an alternative would be as I've heard
from many people we need more Marine
Patrol we only have a small few number
of people that are not abiding by the
rules that are causing problems on lakes
we should not be punishing everyone
thank
you you have any questions
representative rung thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative ball for
taking my question um in some of your
comments I I'm wondering if you um are
familiar that this type of a bill has
been in statute for probably over 40
years um where and then and in Statue
currently it it allows just 10 residents
to petition and it has to do with um
individual uh motor watercraft so this
isn't a new thing um and and also those
petitioners don't make the decision all
they're doing is petitioning the
department of safety to hold a hearing
and you had also commented and and I'm
not sure if if you're aware but you
mentioned that it needs parameters um
those are listed in um page two lines
24 through 30 uh through uh line one of
the following page it encompasses
everything the impact to the environment
and Wildlife the surface area the
uses that have been established for the
lake but another component that's part
of the hearing is the necessity of
ensuring access to and use of the lake
Pond and River for all individuals and
the right of those individuals to
appropriate use of the public Waters so
um my question is all that in
consideration do you believe that the
department of safety can make a
reasonable and fair J judgement at that
hearing I don't want to say anything bad
against the department of safety but the
squeaky wheel gets the oil so if the
same person keeps repeating and they
keep bringing it back and back and back
eventually things are going to go their
way the parameters that I'm talking
about is there's nothing in here to say
exactly what the depth of the water is
that we're looking for um which would be
also very difficult because as
previously with Arlington was stated the
average depth is 9 ft but what they're
forgetting or what they not saying is we
have three four five I don't know how
many CES of very shallow water with no
wake zones that nobody ever goes into so
now you throw that into the average and
it throws everything off also it was
mentioned um about the um disturbing the
bottom of the lake well rising and
lowering the dam disturbs it too because
we keep going up and down um as the lake
you know Rises and lowers so all that 10
ft along the lake is now exposed so I
mean there's just as much toxins and
whatever on those 10 ft but that all is
now exposed to the Sun or the air um
also it was brought up they think that
this might cause some of the problems
with the CYO bacteria but what was not
mentioned is that we have drain uh storm
drains around around our Watershed that
deposit directly into our Lake which is
why I put forward the um restrictions on
phosphorus because of the number of
homes that are in our Watershed that
there's no setbacks and all the um
fertilizer with phosphorus can then get
into the storm drains and come directly
and drop into our lake so we have not
had a Lake management uh plan done yet
we don't know why we have the Cino
bacteria we don't know what's causing it
and my um fear is that we are using this
as a method or someone is deciding that
it must be the wake surfing is causing
the Sino bacteria but there's so many
other um things that could be in there
we don't know what it is yet and I think
this is a little bit premature um
because we have no data to say that
that's what's causing our problem in our
Lake okay just to follow up Mr shair
yeah
so what I hear you saying is that if uh
multiple petitions come up to the
Department of Safety you would think
that eventually they would not make a
reasonable and fair decision I'm not
saying anything because I don't know the
people and I don't know how it works I'm
just saying that I think it's going to
take up a lot of their time I think that
um and I don't be honest with you the
research is not there there's so much
conflicting research that whoever shows
you know the most amount of research I
guess it just nothing has been
determined yet as to what is causing our
Sino bacteria problem nobody's in
agreement as to what the wake boards um
or the wake surfing does and as I said
our boat we've been doing it for 18
years
um we have we have a much smaller wake
so I think if you wanted to really and I
I don't even Advocate this but I mean
restrict the size of the wakes not this
not the sport that's being um done
because I just think that another sport
will come along that could use the big
wake and we're going to be sitting right
back here again so deal with the problem
not with um the secondary issue which
would be the wake surfing okay thank you
anyone else have a question to the
speaker don't see any thank you very
much for your
testimony excuse me do you have a copy
of your testimony I'll send it in okay
if you would Jim ball same
address so Lori told me about this
proposed bill I don't know a little over
a month ago I'll get to this speaker by
the way Jim ball sale New Hampshire
living on on 18 years as Lori mentioned
not as long as Tom 40 something plus
right anyhow uh when I first heard about
the bill I said that doesn't make sense
doesn't you know seem like it's ready
for prime time because you're conflating
a sport wake surfing to boat waves which
might have an impact on the sh Line and
other things like cob bacteria etc etc
and um you know it just seems to me that
it's you know to use a legal ter
arbitrary and capricious you pick one
sport that uses a big weight maybe
sometimes to do the sport but maybe
sometimes not to do the sport and you
don't consider the other wave activity
on the on the lake that also occurs at
the same height of waves so let me go
back up if I'm I'm a wake Bard wake
Surfer while the extreme sports on the
lake and uh like Lori said you know when
we first moved there we had some
Shoreline damage we wrecked up fight it
the 18 years we've been living on there
was one of the first wakeboard boats on
the lake um since then we haven't
noticed any particular damage to our
property now you know certainly I'm
concerned this includes docks boats boat
lines whips you know kayaks that are you
know hanging out by the beach etc etc so
you know that was my observation my
anecdotal information on what I saw in
terms of Shoreline damage but you know
not being an expert on the subject I
wanted to go in and really explore the
research on it and it was kind of
interesting when I uh looked into it is
conflicting research just like we see
everywhere today um one group I'll you
pick the name CR Club is really against
wake surfing they say it has devastating
impact on the shoreline and other
reports by another Industry Group says
just the opposite I'll give you two
examples we talked about C bacteria and
the Wake disturbing the soil phosphorous
coming up causing more of a sinac CIA
problem it's possible it says could in
all the articles but there's no proof of
it but there's also information that a
deep wave also churns up the water
stratification in the pond you know
giving more oxygen to the lower levels
and actually causing a healthier bottom
and a better environment so that you
don't have cob bacteria so when I did
the research I saw one report saying
this and a conflicting report saying
that so I kind of wanted to go to see if
there are any kind of unbiased
peerreview research reports and there
are there's a bunch of them I have one
here from the University of Minnesota
where they looked at 460 lakes in a
variety of environments deep Lakes big
lakes lakes with you know different Co
sizes different depths different types
of boats different speeds different uh
you know orientations where they have
ballast bags or uh the different um
hydraulic weight shaping things that
they have now in the expensive boats etc
etc and the bottom line of it all is
that they kind of cancel each other out
there's no
definitive um information saying that
wake surfing as a sport or big wave
driven by wake surfing
boats um is really the thing that causes
all these issues in fact when you go and
research what causes the most damage to
shorelines at lakes and rivers Etc they
don't even talk about boat waves it's
all about runoff vegetation being
removed all those types of things rather
than the waves now waves can contribute
but are they the make contributor and do
in fact you want to take a
contributor and cause all s of Havoc to
the recreational capabilities on the
lake people's housing values tourism
industry jobs all those kind of things
it doesn't seem like there's real
balance going on here to look at all the
pros and cons and unintended
consequences that uh come apart of
actually Banning something or being able
to ban something with a 25 person
petition so you know I guess my
experience my recommendation my research
you know brings me to the point where um
you I think we really have to look into
doing a lot more research on Lake
specific orientations every Lake
Topography is different big lakes with
Coes shallow Lakes lots of vegetation
lakes with steep Banks all those kind of
things and see what the real villain is
here that's causing all this damage and
not necessarily picking out a sport that
um you know is really the fastest
growing sport in the industry it's
growing at 10% per year it's a $2.5
billion industry going to five billion
in like another five years um and I I
kind of agree with Lori it kind of feels
like 40 years ago when I started
snowboarding the traditional skiers
hated it they wanted to kick all the
snowboarders off the mountain there was
knuckle draggers they made all sorts of
noise and it sounded terrible etc etc
and there we learned to coexist and I
think it was a a benefit to the state
and the ski industry that snowboarders
did come into the mix because they
brought a whole new clientele a whole
new Revenue stream all new product bases
all new jobs jobs and I think uh you
know like I said the bill seems to be
arbitrary and capricious needs a lot
more research and I think maybe more a
better way to go about is to do a par
analysis you know it came from an
engineering company you look at the
problem you look at the top causes of
the problem and you go after the most
ones that you know are the most
egregious the 8020 rule kind of so to
speak and I think that's what we need to
do here before we go out and put out a
bill that seems Half Baked to
me my t morning and we will get you
copies thank you I did did want to end
with one thing this is the the
University of michig Minesota study that
I mentioned it says I'll read you two
sentences the University of Minnesota's
study does not recommend a formal
setback for wake surfing wakes from wake
surfing boats that wash up upon Shores
do not inherently degrade shorelines to
the contrary according to the University
of Minnesota itself Shoreline is driven
by mainly wind driven wave energy
so it's the wind it's the ice it's you
know other vehicles traveling over the
dirt and sand when we lower our Lake six
or seven feet every winter there's a
whole host of things that you know can
contribute to shoreline erosion that are
much more egregious than a wake that can
be caused not only by a wake surfing
boat but by all sorts of boats any boat
has a v-shaped hell if you drive at 10
15 miles hour you're going to throw one
and a half to two foot
wake and there some the research I also
saw is that the velocity of the Wake has
a lot more to do with it than the size
of the Wake so if you're planed off with
a water ski going 25 miles hour a one
and a half foot wave from that ski booat
is going to be more damaging to the
Shoreline than a two and a half foot
wake surf weight that's only going 12
miles an hour so I think a lot more work
needs to be done to evaluate what's
really causing the
issues any questions for us
speaker seeing none I thank you for your
testimony
also opposing the bill I I can't read
the writing of the last name and we need
it for the record it's Ryan from
Bo is he still here
[Music]
Ryan
she Ryan what's your last name um La
Liberty Liberty yeah thank
you
okay um hi everyone my name is Ryan the
Liberty I'm from Bo New Hampshire and
I'm here to testify against House Bill
1301 for me being on the boat is about H
is about family time and not being on
our screens enjoying and noticing the
things we have and what's around us now
many of you might think that this bill
is good to have but there are many
downfalls to this for myself and other
wake boo owners I'm sure many of these
people who have testified are going to
testify haven't been on a wake booat see
if you've been on a wake booat it is
very quiet and slow if you're serving
like me the problem with this bill is
the problem with this bill could be that
there would be limited options for lake
to go to if you own a wake booat and it
can even be harder for the driver since
the boats are forced into the middle
many camps are rent for people who do
water sports this B can affect those
camps in many ways when trying to find
information about wake boats or even any
boat there's a common denominator in New
Hampshire that everyone says that owning
a boat is about spending family time and
doing what you love this impact this
bill can impact Surfers like myself
because there can be too many people out
in the lake surfing at the same time
making it hard for the driver and the
surfer last time I had to write a speech
for something like this and over the
summer I was thinking about how
different the lake would be with this
bill nothing would be the same not camps
or family weekends on the boat these
boats brought me and I'm sure other
people so many memories it wouldn't be
the same with this bill I appreciate
your time and consideration thank you
thank you Ryan anyone have a question
for
Ryan no we thank you we appreciate your
testimony thank
you just pass it up one one one side of
the other thank you Jeffrey
Deacon see he's still here
Jeff New London New
Hampshire guess he left Jeff one more
time
je Evan goldner
Evan there my name is EV Golder I live
in B New Hampshire and I own a summer
camp for kids we focus on water sports
wake boarding uh wake surfing water
skiing I'm gonna not sorry I'm going to
not read this right now because like it
rehashes everything everyone's talked
about but basically I have taught water
sports uh since 2004 and I added wake
surfing to that in
2011 when it when it became a little
more prominent over here um I've driven
boats thousands and thousands of hours
all summer long um my my main lake is um
marry meeting in central New Hampshire
but I've traveled to dozens of other
water bodies Rivers ponds Lakes um all
over New England and it's a amazing fun
job I get to interact with a lot of
people and I just want to say that um if
I could represent a lot of people I work
with they are not fortunate enough to
have a lake house a boat access direct
access to water they have no say in this
kind of bill um it's unfortunate we get
I get people from you know four years
old to in their 80s we get in the boat
we have a blast they might come for one
day to New Hampshire they might stay for
a week they might buy a house they might
rent a place um it brings a lot of
people to our state um and they they
would not have a say in this kind of
Bill I think that's unfortunate it's un
undem undemocratic um it takes you know
the regulation of our water bodies away
from the elected the elected
representatives and it gives it to a a
minority of people in our state who are
so fortunate to have Lakefront uh access
or or a Butters to that um you know
growing up in New Hampshire I would have
killed for a lake house it's all I
wanted um I blame my dad for my my
career right now because he wouldn't get
a lake house for us so like I made this
my my job um and so many people are in
the same boat where they don't have
access and they come to New Hampshire
for our gorgeous Lakes um they rent a
boat or they come to a place like me
where they can get on the boat um and
wake surfing is limitlessly available to
everyone I have taken out people like I
said four years old all the way to their
80s it's low impact um I can talk to
them right behind the boat they can hear
me it's low stress we've had people with
disabilities we've had um you know
Wounded Warriors anyone that that wants
to can wake surf um so I think we're
forgetting a little bit about how
amazing the sport is how much it's
broadened the appeal of water sports and
recreation to to families all over the
all over the country um so I I would
really oppose this bill just because you
know good for whoever you own a lak
front house that is amazing you are
fortunate enjoy the lake I believe
everyone can share and enjoy Lake
together and that's something I've seen
uh in the last 20 years of teaching this
stuff I've seen everyone get along I've
seen fishermen and kayakers and swimmers
and wake Surfers coexist with minimal
issues I've never seen a wake surfing
injury I've seen wakeboarding injuries
I've seen water skiing injuries not one
wake surfing injury um to the direct
Surfer to someone on the boat to someone
passing by it is a slow predictable
Driving Experience if you see a wake
surfing boat coming at you I mean it's
like Austin Powers with the steamroller
you've got years to avoid that boat
because they're going 10 miles an hour
um I appreciate some of the concerns
I've heard um you know if we all Drive
our boats responsibly we can get along
we can preserve our our Lakes I do think
the the key to this is increasing
support for Marine Patrol I work closely
as a summer camp in New Hampshire with
Marine Patrol with Dees with DHHS um
give them the resources to do what
they're doing and protect our Lakes
there's also some great nonprofits like
the tree society and selt uh like at our
particular Lake we've we've conserved
over 2,000 acres of land to help
preserve our water quality because it's
all about like the runoff and keeping
the Lakes clean um so I'm all for clean
Lakes I'm obsessed with the environment
um I love being in the outdoors and um
yeah so I I do oppose this bill happy to
take questions any questions for this
speaker
representative well thank you sure uh
with all the exper expence you have
going to different bodies of water are
there some ponds or lakes that you think
would be inappropriate to bring your
weight totally totally I mean um I I did
a water ski lesson on a family's boat on
a tiny I forget the name if it was a
little Pond you would not wake surf
there um you would destroy your
propeller your boat you wouldn't create
a good wake um it would be I mean not in
anyone's interest you wouldn't you
wouldn't be able to create the Wake to
wake surf
but to I mean I've just there's so much
about this bill I don't I don't agree
with it's just it's just silly like why
would a boater go to that pond to wake
surf they would immediately turn around
their boat probably couldn't even get in
there um so it's a lot of common sense
and most wake boats stay where they live
these are big boats there's not a ton of
trailering so my property is next to the
public launch at our Our Lake so I get
to see you know every it's really
entertaining to watch people trailer
boats into the Lake it's it's hilarious
but I I get to see every single person
that comes in and out and it's mostly
fishermen moving boats back and forth
they like to fish different spots
there's tournaments there's uh all sorts
of stuff I don't fish I don't know but
um um wake boats in general they stay
where you put them um and people don't
really travel too much with them there's
the exceptions people coming if they
rent for a week or so they'll bring
their boat with them but I don't see too
much of like a a day trip or putting
into a lake that they don't know if that
makes
sense any other questions question for
the
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you I don't have a copy
I'm so sorry I just kind of
winged next I also opposed Shane carry
Shane I was told he might have to leave
Shane that's my last card for or against
is there anyone here that wanted to
speak that didn't make out a
card
representative if I may Mr chair yes um
um I just wanted to let people know that
I circulated the testimony of
Representative Linda Tanner from
Sullivan 5 and she represents the towns
of sopy and
Springfield um and her letter has been
circulated to all of the committee
members so I'm not going to read it
right now but I just wanted to let you
know that she needed to be here wasn't
able to and thank you Mr I'm sure our
clerk will make it part of the
record I'll be very you can speak and
then I we need a pink card too you can
grab
one your name and for or against I'm
John Noble I'm here against um so I'm I
own a wake vote I've own it for five
years we've been voting for 12 years um
there's I've introduced more adults
since I've had a wig boat because it's
low impact it's all been said but
there's nothing that I've been able to
do with my teenage kids starting at age
four I can put 10 kids on a boat bones
every one of them goes in the glove
compartment and they don't touch them
five hours of the best fun you could
ever have so when you start picking a
sport because somebody individually
doesn't like it I don't like the people
that water ski at six the Lakes like
glass but it wakes me up but I'm not
going to try to ban them I don't
particularly like jet skiis but I'm not
going to try to ban them you have to
live together it's a
you know responsible
boting it was said uh no wig zones but
you know if you've got somebody that's
out there driving close to shore take
down the registration number call it in
I mean educate them so anyway that's it
thank you any questions for the speaker
thank you very much if you could just
fill out the pink card so we could have
you for the
record we're going to read the blue
sheets
no people who signed the blue sheet let
me uh read them off for the record uh
I'll skip over anyone who who G uh who
gave uh
testimony
uh uh representative Glenn cordelli
Khan Gage
Dickinson is it yeah
Dickerson uh
Khan mark
uh
bonafont
KH uh well colen Tomy you
you you already you uh already testified
Autumn testified uh Tom
canel uh Tom canel he is a
pro uh the balls or test
testif uh Emily has testified uh
Scott Wallace
or Ma I don't know about someone named
Scott from Rockingham
eight uh
Pro
uh wow D I'm not GNA do this
again
read
the just the numbers I'm going I'm just
going to go down one
two one two three four
five five Pro and one
two 16
against and I'm now going to close the
hearing on uh HB 1301 and thank
everybody for coming and for all of you
who testified thank you we're going to
take up real quickly a
hb401 FN because as I mentioned at least
twice the sponsor is going to ask to
withdraw 1401 FN and while we're waiting
for the sponsor to do that or the
co-sponsor is there anyone here to
testify on Bill
1423 I have one
maybe when these people leave I can see
if there's anybody
else
two excuse me can we clear the room
please who have uh those who have
already
spoken you think there's three or four
okay we'll make a ruling on 1423 after
representative wrong speaks I'm going to
call to the hearing to start on
hb401 FM representative run thank you
very much Mr chair and for the record
I'm Rosemary rang I represent Hillsboro
12 which is the town of miramac I'm
going to do my best to get us back on
track um and say that as co-sponsor of
1401 I have worked with the prime
sponsor representative McGee from Hollis
and we have made the decision
with the town leadership of the town of
Hollis that this bill isn't ready yet um
it came about because Silver Lake Park
in Hollis which ab buts Silver Lake has
had years and year Decades of
environmental issues that pose a health
risk to any visitors to the lake vehical
contamination cyano bacteria blooms and
um there was the sense that um if the
department or the division of State
parkks returned ownership to the town of
Hollis who originally own that property
that perhaps the town could be more
successful in ensuring the health of the
lake um there are members of the town uh
Town leadership that in principle
support you know and want to look into
it more but they feel like they're not
in a position yet to um take ownership
should this bill pass um according to
house rules we have gone beyond the
deadline of withdrawing bill so what um
the prime sponsor and I uh would like
the committee is to we'd like you to um
vote on a recommendation of
itl um and that's probably the most
efficient way of making this bill go
away until another another year when it
would be um work more with the town
leadership so thank you thank you
representative any questions to the
representative I'm going to ask my clerk
do we have enough people people here to
oh thank you representative you can
leave just trying to figure out if we
have a quorum in order to take a itl
motion and go into
exact okay you're 11 so yes yes we would
just have a COR you can vote on oh yeah
she can vote okay yep
yep okay so I'm any I had mentioned if
there was anybody else to speak on 1401
but I don't know if there is is there
anyone else to speak on
1401 if not I'll close the hearing and
now with the consent of uh two chairs
sitting next to me um I'm told that we
can move into executive
session um although it wasn't posted but
with the consent of as I yes have my I
understand the rule uh that we're
allowed to go under that agreement
between the uh chairman myself and the
ranking member which is representative
Vale that we wish we can take up a uh we
can go into executive session to dis to
dispose of a of a bill that we both feel
that it's
is with that so I'll entertain a motion
to representative rung you have a motion
thank you Mr chair I move that we uh
recommend itl on
hb401 dfn have a motion for itl I have a
second from representative Vil would you
like to speak on your motion I think
I've said all that I can say thank you
would you like to speak on your second
yes I think um finding a non-legislative
solution is always encouraged I look
forward to the bill if one is necessary
thank you thank you is anyone wish to
speak on the
motion hearing none the clerk will read
the roll
call how come I'm the only one working
here I try to catch up okay uh I'll go
in the normal way uh rep representative
harb
yes representative Horgan yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf
yes repres
representative is he left not
here uh representative
Vale yes representative rung yes
representative Simpson
yes representative Derby
yes representative represent restive
lontine
yes representative lit
yes
and representative Rulo votes yes one
two 11 11 yes zero nay
consent andent okay
yep thank you appreciate that point of
order Mr chair uh because of the FN note
does it have to go in the regular
calendar I don't know uh no okay thank
you I have two cards uh for hb1 1423 FN
so I think we should continue with that
because these people came to be on time
so I'm now going to open the hearing for
HB
1423 FN re requiring the commissioner of
the Department of Natural and cultural
resources to identify all old growth and
mature forests on public lands in the
state of New
Hampshire so I'd like to call up in
support of the bill Katherine
Corker representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
uh committee members of the resource
Recreation committee
uh for the record my name is Tony Kaplan
and I represent mayor Mack 8 the towns
of hener Warner and Bradford and I'm
here to uh present hb1 1423 requiring
the department of uh natural and
cultural resources to identify all old
growth and mature Forest on public land
in the state of New
Hampshire I think it's important to
start out by saying that um in crafting
this bill I recognize the importance of
not
mandating any particular uh management
strategy on on our public land I believe
I know that the division of
Forestry uh in the department is Staff
with capable people experts who
recognize our state's priorities in
managing the most valued natural
resource we have in order to meet the
various functions that we require of our
public lands and particular Forest
lands uh this bill came about as a
result of discussion with the department
and with Advocates of old growth forests
old growth forests are receiv receiving
scrutiny and added value across the
country and indeed around the
world as we seek to fight the threat of
climate change it's a given now that in
terms of avoiding the worst impacts of
climate change we're not only going to
have to stop our use of fossil fuels
that are pumping out gases into the
atmosphere but we're going to actually
have to draw down some of that carbon
that's already in there in order to
avoid the worst
impacts and so uh with that knowledge
you see uh all sorts of innov ation
going uh on there's companies all over
the place coming up with these machines
you've probably seen the stories of uh
these machines that can suck the air out
of uh you know filter out the carbon
dioxide and pump it very energy
intensive and uh you know
technologically intensive machines we
have some of those machines in in our
state they're called trees uh they
already do that and the best ones at the
job are the big old
ones so New Hampshire's uni unique
blessed with the vast Forest cover much
of it on public land state parks the
White Mountain National Forest Our Town
Forest how much of this contains the old
growth uh there are estimates but
there's much to find out and much to
identify and
map This Is Our Land it's the public
land and our for is resource the public
right to know is essential in the proper
functioning of our democracy it's like a
family's finances you can't manage your
finances if you don't know what's in
your bank account indeed if you don't
even know where the deposits
are that's what this bill is intended to
do on behalf of the people the owners of
the resource to identify old growth and
mature Forest on public lands that have
the potential to be useful in terms of
forest carbon storage flood and drought
mitigation water quality and
biodiversity
protection it will involve the
department in a process
of defining first of all Define what old
growth forest characteristics and what
mature Forest characteristics are and
how they fit into those used
categories this process ideally would
involve all the stakeholders in managing
public lands and should be open to
public participation and
comment and I'm willing to offer an
amendment to the bill with language to
this effect uh if the committee is
interested in
that I would like to say something about
the fiscal note attached to this bill I
can only assume that the department is
reaching out to potential partners that
may be able to contribute expertise and
Manpower such as the US Forest Service
and Forestry Departments of neighboring
states working on similar
tasks but in in any case given the
Surplus and budgets that we are uh we're
we're currently enjoying I can think of
no task more entral than long-term
planning for management of New
Hampshire's valuable public for
resource as I said such planning and
decision- making can't be carried out
without the knowledge that comes with
identifying and mapping what we have
it's the Public's right to know that is
the basic Foundation of this work uh and
with that I'll try to answer any
questions the committee has and uh I
think there are some technical experts
coming up behind me so save those
questions for people who might know more
about that those kind of things thank
representative wolf has a
question when you say all public lands
are you talking just State lands or all
public lands we have a huge natural
National Forest yeah yeah I understand
that uh the national forest is you know
an interesting part of this equation and
I I did consider that uh you know when I
was uh writing this bill but I think we
we can
easily incorporate the US National Force
into this study physically because
they're already doing this in the US
National Forest they are studying uh
what old growth is there and they're
identifying and mapping it as we speak
so I
don't I don't I don't think that's a
major problem for us to consider that as
public
land okay any other questions for the
representative representative rung thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question representative Kaplin are there
other states that have doing this have
you done any research about how many
yeah I thanks for the question
representative there are there all our
neighboring states are are carrying out
similar uh investigations into all
growth and mature Forest uh got Maine
Vermont New York state Pennsylvania I'm
not sure about Massachusetts
though representative Darby thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
can you um I didn't see the definitions
of mature and old growth in the bill um
and so do you think that those are sort
of um obvious or do they should they be
added should they be included as
definitions to scope the
surve I yeah I don't think that it's the
place of the legislature to define those
those questions I think that the
department has the experts uh and the
knowledge that they can identify what
those definitions should be as I said in
in my statements I think ideally that
would be a public process that the
public could be involved in um but I you
know that that is the first step is to
ID is to Define what those terms
mean thank
you representative L montain did you
have a
question um I was just
wondering about the job of
identification and mapping um if there's
another way we consider using other
resources like not have the department
do that but maybe contract with
universities or use
uh you know the resources of the uh
Forest Service um and maybe you know
consider rewarding this so that
um um this agency or Department only has
to compile the information rather than
do it themselves yeah I mean that's a
that's a great thought representative
thank you for for asking that question
and especially when I looked at the
fiscal note that was my thought is that
you know there's a lot of collaboration
that is possible here to the cut costs
and I I've been speaking to
environmental Consultants who've been
involved in this work and they mentioned
that a great uh you know pool of uh
potential mappers if you will are
volunteers and getting the public
involved in that and and this are these
are uh you know projects that are
already being done that use volunteer
labor um to do the heavy work you know
going out into the forest and and
actually mapping what's there on foot so
um yeah there's there's all all sorts of
potential there it's it's beyond my
expertise to be able to map that out but
it's something that uh you know when
looking at the fiscal note I would I
would definitely want to know more about
this you know potential
collaborations before I accept it I mean
I know in New Hampshire in in my town
meetings for instance is always for
instance the fire department is asking
for the you know half a million dollar
fir truck and and people push back and
say well hold on a second do you really
need that truck with all the bells and
whistles can you find a you know a
cheaper truck um so in this fiscal note
I noticed that you know seven new
employees being being sought by the
department and and I don't be grudged on
that but uh then I saw there's an every
employee is getting a new vehicle and I
was wondering you know dozens the the
division of Forestry have vehicles
already in place around the state do
they each need a new vehicle so that's
just you know um an exam I know that's
the way things are done in New Hampshire
but um I think that can be questioned
also
do you have a question representative
wolf yes thank you are you aware that
there is a division of Natural Resources
within the department of that's doing
this work
now yes representative thank you for the
question uh yes the division of Forestry
is is a division within the department
that carries on uh you know the work of
is that who what you talking about I
believe it's called the natural heritage
there's a natural heritage Bureau as
well that does mapping yeah they do uh
similar work they're mapping uh what
what are called exemplary communities
which are kind of similar to Old grows
but not exactly the same uh so it's um
it's a little more restricted of a
category and yeah I mean again that is
an example of where collaboration even
within the department might uh yield
some results they've already identified
and mapped some of the old Forest you're
right um but there's a lot of work that
still needs to be done
any other questions for the
representative seeing none thank you for
your testimony thank you for your
time call up next Patrick hyley of
dncr
Pat thank
you
you thank you representative harb and
representative Rulo for the opportunity
to
testify um I also submitted my testimony
electronically just last night so it's
in the queue um for the record my name
is Patrick Hackley I the state Forester
and director for the New Hampshire
division of forest and lands one of five
divisions under the Department of
Natural and cultural
resources
um so this bill is is uh asking the
Department of Natural and cultural
resource to identify an old growth
mature force on public land in New
Hampshire I just want to State also for
the record that we do not have a formal
position on this bill we just have some
concerns we'd like to share with the
committee under the authority of the New
Hampshire native plant protection act
RSA
217a our division's natural heritage
Bureau identifies and facilitates the
protection of the state's rare plants
and exemplary natural
communities um these are types of
forests so that includes old growth and
mature forests so
um we I'll I'll get to the the
definition in a in a moment because it
is um something that there's a lot of
debate about um so the bureau develops
and implements measures for protection
conservation and enhancement and
management of native New Hampshire
plants and natural communities and
serves as an information source to
assist and advise state and local
agencies and the public uh the natural
heritage Bureau is not a regulatory
agency Instead The Bureau works with
land owners and land managers to help
them protect New Hampshire's native
plants while meeting their land use
needs as written HB
1423 this bill would require us to
identify dncr to identify old growth
growth and mature forests on all all
public lands in the
state considering Municipal County state
and federal ownership in in New
Hampshire this would equate to well over
1.5 million acres of
land as indicated in the fiscal note the
cost of hiring adequate staff to
accomplish this task within any
reasonable time period would be cost
prohibitive secondly as I mentioned
earlier old growth and mature Force have
multiple and nuanced
definitions um even among ologists and
other natural resource professionals
there are different definitions so that
would have to be something that would
would need to be Define before we could
even commence any practical inventory of
this particular natural
Community um and lastly through the work
of the natural heritage Bureau our
agency is
already um uh statutorily obligated if
you will we're already in the process of
identifying rare these rare communities
all growth and natural natural um
natural communities that have mature
force in them so we're already meeting
the state's obligation to inventory this
particular type of
forest um that's all I have um thank you
for the opportunity to testify and I'd
be happy to take any questions any
questions for the
speaker representative rang thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr heckley for
taking my question um I was alarmed too
when I looked at the fiscal note um if
the bill was amended to only incorporate
state or maybe even national uh lands
how would that impact the estimated
cost we would probably need at least two
or three more ecologists to help us with
that task um the the White Mountain
National Forest is mostly in New
Hampshire but it also borders it it
drips into the state of Maine about 780
750,000 acres are in New Hampshire and
then the rest uh White Mountain is in
total a little under 900,000 Acres so it
would still be quite a chunk if you just
want to add State lands we have uh dncr
reservations we have approximately
um 200,000
Acres as I mentioned before we already
have identified a number of old growth
components to those
forests um but to get to your your
question again representative Rong it
would be probably a couple three
ecologists anyway so you could maybe cut
that number in half um but it still
would be a large task and you still
would need trucks you would still need
to transport Personnel to these places
we do have trucks uh in our division but
they're already obligated to other
responsibilities one follow so if you if
you say that some of this work is being
done already is the objective of the
bill can that that be accomplished
without legislation and if so what would
the timeline of that
be well I really I'm unclear as to the
objective of the bill I think it it is
requesting more inventory work
um
so we haven't given it a whole lot of
thought because we looked at it at face
value of what what it's currently asking
us to do we haven't gone farther to say
well if we you know we didn't feel like
it was our role
to try to meet the need since we feel
like the division's already meeting the
need
um it's it's an incremental
process and it takes time and staff to
do to do that on state
land
um
so you know I I really haven't given
much thought about how would we
calibrate the the time period to get the
job done okay thank you any other
questions
yes representative um thank you Mr chair
I'm sorry I'm confused maybe I think I
just misheard the question if the state
is already um inventorying the state
lands and this bill were scoped to State
and and this bill were scoped to State
lands it would still require two or
three additional headcount yeah because
our current natural heritage Bureau
staff are already obligated to other
tasks that they carry out so so we would
need to have dedicated staff just to go
out and inventory all those 200,000
acres to see if you
know where all growth first we'd have to
come up with the definition and then we
would probably need to dedicate uh staff
specifically to that task across the
state so there would be an additional
need for staff thank
you any other
questions well thank you for your
testimony okay thank
you
next in opposition to the bill Matt
Ley for
society I'm Matt Le I'm thec
director is this on okay sorry about
that so um I'm Matt Ley public policy
director dor for the society for the
protection of New Hampshire Forest um
and we are a nonprofit Land Trust um our
basic mission is to protect and preserve
U the forest in New
Hampshire uh we do that two ways one by
actually owning and acquiring Forest
land we also um also hold easements on
on other privately held land so we
currently we own about 60,000 Acres of
mostly forested land in New Hampshire so
this you know very big part of our
mission
um you know and you know typically we do
it you know advocate for
additional resources for you know
funding and resources for our public
resource agencies like forest and lands
fishing game um and we certainly
consider you know both those agencies
our you know our partners on this
um but and this has been mentioned
already you know when we saw the fiscal
note it is actually is a concern for us
um in the scope of work currently called
for in the bill you know does seem
daunting quite frankly um
and you know the the there is a number
of challenges and issues and concerns
that are facing the forest in New
Hampshire currently um and one uh
suggestion perhaps I would um pass along
to the committee is to review the
state's Forest action plan um which was
developed um by Patrick's office back in
20120 and it is um a very
extensive document but it lays out you
know the um all the
issues Trends concern that are facing
the forest and there are a lot I mean
there's we have invasive pests and
species um climate change is certainly
an issue um and and how do we um make
sure our forest and not just public
Forest you know private you know
privately owned Forest too um are able
to you know
withstand these changes we may be seeing
because of climate change but then there
are other issues um you know markets for
the wood that's harvested in New
Hampshire you know how do we you know
make sure um there are those markets and
representative harb actually chaired a
commission um on lowgrade wood and we
certainly appreciate that work um and
hopefully there'll be you know some real
action items that'll come out of the
work you did there so um you know that's
really Our concern there's so much going
on in our forest right now and you know
can't and you know we understand you
know the um budget pressures you know
facing the state and so you know given
all that's going on you know you know is
there room and capacity you know with um
the division of forest lands to also
undertake like I said what does seem to
be a a daunting scope of work so I'll
just but I have to take any
questions any other questions for our
speaker seeing none thank you thank you
for your
testimony speaking in support of the
bill Katherine cery New Hampshire Sierra
Club good afternoon uh thank you for um
taking my
testimony my name is Katherine cork I am
with New Hampshire Sierra Club uh the
Sierra Club is an environmental advocacy
group and
um we support this bill uh because we
were hoping to have some space not uh to
to talk about mature forests to talk
about old growth forests and um to
partner with our federal
agencies uh that are doing this work
um
and in particular
um have a space where we're not talking
about logging these large trees um and
to think of the many other uses and
benefits that we get from mature
forests
um it so often when we talk about
forests in New Hampshire we hear from
the logging industry and the markets and
the that's great and you know there's a
time for that but we're hoping to really
focus in on the place of our old growth
and the natural
exemplary um forest in New Hampshire on
our public lands um and I have a
testimony uh from folks who couldn't be
here today um uh one from uh
Zack Porter from standing trees he
wasn't able to make it today and um if
this bill does go into a study committee
I I really encourage you to uh include
him he's he is quite the expert on on
these issues um and uh also from our
Chapter Chair uh Jerry
Curran
um specifically
I I hear um I think it was
representative wolf who talked about all
public lands and the task of of that
that might be I think there's room
around that in this bill um and maybe
it's unreasonable to ask a state agency
to uh head up the inventory of federal
lands I I I think that's probably
reasonable um and asking them to also
inventory Community or or town
lands um I I am definitely uh supportive
of maybe having a little bit more Focus
uh on the 200,000 Acres of the state and
and let
me just support the work that the state
has been doing on this um having
identified some of our exemplary natural
Forest um in the state is is excellent
um but there's more work to be done and
and to
prioritize that work is really what this
bill is I think is trying to do um as I
read it
um so with that um I'm happy to take any
questions and encourage you all to look
deeply into this bill and and find a way
to support the identification and
inventorying of the natural exemplary
forest in the state or old growth forest
in the state thank you any questions
representative Iran thank you Mr chair
it's not common that we see um the New
Hampshire Sierra Club and the society
for the protection of New Hampshire
Forest coming in with different um
positions on a bill so I I guess I want
Clarity on where the New Hampshire
Sierra Club stands are is your um
support for this bill mainly because of
you want protection for the old growth
forests and um what do you cons would
you consider that suggestion by Mr Ley
about reviewing the States forested
action plan to see if um this type of
inventory or this type of work can be
integrated in with with
that um I'm not sure if he testified to
that but um I I know we
are there's a real opportunity um with
the federal government is actually doing
this on federal lands and this could be
a real bridge for the state to collect
collaborate with that
expertise um Beyond The White Mountain
National Forest um as for the State uh
forestry action plan that's that's
really focused on on a harvesting um I I
would be loathe to uh add to the list of
activities of the forest reaction plan
uh because it is is it is pretty massive
um but it's I
guess I feel as though there isn't a lot
of space for for mature
forests um in in those areas and so
maybe
designating some other space for mature
Forest um that this this bill might be
doing any other questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony pie
each
thank
our next speaker Jason stock
Jason New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association opposed to the
bill oh good afternoon U I'm going to
try to be brief um I know you've had a
very long morning but I appreciate the
opportunity to come and testify for the
record I'm Jason stock I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Timberland
owner
Association and uh our members represent
we represent Timberland owners as well
as folks that work in the forest and
process Forest products and for many of
the reasons you heard from the forest
Society we oppose this bill um kind of
put things in context you heard 1.5
million Acres of public land the state
of New Hampshire is 5 million Acres
roughly so to to ask the division of
forest and land
to to inventory and map one point
basically a third of the state for one
specific element is a pretty tall
order moreover mapping inventorying and
mapping it's not like you can just
Google Earth it and say all right that
looks old that doesn't you actually have
to get out there and have boots on the
ground so when you look at the fiscal
note think about hiring someone to go
out or many someone's to go out and
actually Cruise a third of the state
looking for old growth
characteristics document that and then
get your GPS points map it load it into
whatever software you use it's a pretty
big task so although you may say well
it's just map it and inventory and it
that's that's simple enough it's a lot
of land uh 1.5 about a third of the
state and as as Mr Ley had testified
there are a lot of other challenges
facing the state the state at least on
state land they have they they as you
heard they know where the old growth is
and where those characteristics are on
their property to ask them to go to a
county the Army Corps of engineer lands
the US fish and wildlife service and
let's not forget Town Forest and say
okay we want you to start cruising those
and mapping that again that's a pretty
big task and so I think the suggestion
to to look at the forest action plan it
is more than just about Timber
harvesting there are chapters in there
about carbon there are chapters in there
about rare rare ecological systems it is
it is incredibly comprehensive very
large very dense document if that is
where this this really should reside and
and that's where the charge should be
that comes up periodically for review
and that's where the division of forest
and Lance that's think of it as their
kind of their strategic plan for the
state's forest and that's really where
this this should be this task should be
vetted and and inserted with that I'll
conclude my testimony I'd be happy to
try to answer any questions
thank you any questions for the
speaker Mr D representative
Derby representative R Mr chair thank
you for taking my question certainly I
just want to make sure I understand the
op um the concern um of the U the New
Hampshire Timberland Owners Association
are you concerned that um the state is
going to it's going to cost uh State too
much money to do this or is there some
other concern that is underlying your
your
great question concern is twofold one
this is not the appropriate venue to be
the forest action plan we feel is really
the approp that strategic plan for the
state's Forest that's really the
appropriate venue to be mapping out task
like this but secondly as as the fiscal
note indicates it's a it's a large
expense and it is a a large expense
imposed on an agency that has many other
tasks and so unless the unless the state
dips into the coffers and says yes we're
going to fully fund this and we're
really going to put the resources on it
other areas Forest Health and other
areas will suffer and that's really a
concern that we have is that and
moreover to ask them to do that on land
that they do not control Town Forest
County forest Etc we think it's just
inappropriate you're welcome welcome
representative renz
Zulo thank you and thank you for taking
my question this might uh well this
question might be posed to just about
everyone who who spoke spoken my concern
is about the
security of these valuable resources and
historic
resources uh is is with this is this
information going to be sequestered a
hell at least a some kind of
confidentiality because I could Vision
Vision know just any old person deciding
hey let's go to this real Old Forest and
maybe we can do a few cuttings uh I mean
sure people are like that well is there
any thought on security the in the
protection of these sure this
information sure good question first off
this is information on public lands so
it's not private lands so this is public
lands so if someone were to say ah I got
a map of Old growth let's go let's go
log it that's not GNA I mean that that
that brings in all kinds of other
violations and so my cuting I me my
cting I me so so I think I think the the
point is is that from a security
standpoint these are lands that are
managed by professional
public Foresters and so there's a
there's a level of security there
there's a level there's a level of
regulations and laws that protect even
tree trimming you can't you can't
legally go on and start trimming trees
on someone else's land even public land
and that in fact violates the law so
there's also another level of of
regulatory um legal Authority there to
protect this protect this resource so I
think I'm not as concerned about that um
you know I think the security question
is answered already with the way these
lands are owned managed and our current
Regulatory and legal
infrastructure representative of
B thank you Mr chair um thank you Mr
stock for uh taking my question I just
um quickly do you have a definition of
old growth and of mature forest for us I
don't and and here here's why it is and
as you heard earlier there it's like
many things in the natural resource
realm there are and it's a scientific
definition and depending on whom you ask
you're going to get a different
definition old growth characteristics I
can tell you in rumney right now there's
a bog that is old growth and you walk
through it and you would look around and
you'd say this is an old growth growth
all the trees are about this big and
it's a tight Hemlock stand where these
trees have been sitting here and they
just slowly slowly slowly growth so my
point is is that you know there are some
definitions they can vary I don't have a
definition and I wouldn't even begin and
you know I look at a um sugar maple tree
and I know from a forest product
standpoint you can hit biological versus
economic maturity economic maturity on
some of these species you start looking
at 60 to 80 years for economic maturity
that sugar maple can grow for several
hundred years so again this definition
is leave that to the silver culturalist
and the scientist don't ask the
lobbyist any other questions for the
lobbyist
thank
you I don't see any well thank you for
your testimony a pleasure testifying is
there anyone else that wants to speak on
hb1
FN one more time hb1 1423 FN seeing no
one approaching and the cards all having
gone through I'm going to close the
hearing on hb1
FN many PS do you
have that's the next one no this is not
this is all
1423 that's the next one Here's my
thought just take 15 minutes we can't
for the members of the committee we're
going to take a short break 15 minutes
um we' normally take longer but we have
quite a few people want to testify on
the next bill and it's not fair to keep
them waiting too long so we're just
going to take a 15minute break I hope
those that came to testify we'll
appreciate us having a little break so
we'll come back at a little about 116
117 yeah if you get it if you get uh if
you get the
food uh you can bring it back here and
take I'll take the heat for it so we can
keep you so we can uh help get to the
get to what the public needs to hear
thank
you huh what
oh9 hey I just I just grab my seat I got
fired and hired again oh
oh
e
thank you I'm going to open the hearing
on hb1
FNA establishing a procedure for the
Department of Environmental Services to
transfer ownership of dams to
municipalities and others including
making
loans call up the prime sponsor
representative Lisa mazour
Lisa good afternoon honorable members of
the committee my name is representative
Lisa merer and I represent the great go
the great towns of gtown and where I
come before you today to speak to HB
1429 this bill was written to address a
matter of great importance to our
communities our dams and waterways this
proposed legislation is a step towards
enhancing local control and ensuring the
sustainable management of these vital
resources this bill came about because
one of the towns I represent gtown has
residents who will be impacted by three
dams that came on under recent scrutiny
by FK Federal Environmental Regulatory
Commission thank you Fred the Hadley
Falls Gregs Falls and Kelly Falls dams
since working on this bill I have become
aware of many more dams across our state
who are being hit with the same Federal
requirements and are facing hard
decisions about their dams and waterways
as well the state of New Hampshire took
ownership of the Hadley Falls Dam in
Goffstown in 196 8 and it began
producing hydroelectric power from then
until that ceased happening in
2007 in 2013 Dees became the sole leny
of the dam between January and March of
2023 Dees and FK efforts to negotiate a
new lease had failed to come to accept
acceptable terms then in April 2023 Dees
advised our town and other stakeholders
that they decided to surrender the dam
license and begin the process of dam
removal this decision was a surprise a
shock to all in attendance as earlier
communication indicated surrendering the
license was only a
consideration Additionally the two other
dams mentioned previously were on FK
radar as dams that required resolution
as well in turn this decision blindsided
our community as it affects not only
only Waterfront owners but our entire
town there are recreational events that
happen in gwn that center around these
dams that bring in significant financial
Revenue to local businesses as well G
toown was left with little options but
if this bill was in place during
discussions about Hadley Falls we may
have been able to save the license hb1
1429 as
amended which you have in front of you
uh would present options and
opportunities for towns and
municipalities to have a more direct say
in the management of these critical
infrastructures by providing an option
to bring ownership to the local level we
can ensure that town decisions regarding
their dams and waterways align with the
unique needs and priorities of their
communities this bill is not just about
transferring ownership it it is about
empowering New Hampshire's communities
to be active custodian s of these
valuable assets of course we understand
that with this new found responsibility
comes the need for careful planning
expertise and financial commitment
however we are confident that with the
support of the community and
collaboration with relevant stakeholders
we can successfully navigate these
challenges and ensure a smooth
transition Dees expressed initial
concerns about the loan aspect of the
bill and after meeting with them over
our holiday break and Amendment was draw
up drawn up that was agreeable to all
that amendment is in front of you today
we were able to get bipartisan support
on this as well as many New Hampshire
communities are going through similar
situations in conclusion this bill will
not require a t a town or municipality
to take ownership of their dams that's
important to note it's not a requirement
but it gives them an option to do
so we didn't have that in gtown recently
I ask the members of this committee to
consider the profound implications of
this legislation as an opportunity for
local empowerment sustainability and
community-driven
progress thank you um I know that uh
Dees is here that can answer any
technical questions or anything else you
have so thank you for hearing me
today representative
Kelly thank you for being here are you
able to elaborate on the differences
between the amendment and
the original bill just yes it's mostly
just um the the the fund the fund
section changes to revolving Dam fund so
you you'll see the differences in in
that language um so that's that's the
main differences and and I know um so
Dees is the one that mostly you know we
worked on the amendment but they came up
with um these changes that would be
agreeable to them and uh yeah and also
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
so yep any other questions for the
representative seeing none thank you for
your testimony thank you representative
Alexander in support of the bill one of
the
co-sponsors thank you Mr chair members
of resources Recreation development for
the record my name is Joe Alexander I
represent the town of go Town only in
the state house um I would like to Echo
a lot of what representative merer said
um just to start again this is a
Statewide issue if your town or
municipality or city in your District
hasn't dealt with this there are over
200 dams in the state um this is going
to provide an option for them I think
it's really important to note that it
may not have happened to you yet but it
may happen to you because there's a lot
of dams that are headed into red listed
um you know this is a goth Town example
but when we talk about economic
viability of our downtown town the dam
really put the dam was a huge part of
that factor I don't know if anybody's
been to the golf toown pumpkin rata but
we carve out pumpkins and Float them
down the river and and the dam was able
to to be that buffer to allow us to do
that so it was like one of our big
downtown festivals of the year so very
important to us um I just spoke to New
Hampshire Municipal Association who was
planning on testifying they're behind me
um they are supported supportive of the
local option and concept and they just
have two minor changes that I believe
that we can bring to the committee and
I'm happy to send an amendment over and
to get you a final Amendment um to look
at and then again just to note this bill
does not have a fiscal impact it creates
a revolving fund and puts a dollar in it
so then that we can decide in the future
in a different legislature if you'd like
to fund it or anything but I think that
this at least establishes the fund in
concept by putting a dollar in it so
with that uh again technical questions
I'll refer to Dees but I wanted to
stress some of those points thank you
thank you any questions for the
representative one whole
dollar representative
Derby thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um if you want to
defer this question it's totally okay
with me sure but I noticed that there's
already statue that allows the
municipality to take ownership um by
eminent domain of a dam um once it's
found in dis disrepair and it seems like
if the
foreseen Factor here is the federal
government says this Dam needs to be
repaired then it isn't disrepair and
would allow the municipality to go
through that eminent domain proceeding I
can give you the statute if you care Sor
I was wondering if that was a
consideration or if the real driving
Factor here is the um is the the
revolving fund that because you want you
want money to support to provide for the
DM repairers well thank you
representative for your question I think
it's the ladder so I would say that
creating this revolving fund would give
a municipality options because in the
example with gown we really didn't have
$10 million to Shell out to purchase the
dam because um Dees will stress that
they offer the dam to us for a dollar um
but with all the repairs needed and
things like that it was something where
it wasn't a realistic option for
Goffstown but I believe creating this
fund will allow municipalities the
option um to tap into that resource if
they need
it any other questions for the re
representative seeing none thank you for
your
testimony another co-sponsor
representative
PL thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
allowing allowing me to speak before the
committee I won't touch on what was just
said I agree with all of it but the bill
now has a dollar setup for the fund and
nothing can come out of it till it's 2
and a half half million at least in it
well and there's no mechanism right now
to get that two and a half million in it
but I'm asking our our inde not to worry
about that pass the bill and uh the
dollar would be set up but then it go to
Ways and Means for because if it's a
revolving fund that a dedicated fund
that's what uh Ways and Means do does
and then the finance finance committee
won't have to address it address it this
year but they will in a a budget to be
able to get some money in there there
but that's something that rr&d doesn't
have to worry about that's that's why
there's an FN note to go to a second
committee thank you any questions for
the representative representative Darby
thank you m Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so I haven't been
able to read this bill this amendment
yet but are you saying that the the loan
process is different in this amendment
than it was in the original bill which
used the um an existing fund that would
that is according to the fiscal note on
the bill funded by um uh what is it the
um
hydropower is this a different fund or
is the same I I think it's a different
fund it's a brand new fund with a dollar
in it and then because what you you
can't spend any money till there's at
least 2 and a half million uh in in the
bill the language of the bill and so
that that money has to be in be put in
there somehow and that's something for
finance committee to work
on thanks any other
questions representative Ron thank you
I'm still trying to digest the bill
representative PL but my qu my question
and thank you for taking it
is if if the state does not fund the the
revolving fund but yet the town wants to
take ownership of the dam but then they
can't access the loan money to for
repair any needed repairs would it be
possible over the town then to go to the
town voters with uh let's say a bond to
bond the repairs so that they're not
hung I'm just I'm looking at a situation
where the state is going to um uh you
know dis you know uh get rid of a a dam
so a town may want to say hold it we
want the option to get it the town
decides yes we want that Dam but there's
no money in the revolving fund to make
the repairs so the town likely I would
expect would not want to take possession
of a possession of a dam until they have
the money to do the repairs would they
then be able to go in bond get a
municipal bond for that if the Loan Fund
doesn't get um the two and a half
million that is another option yes okay
um we would have to go to the voters
nevertheless because you you committing
to that kind of money we'd go to the the
the town's people to get approval for
the for the town to take it on
obligation with we would either way not
come up with the money from the town
immediately but we either pay a bond
interest and dividends over time or
through this mechanism we' pay be paying
the state back uh through this mechanism
follow so would the town people have to
vote on taking that loan out then yes
okay so they'd have to vote either way
either for a bond or to take money from
the revolving fund yeah correct okay all
right thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank
you Ted dear New Hampshire Dees
Ted thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
clerk chair thank you members of the
committee uh it is great to be here
happy New Year to you all and uh so I'm
happy to chat it's been a terrific uh
experience working with with the
sponsors on this bill providing some
technical assistance from Dees and it's
it really has been uh it's been great uh
that that exchange has been wonderful I
think these sponsors have have done a
great job on this um so I'm just going
to provide a couple of pieces of
information I sent around a letter of
testimony uh I just going to point out a
couple of pieces in there Dees has 276
dams that we manage for the state owned
by uh some of them by Dees some by fish
and games some by do a few by dancer and
so we provide uh assistance to those
agencies in managing those dams uh those
uh together uh you know I don't know
what the average age of those dams is
but it's probably approaching a 100 so
we have an aging uh infrastructure uh of
all of these dams we know that of the 60
high-hazard dams that we open we have
that is high Hazard is a dam not it has
nothing to do with the condition of the
dam but that Dam should should it fail
would cause life likely cause Li loss of
life we have 60 of those in the state
that the state uh maintains and they
currently have a capital need of about
$300 million to just keep them in repair
the rest of those dams the other 200
whatever 216 um have a capital need of
about 115 $116 million that we know of
right now just to keep them in repair I
just want to put that in context um
where about to go out to bid on goose we
just went out to bid on Goose Pond uh
that is a dam that's being rebuilt and
uh the cost of that was $6 million uh
relatively straightforward project um
that is on top of the already probably a
quarter of a million dollars we've spent
on design so these projects are not
cheap um and so we are making hard
choices every single day about what goes
to the capital budget for requests and
what has to get get funded first what
has to get repaired first so I just want
to put that in context of this bill and
all of the other testimony you'll hear
about uh the various different uh Dam
bills that are coming before you uh this
session and there are a
number so I about this bill in
particular uh the transfer this was
raised representative Darby you raised a
good question that U there currently is
obviously a mechanism like I said I'll
sell you you name the dam I'll sell it
to you for a dollar uh but um
what isn't in this is that should the
state determine as I think we've made
that determination on Hadley Falls that
the best option is for removal that the
there's no mechanism for the uh for the
municipalities to say hey stop I might
want to buy this and it takes a while to
get through that process if you're a
community and so I think that's what
this is recognizing obviously the town
can take something on imminent domain if
it's private um obviously we can sell
something there there's a whole process
for Surplus lands that you're probably
familiar with but what this bill does is
it sort of gets that there's a little
bit of a donnut hole there that should
the state want to go down this road and
again I think we don't have a problem
with that these are long project they
take a long time in planning and
implementation and we want to make sure
that however this goes that the
community has adequate time so if that's
something that the communities feel like
they need I think that that's something
that's that's certainly uh a
warranted um this this the loan business
is a little challenging uh you know we
currently run at least three or four
different banks uh at Dees uh the Old
Bailey Savings and Loan um and um so so
we are Bankers as well as environmental
folks we funds we have a a past fund all
of these are things that and mtbe we
have a whole bunch of these different
funds that we run uh what we know about
that is that they're incredibly labor
intensive uh and it requires outside
parties to do thirdparty review of
finances there's a lot of mechanisms
that go into being a banker as well as
just keeping track of things and making
sure that all of that runs smoothly not
to mention the engineering review that
has to go into the loans that we're
actually uh sending out so so having
some dollars in that now we did have a
loan program uh with the dam Bureau that
was set up in 2004 and was eliminated in
2019 that was funded out of uh
administrative
fines so and the most money that was
ever in that fund was
$70,000 and as you've probably surmised
just from the the dollars that I've been
throwing around in terms of dam repair
$770,000 doesn't buy you very much it
barely gets a consultant out of bed in
the morning uh to look at your Dam so so
putting some dollars into that will be
really important um and then setting up
a new fund this is a this would be a new
fund outside of the dam maintenance fund
the damn maintenance fund itself is
extraordinarly stressed we have about
$1.2 million to do maintenance on 276
dams we are currently getting rid of a
couple of dams uh York Dam in Penacook
is currently being purchased by the
hydro operator and um there's uh another
Dam Warren Dam uh which is currently
going through the whole uh process
through cord uh and uh to go to the town
of
Warren so um the the new the language
that you see in the amendment is largely
based on information out of our srf
programs which are la standing loan
programs and um they um so so some of
the lessons we've learned about that in
terms of the intensity of of Staff need
in order to run those kinds of things
with that I will end and um just point
you towards uh hb1 1277 and SB
549 which would establish commissions
legislative commissions to look at how
we fund the maintenance of dams over
time it was 2004 was the last time that
that issue was brought up in a
comprehensive way and if you look at
this bill it does sort of fit into that
whole rubric of how do we go about
dealing with this you know large number
of of of dams in the state so with that
I will open up myself to any questions
uh that you might have and um thank you
very much for the opportunity thank you
representative L
montin thank you and um thank you for
taking my question when I first saw this
bill and I thought if we're talking
about dams that were are slated for to
demolition to be taken down my thought
was they're being taken down for
environmental reasons not just because
they're in disrepair but most of the
discussion has been about the
disrepair but that would be a concern to
me if um say Dees has said well the
continued existence of this dam is
causing problems with water flow and the
health of the river
Downstream
um but then we turn it over to the town
so they can keep it which I love
historic old dams it's beautiful but I
also know that they're often at the
expense of the health of the river so
how would if we give
up um control of the dam are we
completely giving up control over it as
far as um environmental regulation or
with Dees still want to say well we'll
sell it on the condition that you add
fish ladders or things like that so that
I'm wondering about the environmental
impact that's a that's a great question
thank you very much um and what I would
say is that anytime there's a decision
to remove a dam it's a pretty big deal
with few exceptions and it takes a long
time to get through that process so and
it's almost always by the time we get to
that point there has been uh you know a
lot of discussion in the community
there's been a lot of debate about
whether or not somebody wants to take it
on and do something else with it and
there's there will be a full discussion
in the community about the environmental
benefits this you know Durham is a
really good example right the mil pond
in Durham which Durham already owns that
that damn but they went through this
debate about do we do we keep it do we
keep the dam and restore it at very high
cost because it was also in in in bad
condition or do we remove it and and I
think the Department's position on dam
removal has been that it really There
Are Places which it is an environmental
benefit to do so hands down especially
some of the head of Tide dams and some
other places where fish passage is
really important PCAT quag River happens
to be one of those places because it is
one of the places that the fish and
wildlife service has suggested is one of
the best Fisheries restoration uh
opportunities in the Northeast so again
there's a good opportunity that that
said it has also been our our our
recognition that these and if you look
at the mission in of all of our damn you
know our damn statutes it does Focus
again on those human uses as well so if
this is not the time at which we're
going to R remove that Dam you know
that's okay that's a decision that has
to be made as a as a community and so I
I think that there's going to be the the
the conflict that you described is
possible but unlikely because there are
so few dams that get removed anyway um
for any reason so I think it's a an
unlikely position but it is it certainly
is a
possibility and there are ways around um
providing some of those Wildlife
benefits without removing the dam there
can be fish ladders there could be
nature-like fishways exitor is a good
example we retained part of that
empowerment but put in in a a a nature
likee fish passage that looks like the
stream that actually gets fish up and
over it so there's a place where you
could have your cake and eat it
too okay follow your fish cake question
yeah fish cake yes
follow and do you does dees maintain
some regulation over dams that are owned
by towns or other people that's a great
question and I want to emphatically say
yes we have a whole series of of dam
regulations which we apply not only to
ourselves but to all of the 2600 dams in
the state so there's about 2600 dams
that we regulate in the state we
regulate structures that are greater
than 6 feet in height so um th those
structures we do all all fall under the
the the dam safety rules that we have
they all get inspected by our inspectors
they have a certain inspection schedule
that they have to go in based on their
likely Hood their their their risk that
they that CA that if they were to fail
something bad would happen all of that
plays out regardless of who owns the
dam thank you you
that representative Iran thank you Mr
chair and thank you Mr dear for taking
my question um when uh representative PL
was testifying I had asked him if um in
lie of accessing the loan revolving fund
if a town could take out a bond for the
maintenance and when you or repairs and
when you were speaking about the various
banks that Dees runs I got the sense it
wasn't something that's fun for you uh
with Dees and um and that and then also
there's a lot of it's takes a lot of
time and a lot of engineering to I guess
evaluate any loan
proposals um so what why wouldn't
Dees um I mean would they prefer just a
town go on their own to raise the money
for the for the loan through a bond um
especially if if it takes some time um
they would it wouldn't require DS to do
the engineering but I suppose in the
cost of the loan they would it would
require obviously some project
design I don't know I'm just kind of
wondering if if if a town has those two
options right what would the pr
preference be from your perspective
thank you representative it's um it's
it's uh honestly the legislature rarely
asks us to something this is what we'd
like to do um so it's not really a
question of liking or not liking um if
this is if the state determines that
this is great policy Direction our cons
my concern again and I I sort of am in
charge of budgets and people uh at the
Water Division and so my concern
immediately becomes how do we staff it
how do we make sure that we're doing a
good job for the state and in in because
we are then responsible for shepherding
those dollars and we take that very
seriously and and I if I said it makes
it sound not fun I only um say that the
way I was describing it is that it is a
it is a serious responsibility one that
we take very seriously I love our
revolving loan funds don't get me wrong
they have done we've done 30 we've done
over we've done billions of dollars of
loans that continue to fund amazing
projects in our drinking water and
wastewater projects these this this
state revolving fund stuff has been
really amazing for the state and allows
us a lot of flexibility on how we go
about doing things that's the advantage
of the state having a revolving fund is
that outside of a municipal Bond we have
a lot more flexibility to be able to to
deal with a municipality in different
ways than say the bond market does no
that would be link to the bond market
because the interest rate has to be
somehow set we try not to be in
competition necessarily with the outside
world but we definitely want our
communities to be able to get the best
deal possible now so so anyway I I I
want to just make sure and this is why
you know some of the like we wouldn't
start doing loans until we got to about
200 you know 2.5 million it's not worth
it um it's not worth the staff time to
try to get to that point uh that I put
in some dollars for administrative costs
again it takes people to do these kinds
of things so you know that's the kind of
thing that might would be my concern if
the legislature discerns that this is
you know the a key policy Initiative for
the state and somehow uh the good folks
in in Ways and Means are able to find
the the pennies under the seat cushions
to fund it that's great um I don't think
that you know I don't I don't think that
that's it's not something that is going
to be a problem we know how to do
that
sure represent of Darby thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my
question so um section one of this bill
talks about both
municipalities as well as I think I saw
yeah um other um associations of land
owners or interested
parties section um four on or sorry
under section two and sub paragraph four
right it sort of talks about um the
qualifications yep but really it talks
about property taxes which I think only
applies to
municipalities or or Village districts
or other things that can raise taxes or
right um so my general question um so
I'm a little nervous that the it doesn't
talk about how how these associations of
landowners are going to be vetted but my
broader question is you you started by
describing how expensive it is to
maintain these damps
and it's one thing to sort of repair it
get the loan to repair it but then it
seems like they have to be maintained
over time and so if either the
municipality or the um landowner
Association sort of runs out of money
like who's responsible what happens yeah
I think it's a really good question
representative uh Darby the um you know
this is something that we have problems
with around the state uh we have had uh
itinerant Dam owners um that have
essentially we have corporations that
essentially folded went bankrupt and we
have and there's Dam liability sitting
around um what has happened in the past
is that Dees has a a statute which
allows us to go in and render that
facility to be um sort of take take the
risk out of that facility so we would
either open up the gates permanently
depending on the size of the of the the
facility so it would just run as as the
river so it wouldn't have to be managed
it wouldn't and we would just get it to
a state in which it was acceptable um if
it was a a facility that say had some
Wildlife value or something like that we
would probably go out and try to seek um
grant funding or something to remove it
but there's a chance that it could
result this that that if a if a town
it's hard to imagine town going out of
business but if a Lake Association or
something like that took on one of these
it's possible it could end up being a
state
responsibility any other question for
our
speaker saying none thank you for your
testimony thank you all is there anyone
else who would like to speak on HB 1429
FNA can you please fill out a pink card
and uh take the
stand
thank
you Jim Craig supports the bill Jim
thank you um my name is Jim Craig I'm a
um gtown selectman I'm not here
representing the the select board I'm
here on my own um just as a way of
background I sat with you for
10 years or so in the Judiciary
Committee and uh back back in the day
and it's nice to be here with all of you
and nice to be sitting here uh brings
back a lot of old memories um I wasn't
going to speak when I came up I was
going to listen and support but uh I
used to I I lived in Manchester most of
my life and four or five years ago I
moved to gtown and uh and I really love
it there and uh just to give you some
perspective on this uh back in maybe
September October or November no
probably October um we were at a meeting
of Select select board and uh and it was
and Dees at that point told us that they
were withdrawing um their ownership of
the dam the hadly fall Dam now I don't
know if you if you're familiar with go
sound but it centers um on the pascas
squar river and it's a probably 100 in a
length of a football field wide and
that's where we have all our pumpkin V
and all that stuff matter of fact
there's a ad hoc Committee in town um
which is charged with putting a foot
bridge that fell that that burned down
years ago back over the um over the the
uh River and uh and then um in O again I
think don't I'm not don't quote me but
October maybe um we were told that
um they're they're going to the the the
dam is coming down and uh we're all
sitting there dumbfounded um you know
part of it was I don't think it was done
very well but the part part of the
things I like in this bill is at least a
year we get at least a year notice um
because can you imagine trying to you
know uh figure out what's going to
happen who's going to own and we were
told that um the river was going to
shrink probably from you know the length
of a football field to you know more
like a river maybe 15 20 feet long you
know and put a bridge over something
like that and all kinds of practical
things uh became problems and um there
there's a um there's a development right
next to Hadley Falls uh with I think
almost a 100 units coming in their uh
apartments and uh and it's it's called
Hadley Hadley Falls Dam's apartments and
uh there won't be a Falls there anymore
all those all those kind of things um
were just dropped on us and uh we were
told that it may take uh six or seven
years uh before the dam comes down um we
had a ton of questions um and no answers
um other than we're going to do all the
work necessary to find the answers like
who's going to own the who's going to
own the land in you know that's no
longer under the water um what what's
going to happen to it um how much is
there going to be um you know all those
kind of things uh that we didn't have
answers to and so um you know we still
don't that you know we we're still
waiting for some of those um those tests
and and um reports to come back uh to
see how much it would cost actually cost
to repair it um some people would like
to repair it um I don't think it's I
think it's going to be cost prohibitive
um and again I don't speak for the board
speak for myself here um but I just kind
of wanted to give you a flavor on what
could happen happen to us could happen
to you your towns um and uh one thing
that I like and and I would if you're
going to move forward with this um in
the first paragraph on line four it says
at least one year prior to removing the
dam uh the process takes about I'm told
six or seven years um
so it may be esoteric but um prior to
beginning I would prefer it to say prior
to REM beginning the process of removing
um so we and not you know a year because
if you read this technically and uh it's
what I used to do so um you know they
could wait until this one year left and
then then offer it to us um and the
other thing that so I I you know that
that's one thing that caught my eye and
the other thing that that's good is U
you know we would get a year each town
would get at least a year to to think
about about all these things and figure
out whether it's possible what's
possible and what's not possible and uh
you know we're given uh paragraph 3
Roman 3 um we would be provided with all
documentation and things so that we can
make you know get Engineers or whatever
and make um intelligent choices on you
know what are we going to bring to the
voters and what um this is this has
resulted in um a couple of
uh uh public hearings and uh the dees
has been very cooperative and come down
explained everybody's um everybody's
questions and uh the public hearing is
probably what 100 to 200 people appeared
and it's a Maj you know it's a big deal
in our town um I get I understand um the
reasons that Dees is doing what it's
doing um but I'm asking for some
consideration for the towns and as you
heard there's you know 200 uh and and
you know most of the dams I guess are
not
um they're not as up front as this one
is this one's right in the middle of
town and and it and it's going to affect
um the character of the town no matter
what happens um so so I just wanted you
to provide a little background of why
this came up and uh there's got to be a
better way to do this so with that um
entertain any questions if there are any
any questions for the
speaker don't see any so thank you for
your testimony is there anyone else that
wants to speak on
1429 I'll ask one more time anyone else
to speak on 1429 seeing no one
approaching the stand I'll close the
hearing on hb1 1429
FNA and I'll ask for any pink cards on
hb1
1477 FN I'll open the hearing on
1477 FN relative to environmental shity
bonds for for businesses that pose a
significant risk to the state's natural
resources and I think we're going to get
a couple in a
minute
it's 1477 it's not
there I should have asked while we're
waiting for the pink cards can maybe
representative Darby can you grab the
blue sheets on
1429 maybe just give us a
count and it's
oh it's in the
back if you just give us a count for and
against if there's any on it none okay
that's
easy9 89 for two against 89 for two
against
CL from now you have no
idea
so opening the hearing on hb1
1477 FN the prime sponsor is with US
Representative
potenta you have the
floor that's a z and that's a t I'm not
CCT
sorry I didn't see it and then I was
thinking that it wasn't here and then I
went in the hallway and panicked and
thinking it wasn't in this room and I'm
like I know it said this so um my name
is representative Kelly Penza from
straford District 19 um I'm the sponsor
of this bill uh so I put this in
actually um not truly understanding to
the extent of I knew a little bit but
not enough and um this was through
several constituents so you know just
for everybody that might not be aware
what an environmental security bond is
um you know they're required there's
required types of shity bonds that are
needed for of course environmental
contractors they're put in place to
protect environmental Integrity when
large or small construction projects
involve any number of environmental
risks they include performance and
payment charity bonds when the
contaminated property is being um
remediated and of course license and
permise bonds for it could be for
landfills Wetland mitigation chemical
plants plastic and rubber producers and
on and
on and other industries of course that
impact uh the environment so
environmental secy bonds really
guarantee that the contractors and other
service providers will comply with
federal state and local regulations and
environmental policies um in in so many
in the smallest way or the
uh um
the most succinct way to say it it is
actually putting um you know the the
business The Entity they on the hook
instead of the taxpayers and that's how
it should be or the state so um so the
state's not on the hook or the taxpayers
not on the hook which really always
comes down to the taxpayers so they're
designed to prevent of course and um
prevent or repair environmental damage
by covering construction projects and ha
hazardous materials um included in the
bond term so like who needs this right
um you know there's coal Burning uh
storage facilities um usually have a
closure Bond landfills usually have a sh
there's different um different levels of
bonds that you can get but a shity bond
is one for the closing of the landfill
um you know construction firms
especially if they're going to be
digging in any sort of dirt um that have
environmental components asbest lead
petrol chemicals um environmental
remediation contractors who need that
kind of like extra bonding capacity uh
depending on what they find uh and then
of course manufacturing companies whose
processes generate byproducts that
remain um that remain in residual
landfills not in our landfills
necessarily but um landfills that could
be because of course most of our
hazardous waste pretty much all of our
hazardous waste in New Hampshire is
we're paying for that to be
removed and um you know just some things
that uh shity Bond can cover uh esus
removal contaminated material disposal
uh sediment control soil remediation
underground tank removal uh well plug
and well plug and abandonment um I just
wanted to speak on that one specifically
since that has happened uh all
throughout New Hampshire uh as um as
everybody's probably aware well on our
committee anyway I'm on environment and
agriculture um and I think it was first
discovered in the early 20 thousands in
regards with peace Air Force Base and
the level of pollution that has taken
place there you know who's responsible
of this is it the federal government is
it is it the state entity um there's
been many people impacted there are
current still pending lawsuits um and
there's tons of questions I mean most of
these folks were were literally uh
drinking tainted water bathing drinking
cooking in it um for over a decade and
uh in it in it SP and there's tons of
Wells that are of course all
decommissioned and have huge levels of
not just the you know the the forever
chemicals that we're talking about
everybody's talking about poas uh p
pfoas and stuff like that
so this is just such the Smart M to move
forward and I know that there's uh
there's a couple issues with the bill
that could definitely um be that that is
no problem to have an amendment um the
you know the commissioner came and and
and you know came out and said that that
he had some issues with the bill and I
I'd like to talk about some of those
issues because it looks as if he's you
know acting as if this is putting them
in a position where they're going to
have to be responsible for for these
things and it's this is um this provides
funds to cover litigation that would
lead to continuous litigation so the
bill like in no way would change like
prerequisites to file any kind of claim
and that's stated in here and it that's
just not true um it would also reduce
the chance that taxpayers would end up
having to foot the bill um for harms
that you know like bankrupt or shell
companies C that that you know shell
companies that have caused and then we
try to seek to avoid that I'm just going
to give you an example um I'm going to
use a I'm going to use waste management
for example so
uh or landfills so we you have waste
management that is always underneath
Waste Management their name and we have
another private company that um
literally creates uh multiple llc's so
you can open up a landfill you close it
you decommission it that business
doesn't exist anymore they bankrupt it
and it's all done and you can't get
anything out of that and then it comes
back to the EPA gets involved it becomes
a super fund site and then the taxpayers
are on the hook for that so in I'm going
to grab some of my information here so
in December of
2013 that was um there were 20 super
fund sites around the state that was 10
years ago and there's many more um since
then and you know once it's a super fund
site it kind of stays that way forever
and I could give lots of examples and
I'm going to email you a bunch of my
testimony because I have tons of attack
attachments and just a lot of wealth of
information where I've been researching
for you can for you to understand how
this is so necessary uh to have in the
state but the tanneries they started
polluting the state um in the early you
know
1950s and those areas are are never to
be built upon like you're that's kind of
dead land so once it's you know it's all
monitored there's monitoring RS you know
all you know um all around those
properties but you know we can't you're
not going to be able to build you know
a a condo uh facility there or anything
like that and as you know which was um
in um which was in the house the last
time the place up north uh the the
logging Mill that was actually built on
property that was kind of like dead
property because it was where an old
Tannery was as well um but you have
there's a huge case of course that was
was with the EPA that happened in naswa
we're talking about in bosan in Penacook
those tanneries um and we all know the
one that's glaring right in front of us
now which is St coob and um and I think
what bothers me the most is that we knew
in 2004 we knew it they they got their
permit in 2000 and they bought that
company from another Plastics Company
and in 2004 we we knew there was a
problem with the air we didn't do
anything and and then um by 2016 we're
realizing that people's Wells are
contaminated over a thousand Wells now
that has spread it's not just in marac
it's maram it's Lichfield it's Hollis
it's Bedford once things are in the
water table um I had talked to a
grandmother on the phone and you know
she's uh she's riddled with tumors at
this point uh she continued to drink the
water and you know all that was provided
was bottled water and they were were
still fighting we got millions of
dollars in this state and they were
still fighting to get um like full whole
you know water
systems and that's mindboggling to me
could you imagine living in a home you
know a $500,000 home using bottled water
for seven years like this stuff to me
just doesn't make any sense and if
there's a shity bond that was in place
which I don't believe there is because
what did they do s Cain is now Cut and
Run and now we're going to try figure it
out after the fact how many more years
of these people's property that are you
know nobody's going to want to buy that
home if they want to if they want to
sell it and a shity bond would actually
um compensate of course the cleanup and
and would be backed by all of that
because they would have had it to begin
with um Dees talks about uh you know
having to get more staff and monitor and
all of that there are I mean almost
every single state
has some level of this going on in their
state um if you look on de's website
they talk specifically about shity bonds
um in regards with landfills and that
you know they give different types of
funding options that you could pick uh
if you'd like to um you know the shy
bonds is one there's a couple other ones
that they give as resources because
you're going to have to have something
in place for when you close that
landfill just for cleanup for monitoring
all of that that so this isn't something
that would take an an we wouldn't have
to have designated people they they kind
of give a worst case scenario here there
is very simple you know um there's very
simple criteria that could be looked at
and the work isn't done by Dees it's
done by the whoever you're trying to per
give the permanent to so um I have I
could talk talk about this for a long
time and I I don't know how long your
committee's been going but I've been
going all day I wanted to read I wanted
to read one thing that is um so this
affects um straford County this is
affects a
constituent uh well several constituents
and um a state representative and it's
it's really sad so if nobody's heard
about the when they demolished the
Davidson it used to be called Davidson
Rubber Factory that was four decades
basically of manufacturing so one worker
this was like where they were just kind
of thinking back her name was Louise
Korn she was hired in October of
1966 she spent 36 years with the company
as it prospered it did extremely well
they moved up in the rankings they were
doing rubber manufacturing um all over
the
country so she went through several
different Transformations it also went
through several different hands and
eventually it of course withered out and
became a large part of a the American
manufacturing base so um and they were
kind of sold out because of Cheaper
labor rates as we all know this is her
quote they used to pour the chemicals in
the brook out back they didn't know any
better back then said Korn this was the
stream that ran through the plant under
Route 11 and the federal aquifer into
which was into which was sunk the town
well that was subsequently knocked out
of commission they used to quote they
used to bury everything from soups to
nuts out back I don't know how they'll
sell that land said K so right now
there's there's been and I can give you
kind of an update on that but it's 123
acre uh kind of like uh partially
partially developed parcel in Farmington
but as we know it it doesn't matter if
somebody pollutes you know 5T when you
get into the water table that's it it's
game over and it's the same thing that
has to do with like a St gobain you know
it wasn't confined to just marac where
their plant was located it is now in
what seven different seven different
cities towns in New Hampshire
so this um they're still they're still
fighting this there's people's
properties that are right there that are
that are worth nothing now no one would
ever buy that property uh there's a a
person their family is a family of four
um they now have they all have um
they've all had found cancer this this
is the voc's which are in the top 10 of
the most deadliest compounds that you
can find on a site so um I'd love to you
know put all of this in writing and kind
of dispel some of the myths that are in
here I don't believe this fiscal note is
even necessary um you know I'm
conservative I don't want us to have to
spend more money I think that that we
have the resources in place uh that we
can do this and um and I think it's
great for um this is a nonpartisan thing
we should have people that are coming
here that are working with um with
poisonous substances make sure that um
that it holds them accountable if
something does happen and it's more than
just being able to have that Safeguard I
think
that when when you have someone that has
a shity bond it also is kind of a they
know that they're going to comply like
they have they already have you're
you're you're kind of mitigating risks
they're signing on something where
they're saying okay we're going to be
legally compliant you know that they're
coming in here and they're not going to
have to worry about having a shell
company or starting up about a new name
in bankrupt and cut and run when
something is um is that is that dire
so um any
questions do anyone yes represent have
been wrong thank you very much Mr chair
and thank
you and thank you representative Penza
for bringing this forward um
representative healing and I are from
miramac so we know um you know what the
cost we've had to do in our town to deal
with the Senco Bain issue um and boy it
would have been great to have them
upfront have the the the resources and
and take responsibility for that so I
think this is definitely on the right
track but but I do have some questions
um one is um there there are many
hazards many many contaminations that
happen throughout the country a year
with let's say fuel trucks or tanker
trucks that derail or there's an
accident I mean there was a huge issue
in Palestine Ohio um I'm not I don't
know if that's really well defined in
here Transportation
incidences it's and that's one of the
biggest sources um and then like if
there are
contractors uh where a company might and
this happens where there may be a a toll
manufacturer so let's say there may be a
company that
produces uh some type of a chemical
product but they may contract out uh
let's say uh in process step so maybe
they they may purchase the raw materials
but have another company do produ ction
and synthesis of this intermediate and
they might finish it off and and I'm not
sure that's that's included um and then
what if a company during the course of
their operations decides to change
switch out of material or assume
production of a new product um if we're
only expecting the shity bond at the
time of Licensing I'm not sure we might
capture that um and then one example
yesterday I was testifying at I provided
testimony at a Senate bill regarding the
salting of Continental Boulevard in
miramac and the salting by the state has
contaminated one of our wells to the
point that we had to shut it down and
build a new one um so you know would the
state something like that be captured so
I'm just wondering if you would
entertain maybe uh an amendment that
maybe instead of of this bill maybe
might put together a study committee to
look at all these different factors um
to make sure that whatever is is really
very comprehensive and covers all the
you know dots the eyes and crosses the
te's I think it's hard to be to have a
one c one size fits all because that's
if we can this is this is going to take
care of a huge issue a huge gap that
we're not requiring where almost every
other state in some capacity is I
understand right if a transportation if
a big Transportation um company is
coming in through a truck and there's a
spill
99% of the time that is covered because
they're under a huge National umbrella
so we're covered by a lot of those
things automatically now of course if
it's something that happens with the
state um but you know we're on the hook
for that and there there's not really
there's not really much that we can do
um um I do want to speak to fuel stuff
so New Hampshire had and I'm trying to
think of when this was was it 200 12 uh
I'll send you that too about mtbe so we
had the largest uh we had literally we
got the largest settlement from that and
so if you look in the folks that are out
in East Swansea so it's very very small
town and they have been begging for
years and it's kind of kind of Fallen
deaf ears and they haven't done much
about it about a cancer cluster because
of the mtbe poisoning from under
underground tanks uh in regards with
petroleum they haven't gotten a dime of
that money we got
$263 million and there
is I've seen the whole their their they
have a chart of all of these homes and
becau and there's cancer throughout the
entire family to include you know
children and it's
where is that money gone what are they
using what is our state using for those
things and it's um that's the kind of
stuff that doesn't make sense we've
gotten some big settlements and if we're
not using that to help folks that are
that have been infected by like mtbe all
of that ground poisoning then we should
be using that in other places like that
money should be used in in with what's
going on with St Cain that money is a
huge settlement and should be dispersed
out and that can happen through the
executive branch and our and our Council
so I believe that this is the first step
if I've missed something that we could
catch here great I also don't want it to
be too restrictive that this doesn't go
through either I want to make sure that
it is not um it's it's not going to
restrict Dees from being able to do what
they need to do but it also it can be
there's there are specific um there are
specific Industries and companies and
manufacturers that we know produce toxic
waste and that kind of thing so we can
we can hit those up and and then as
moving forward we've had nothing go on
for decades and it's it's time
so follow up yeah I just want to point
out that the mtbe settlement money uh to
my knowledge funded the drinking water
and groundwater trust fund and marac did
tap into that to help uh defray the
expenses of uh building our past
treatment plants so just to let you know
that that fund exists any other
questions representative
lonte I really appreciate your
motivation
and I really appreciate your the
motivation behind this Bell and I agree
it's very important it just does seem
so broad um
and I'm wondering like the line where
you require persons working in that in
such
Industries um would that apply to every
employee of the company or uh the owner
of the company or the board of directors
um that's one of the little changes
we're going to make in Amendment the
other you know the task of looking at
the many ways that any industry or
enterpr Riser or process could affect
the air water and soil that that is an
enormous task to try to put a dollar
value on that and think it all the way
through um that would require some money
and you said well the people applying
for the the um the license would be the
ones to do that well well they would
have an incentive to downplay what those
costs would
be so there just seems to be
um many aspects of this that aren't
quite thought out yet and that's I kind
of agree with representative Run's idea
that um we consider studying this
further so this was I guess this was a
bill that was put in before I'm a new
representative and uh it was I don't I
don't think it was studied and then it
was ited so this has gone around a
little bit I'm gonna speak to Yes um one
persons needs clarification to mean the
owner operator of the business rather
than any individual that will be changed
um you know the blackl language um of
the bill is you know fairly clear though
that legal actions would be against
polluting businesses of course not Dees
because that was one thing in their
letter as well um the other uh there was
one thing
here let me
see
okay
so um at once needs to be specif against
gener okay so of course this isn't just
because I'm I'm mean Anda and the
landfills are you know that's you know
that's kind of the Hot Topic or whatever
but this generally really needs to
reflect the need for shy bonding for
other types of highrisk polluting land
uses and in that regard that's where
most of the research that I've done is
so when you are putting together a
proposal to build a $50 million $100
million facility all of that stuff is
already there this this is industry
standard information so for you to be
worried that they could undercut that it
just doesn't happen it we're talking
about stuff that is already a known it's
a known entity we know what we know
there's already formulas for cleanups
for landfills for cleanups for old
school buildings all of that stuff has
been in place for a very very long time
the EPA has tons of documents on this
they so I'm just saying that all of that
work has been done for a long time for
plastic producers uh uh rubber
manufacturers ones that are emitting any
of course you know the forever chemicals
which are newer um but those are really
on the radar at this point but all of
the dioxane uh one through for uh voc's
all of that kind of stuff is is really a
known entity in that manufacturing so
this isn't something that they would
have to do Dees wouldn't have to do that
work and this is already information
that is really on a known entity so just
to speak to
that representative
Bale thank you Mr chair thank you for
your testimony
representative um so recently we have
come up against an asphalt plant being
built in the middle of Nashville
something that really concerns us it's
right in the middle of four schools and
the most congested part of our city it's
also in the worst Economic Opportunity
in End Zone and that's probably not by
mistake so we had public hearings and I
went in and I asked for that company to
bond a cleanup but as I was coming back
to my seat I'm like well who measures
how much that would be and how do we
come to that kind of determination who
would be involved besides me in a city
public hearing so I just um have some
questions about
that so just because we're working on
all the new rules for like permitting
landfills I'm just going to give you
that example so and that's just one at
the Solid Waste Department you know in
Dees is just one of many different all
these areas so them along with the EPA
have those expertise so the asphalt
company that is coming in for example
they do it based upon size a based upon
scope employees production all of that
stuff when when because no matter what
they are going to have to get a permit
from Dees it's going to have to happen
so it's none of those none of those
folks are going to be able to just come
in purchase a piece of property when uh
it can have it an environmental impact
and just start building that's what I'm
saying all of that stuff is all those
formulas that are in place they know
that because they're building it they
know what kind of they know what kind of
waste is going to be outputed all of
that kind of stuff so it's really you
know the agency that is controlling that
the city of course is going to be able
to through you know uh public input um
through petitions if if you guys don't
want it you're going to have to Rally
your troops to to to make sure that it's
not there and get your city council to
to you know to uh reject that that can
happen on that level but if it does get
approved and it comes all that whole
process um just like it is for the
permanent process for a landfill um same
thing for a permanent process for a
Plastics Company all of the work that St
Cain did
um was uh you know was I don't want I
just say rubber stamp and approved but
there was
already uh um it made it easier for Dees
and that should have been looked at
because they were purchasing something
else that was already there um and maybe
that's something that could be in there
too like if it's a a current a sitting
structure a business that has been um
shut down because they're selling or
getting out then um then it needs to go
through the same process if someone's
purchasing that property and putting
another business in there if it's the
same type so
I I think that I want this to go through
so I want impact uh like I said I am not
an expert I'm going to um um but I'm a
dog on a bone for research so whatever
you guys are going to give me I will um
I will work on this and I I think it's
just we need this level of protection
and to be honest if if you want to come
into the state and and and produce
whatever you're producing and even
though it has you know it has some some
negative toxic waste that comes with it
if you are handling it appropriately in
the right way um so you're providing you
know whatever Service as well you're
providing jobs but you're also doing the
right thing for the environment I'm all
for that I think we have to have that
balance and I want to make sure that
this bill covers that because I I want
this to go through I think that this is
a this is a bipartisan nonpartisan this
is great for our New Hampshire citizens
and we need this
now thank you representative I have a
question what if the shity company will
not issue a bond in the amount that is
analyzed that says that you need to
have so I brought that question up when
um when the constituent asked me to file
this and so I went to look I just
started do some research to see how many
were like rejected and the only ones
that I could find really were ones that
had companies that had bad track records
so it's just like anything else if um
you know insurance if I'm a heavy
drinker and and smoker and all of that
my life insurance is going to be more so
the usually there's not a Flatout denial
if someone had had problems in the past
and um our company had problems in the
past and they wanted to write the ship
yes their rates were higher but it was
always determined on okay so you have
one for in colado I think it was they
had to have a 15-year track record they
were able to issue the security Bond but
they had to have a 15-year track record
and um and then once that their rates
would go down so there's incentives to
be able to do that the O I didn't really
see many that were a Flatout denial the
only ones that are Flatout denials are
companies that we wouldn't want here in
New Hampshire
anyway thank you any other questions for
the
representative seeing none thank you for
your testimony thanks Ted deers New
Hampshire
Dees hey
no Mr chair members of the committee I
am still Ted deers I am the assistant
director of the division at the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services I have a letter of testimony uh
going around you've already seen uh a
fiscal note uh that we prepared um I
think that there's some places where a
representative um Penza and the
department would agree wholeheartedly uh
on this and that is certainly that uh
certainly polluters should pay uh that
is I think a basic premise of this and
the concept of that is absolutely I
think in keeping with with other state
policies um and and certainly uh you
know to be to be worried about you know
sort of future uh issues that might uh
come up with a license that gets um you
know that gets
created that said um we definitely the
way that this bill is written right now
we would have to oppose and largely
because it is extraordinarily General
and I think this was brought up in some
of the questioning um it was it's
sounded like from the testimony that it
was is meant to to apply to toxics or or
to other things that may be specifically
harmful to humans uh that's not outlined
in this particular Bill language um and
it also is very clear that the
commissioner that is the department
would play a significant role in
determining actual value of potential
future damages um and that is something
that we don't have a lot of experience
doing would require a lot we believe a
significant amount amount of staff and
expertise in order to be able to do that
the bill doesn't um set up an authority
to write rules so it appears that it
would actually rely on other rules so
that's not clear how that would play out
um and I would just point out to you all
that the Department issues on the order
of
10,000 different permit or 10,000
individual permits and licenses on an
annual basis so does this apply to all
of those because we wouldn't necessarily
be giving you a license uh or a permit
if you didn't have um the potential to
pollute the air water or soil right so
if you look at the overall statutes does
this apply to all of those I think that
we heard from the testimony it was meant
to apply to some subset of those that's
not indicated within this particular
Bill uh like I said I don't think that
we have a lot of experience in this
world so I we would need to understand a
lot more about it before we were able to
I think provide um more technical
assistance in crafting a bill uh I tend
to think that this idea of studying it a
little bit more makes some sense again
given the concept itself is is certainly
an important one of understanding how do
we pay for future problems uh that our
children or grandchildren shouldn't have
to inherit so I I I certainly think that
we're willing to to participate in
future discussions as a department um
and happy to answer any questions that
you might have here today thank you very
much thank you any
questions representative
Kelly thank you Mr deers for being here
today so I guess my question you might
probably don't have the numbers on hand
but uh so Berlin where I'm where I'm
representing one has one of the most
famous super fund sites in the state um
dating back to 1999 and the the and I I
I didn't know if the department has any
figure about how much it cost because
the department was responsible for the
original excavation of all the Mercury
on the site uh back in
1999 and and and I'm wondering because
the the final uh settlement with Georgia
Pacific who eventually took ownership of
the assets uh there the final owner of
the assets uh settled with the EPA for
about
$500,000 which the size of the plot will
likely be what they get in real estate
for that transaction and so I'm
wondering if the department ever
recouped any of the funds beside you
know I'm assuming the cost was greater
than $500,000 so I'm wondering if
the department was on the hook for that
taxpayers were on the hook for that so
thank you very much for your question
and I will have to answer that I have no
idea uh that's in a waste division
that's in their the super fund program
and we would have to get somebody from
Super fund to speak to that I think
those are the kinds of questions that
the committee might want to look more
more fully into and um but in terms of
if you'd like to know how much was spent
on that site to date I will absolutely
get that information sent over to
you any other questions from Mr
deers seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you have a great
day opposing the bill Gary
Abbott Association of general
contractors Mr
Abbot thank you uh chairman
committee members for the record my name
is Gary Abbott I'm the Executive Vice
President of the associated general
contractors of New Hampshire I represent
uh large commercial and industrial
building and Highway
contractors and I come here today in
opposition to the
bill the language in the bill is
probably the first concern but let me
understand who I
represent in the building industry or
Highway industry we're very familiar
with bonds performance bonds
construction bonds and of course the
first knee knee-jerk reaction is this is
just another Bond are we adding this to
our our projects and what's the cost
because understand what a bond is it's
somebody has to pay for the bond for the
coverage and the insurance company is
taking a risk and the cost of those
bonds depends on a lot of factors and
what the risk factors are when you look
at the structure of this it doesn't
really say permitting which I heard in
testimony prior to me it says
licensing those are different things
there's a lot of different uh parts of
Dees that we get permits from there are
certain sections like air resources that
we kind of have a license or a permit to
admit so it's a little unclear who this
applies to and how it applies so when
you look at that there's also a cost and
I think you the chairman brought up a
very good question about uh what happens
if you can't get a bond or what happens
if exceeds reasonable for the operation
even to continue in New Hampshire for
whatever it produces lot of unknowns it
sounds like a a very easy Bill like
you're passing a bill that's you're
going to mandate a bond and you're fully
protected well for how many years and
how much does this cost and what's the
impact on the companies so I represent
companies that would have to pay so
there's a lot of detail missing from
this bill just how this would work we
also feel like we already pay an awful
lot of bonds that are required either
whether they're required from the
municipality or the state in order to
perform construction work so we're
already feeling like you have the
protection of a construction
project even through the permit process
we're agreeing with Dees on Ser certain
permits whether we're getting a Wetlands
permit or any other permit and trust me
if we fail they're going to find us and
we're going to be in trouble so we think
the protection is there I guess this
bill just needs a lot more clarification
if it is after super high risk or a
defined group um and one of the things
uh super vun sites anybody who's ever
been involved in one of those if you
touched any of those products the
federal government's after you for money
and so it's not it's not a a left town
and I'm not not not involved because I
remember some in my early days superf
fund sites that even some of our
contractors who move product from a
super fund site they were all under the
umbrella under the feds it wasn't the
state but it was the whole super fund
site
so I don't think anybody's liability is
off the hook uh under this but we just
looked at this I think the winner is the
insurance companies we're not so sure
about all the other players involved in
the process and so I'm here today that
the the language needs to be
dramatically changed if that's what
you're after and know what you're
looking for because I think there's
going to be a lot of unintended
consequences on people that have been
operating for years getting either
permits or licenses that don't need a
further Bond so with that I would end my
testimony and answer any
questions representative
Kelly thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr AB for being here so my question it
it's tangentially related and I I'm
wondering if you'd be interested in this
so a lot of talk recently has been about
the amount of CND construction
demolition waste that's ending up in
landfills it's it's the it's a I don't
know if it's the majority but it's close
to the majority of waste that's going
into the landfills currently so my
question is if there was some type of
waiver in this so that that like the the
question's been asked about how do we
get less CND waste into our land fs and
there's plenty of programs out there
that companies like producers are doing
to try to recycle their own Goods they
know how to do it but they it's how do
we get it into their hands so if there
was some incentive let's say like if you
were able to cut your construction
demolition demolition waste by 50% then
you would have a waiver from this policy
is is that something that you think
could work do you
know we are actually talking about
um construction waste has been you know
I've
been after Clos I've been around here 40
years we've talked about construction
waste before and
Recycling and we've been through a lot
we've had bills that we've directed that
we we did certain things uh glass those
kind of things sometimes it doesn't work
out financially or feasible and so we've
gone through an awful lot of
construction debris contractors want to
be the most efficient way they can get
rid of material as well and it all
depends on cost and as you probably know
you know there was a whole recycling
effort a lot of people Recycling and
suddenly that costs more than allinone
so it's a complicated area I don't want
to hear
say we're always open to those
suggestions but clearly what it comes
down to is
economics uh what I've learned over time
you know the econ if the economics are
there it'll happen and in some cases on
some construction projects they save the
brick they save other things because
it's economical to sell the used brick
so some of that already happens so
construction debris gets sometimes it's
used but I'm not so sure people
understand when we did recycle glass our
industry got totally involved and looked
at it all but believe it or not we New
Hampshire doesn't produce enough glass
to to you know to make it effective in
using it as a product in the field so I
I'm just giving you that my history of
it's complicated we've looked at a lot
of things we've even done rubber in
roads and I can tell you the issues that
happened there but construction's always
looking for the best way to use
materials and save so I I think that's
the same on the town end to try to
eliminate how much it costs that's
coming in that uh you know is costing
you and uh you know taking care of
waste any other questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else that
wishes to testify on hb1
FN ask one more time anyone else to
testify hb1 1477
FN don't see anyone coming how about
the the blue sheets do we have anybody
sign in on the blue
sheet
two opposed and one in favor on the blue
sheets
online we have 68 in support and zero
oppos zero
neutral and I hereby close the hearing
on HB
1477 FN we'll start the next Hearing in
our last one of the day at 3:00 thank
you
of
remembered that
as
you
second
yes
okay
no
AB
you
yes answer your
question
I mean I think we're on the same
page I didn't get CH to your
name testified another bill right you
went up and I was in the back and I had
to go right out and then I came back
like well we for the
day
no oh really
y likein
and'll yeah absolutely nice to meet
you
that's my butt good afternoon I'm
calling uh the hearing on HB 1709 FM to
order establishing a tax on land used
for carbon credits our first speaker is
the prime sponsor representative Kelly
representative Kelly you have the
floor thank you chairman and thank you
committee for allowing me to speak today
um I want to start by saying uh lock
yourselves in it's a little long I
apologize I know it's the end of the day
if anybody falls asleep my entire
testimon is online so you can go get
catch you up
there okay I am representative Aman
Kelly representing Berlin Carol
Jefferson and Whitefield although there
is a certain situation in Northern Coos
making news stories right now I want to
start by saying that this bill is not
meant to deal with that issue that issue
highlighted an important question
however and I hope that this bill will
open a conversation on how to begin to
answer that first a little history the
last line of part two Article 5 of the
State Constitution reads for the purpose
of encouraging conservation of the
forest resources of the state the
general court May provide special
assessments rates and taxes on growing
wood and Timber that line was added in
1942 following years of debate on the
value of this growing timber at the time
the state had only three main sources of
revenue alcohol tobacco and horse racing
whatever the state couldn't fund with
that Revenue was delegated to towns to
fund through property taxes as spending
on these three vices diminished during
the Great Depression and nearly
disappeared during World War II towns
were left on their own to Levy higher
and higher property taxes at the time
the value of Timber on a property was
considered part of the assessment it
meant that Forest land was only
desirable in the year or two before it
was harvested it also meant that younger
trees were more of a liability than an
asset and so when Cuts were done the
whole forest was brought to the ground
many of the depressing photos of the
White Mountains completely bald from
clear cutting come from this pre- 1942
era recognizing that these practices
were a serious threat to long-term
Forest management goals the state acted
and ratified the amendment with a 71%
Statewide vote it would be another seven
years before the legislature approved
the timber tax as we know it today the
only excise tax approved by our
constitution the Declaration of policy
at the beginning of that bill makes
clear the legislature's intent it is the
declared purpose of this act to
encourage conservation of the forest
resources of the state by releasing
growing wood and Timber from the yearly
burden of local property taxes and
substituting a yield tax so as to give
an incentive to the owners of standing
Timber to abandon destructive cutting
practices in favor of long-range Forest
management plans and to promote the
restocking of depleted Forest lands by
conserving an understory of immature
trees of desirable species it is further
designed to provide a continuous
sustained yield of wood and Timber for
New Hampshire wood using Industries and
to stabilize employment in those
Industries to maintain Forest lands at
their maximum productiveness to protect
the water resources of the state to
minimize the effects of droughts and to
maintain a more constant water level in
Wells Springs streams and Public Water
Supplies it is also the purpose of this
act to benefit the agricultural
industrial and recreational interests of
the state and to provide healthful
surroundings Scenic
values and improved conditions for
fishing
game at the time of its passage in 1949
the state's Forest cover was 84% and
with a current rate of around 82% we can
say it was a relative success that bill
included two key Provisions that should
help us understand its context for
today's hearing first it included a 30%
tax break for land owners who could
prove they were using good Forest
management practices in 1973 that
provision would be supplanted by the
current use program that we have today
the second provision from the 1949
Timber tax bill and the one that is most
important for this hearing was the
creation of a state fund to offset the
loss of property taxes from the new bill
if the town's tax collection dropped
below the 5e pre- timber tax average
then the state would loan them the
difference the town would then reimburse
the state in future years when Timber
tax collection led to a surplus
Revenue the fund was meant to be self-
sustaining as towns paid in some years
and withdrew in others this clearly
shows that the timber taxes were meant
to merely act as a delayed property tax
device they are essentially property
taxes collected when the timber is
harvested okay so history done the next
step in understanding today's bill is
grasping the concept of carbon credits I
think it first helps to break the system
into two categories the regulated market
and the voluntary Market the regulated
market are systems imposed by
governments these are often referred to
as cap and trade programs every business
in a state or a country is given a
yearly cap on their emissions they can
either lower their own emissions below
that cap or pay other businesses to
offset their emissions by doing things
that re remove carbon from the
atmosphere each year the cap is lowered
the demand for offsets Rises and with
that so does the value California has
the only regulated market here in the US
but there are many other markets around
the world the voluntary Market is much
more complex and harder to grasp due to
the rising importance of ES G metrics
investors have placed increasing Demand
on large large corporations to prove
their ability to recognize how their own
emissions are affecting our climate for
many large companies like Delta or Exxon
Mobile this has meant voluntary funding
program project voluntarily funding
projects that purport to fight climate
change this has led to a whole new
industry of carbon Traders working in a
dozen uh in dozens of different
exchanges with hundreds of project
developers marketers regulators and
certification authorities it is an
extremely complex web of businesses with
very little
disclosure in both the regulated and
voluntary markets there are currently
dozens of ways to produce a carbon
offset in most situations they are sold
as emissions reduction tons and are
equivalent to removing one ton of CO2
from the atmosphere this could be
something like the capturing and reuse
of landfill methane gas which would
traditionally be vented or burned by a
landfill although we don't have S much
insight into the voluntary Market nearly
80% of all credits on the California
Market have been sold in the form of
forest carbon Forest credits fall into
three types aforestation credits where
you are protecting land that is under
threat of complete deforestation
reforestation credits where you are
planting a new Forest on deforested land
and improved Forest management credits
where forestry practices are changed to
improve carbon retention these ifm
credits are by far the most popular
representing 84% of forest carbon
credits and 67% of all credits sold on
the California
Market Behind These Forest carbon
credits is a whole bunch of math
companies looking to sell these credits
on a regulated exchange must pass the
muster of private certification
authorities growing scrutiny in the
industry has led to a very rigorous and
complex system project developers must
complete surveys to document tree growth
tree species threats and numerous other
factors to properly quantify that the
carbon that will be captured over the
life of the credit which in the case of
the California Market are a staggering
100 years to prove their numbers to the
certification Authority the project
developer must produce a greenhouse gas
project plan this plan can be hundreds
of pages long and details the Baseline
scenario and the with project scenario
showing how many more tons of CO2 will
be captured by the changes in Forest
management practices they are
proposing so we have a history of of the
Timber tax and we have a basic grasp of
these Forest carbon credits so now let's
talk about why we're here today these
carbon credits which are wholly
conceived bought and sold outside the
state of New Hampshire are nonetheless
generated here and directly offset
traditional harvesting of Timber without
a new mechanism the delayed property
taxes on these properties will never be
collected and therefore local property
tax players will be subsidizing the
production of something created entirely
for the benefit of those outside the
state of New Hampshire we must tackle
this issue head-on and develop a system
that fairly balances Forest carbon with
traditional Timber practi
practices one of the arguments given in
the most recent case making the local
news was that carbon credits were
currently much more profitable than
harvesting and selling the timber no
doubt they are because in this current
system the government is subsidizing
them this activity is only set to become
even more prevalent in New Hampshire as
caps and regulated markets get lower
each year and other companies adopt
other countries adopt similar systems
the value of credits will continue to
rise exponentially additionally the
complexity of calculations traditionally
limit generators to lot sizes of 100
acres or more but just last August the
federal government announced $150
million in funds to include lot sizes
down to 50 acres Additionally the nature
conservancy and others have created
their own program on the voluntary
Market to pull together many small land
owners in a fashion similar to how
subprime mortgages are bundled and sold
what I'm proposing in this bill is my
first attempt at this I am not a lawyer
or a tax expert it took legislators six
years to create the first timber tax and
my only hope is that we can beat that so
here's what I'm proposing and thank you
for bearing with me uh I want to mirror
the timber tax as closely as possible
the Constitution gives us the clear
right as a legislature to tax growing
trees my proposal can fit neatly in the
same RSA 79 a company looking to
generate an emissions reduction ton on
New Hampshire Forest land would file an
attent to generate with the local
assessing official just as they would at
pa7 intent to cut today the exact nature
and language of that document would be
decided by the division of forest and
lands along with the intent to generate
they would submit the ghg pro the
greenhouse gas pro project plan that
they are already producing for their
certification Authority those documents
would be first reviewed by the local
assessing official and then forwarded to
the division of forest and Lance both
the local and state officials would have
the opportunity to review and challenge
the numbers in their reports just as
they do with the intent to cut the local
officials would then assess a yearly tax
based on the growth claimed in the ghg
project plan this would be the growth
above the Baseline laid out in the plan
the project plan also defines a
crediting period in the case of the
California Market that is 100 years but
in other cases that can be much shorter
the tax would be assessed on a total
board feet of growth over the pole
project divided by 50 or the crediting
period whichever is less this is based
on the fact that most areas will go
through an approximately 50-year growth
rotation so a 100-year crediting period
would mean giving up two Timber tax
collections essentially the actual tax
amount would fluctuate each year because
it would be charged on the current
stumpage rates published by the division
of forest and lands essentially my
thought is that widespread adoption of
credit generation would lower the
availability of Timber and likely would
lead to an increase in the average price
of stumpage as stumpage rates rise the
tax would adjust to reflect that this
should naturally work to level the
playing field between generation and
cutting leading to a smooth transition
transition and avoiding a rapid collapse
of the Timber harvesting industry the
remaining segments of RSA 79 would apply
including the parts about doomage for
those unaware doomage is the penalty for
submitting inaccurate information to the
assessing official there would be
another incentive for generators to go
along with this in the current Timber
tax law as it's written today towns and
cities have the right to preemptively
apply the timber tax if a town believes
that an owner isn't harvesting a
property to the historical level they
may apply a Timber tax to the entire
parcel that Timber tax is then credited
when the timber is eventually harvested
under my bill as long as an owner was
paying the yearly generating tax the
town could not apply the preemptive
Timber tax it's an incentive to be part
of our new system I'm aware that there
are flaws in this proposal many of the
places that have the most Forest have
the fewest people and therefore the lack
lack the expertise to scrutinize complex
mathematical documents we would be
relying on professionals at the state
level to sniff out Bad actors much as
they do now with audits on logging
operations this will likely take a whole
new position at the office with an
expertise different from traditional
forest rangers I'm also aware that not
all project plans requirements are the
same especially on the voluntary Market
but I believe that if we are going to
allow resources in our state to be used
for the exclusive benefit of foreign
companies then we should set the rules
and they should learn to play with them
there are forests all over the world
where they can spend their money we
should be courting the buyers who are
willing to rise to our
standards I'm not sure if that 10% rate
in the bill is the appropriate number
when the original Timber tax was passed
in 1949 a commission was established
that ran from 1951 to 1953 to establish
whether their original number accurately
offset the loss in property taxes we
will most definitely need the same type
of commission this time around we will
also likely need to assess how this new
system fits into our current system
system of current use many of these
credit agreements include Provisions
that limit recreational use on the land
especially motorized Recreation and with
the OHV and snowmobile use in this state
being so important for tourism we need
to examine that issue and whether carbon
credit generation deserves that subsidy
I have another bill before a different
committee to examine just that if we do
nothing more this year I would ask that
we pass the intent to generate portion
of the bill we need to give lawmakers
and the division of forest and lands the
the statistics to understand the current
landscape with so many markets out there
it is currently impossible for us to
know how many acres of forest land here
in New Hampshire are currently under
these restrictive agreements and for how
long that is precisely why the fiscal
note on this bill is unable to give any
insight on projected Revenue at the same
time the division of forest and lands
has extremely accurate numbers on
traditional harvesting operations
because we recognize that those numbers
are important to protecting our forest
resources in the best interest of this
state I apologize again for being up
here for so long it's an extremely
complex topic that has taken me months
to grasp and I know that I am still just
touching the surface although I am happy
to answer your questions now in the
interest of giving others time to speak
today I would ask that you might hold
them for a time outside this hearing or
possibly a future hearing on this topic
many of these people have traveled a
long way through horrible weather and
many did so yesterday for another
committee but were denied the
opportunity to speak due to lack of time
I want to be sure that we can hear from
all those who wish to speak today thank
you
I'll give you your request you can
leave thank
you Patrick Hackley division of forest
and
lands
hat thank you sir
thank you representative harb and
representative Rulo uh for the
opportunity to testify on HB 1709
establishing a tax on land used for
carbon
credits uh for the record again I spoke
with all you earlier today my name is
Patrick Hackley I'm the state Forester
and the director for the New Hampshire
division of forest and lands we're part
of the Department of Natural and
cultural
resources um we we do not have a formal
position on House Bill 1709 but we do
have a few concerns which I'll Express I
do have to say a thank you to
representative Aman Kelly for offering
an exceptional background to his
thinking behind this bill that was
unfortunately we didn't have an
opportunity to get that before before I
made my testimony so um I I have a a
better understanding of how hard he
worked on this and um I'm sure we'll
have conversations after this this
Committee hearing um just for a little
bit of background which I don't believe
I gave this morning the division of
forest lands is the state agency charged
with the execution of all matters
pertaining to forestry Forest management
and Forest lands within the jurisdiction
of the state one of our key
responsibilities to protect our natural
resources for the benefits of the state
citizens visitors and the forest
products
industry I understand the intent and and
again I'm I'm going to riff off of uh
representative Kelly's comments a little
bit I understand that this this bill was
inspired by uh the need to address the
participation of landowners in carbon
credit programs that could result in the
potential loss of Timber tax revenue due
to reduced
harvesting the bill would enable towns
to Levy taxes on landowners who sell
carbon credits and instead of Timber
which has historically been a subject to
a severance tax under RSA
79a uh of which a great history was just
presented to you by representative Kelly
uh landowner enrollment and carbon
credit programs is still in its early
stages however there is valid concern
that Timber tax revenue may be
diminished over time should an
increasing number of land owners choose
to generate carbon credits rather than
Harvest Timber acknowledging this new
Revenue source to land owners and its a
potential effect on possibly depressing
tax revenues I wish to make the
following
observations uh the situation that
inspired this bill in Pittsburgh with
the state's largest private landowner um
is still unresolved under the terms of
the state held conservation easement
which our department monitors the
landowner must submit their 10-year
Forest management plan to our agency for
review and
approval that is in compliance with the
conservation easement while the land
owner has indic indicated that they
still intend to drop the Harvest to half
the volume of previous years in favor of
carbon credit
generation we the state has not yet uh
approved uh that plan relative to the
purposes of the
easement so that's still in the process
we have multiple agencies looking at
that uh we we did just receive their
Forest management plan a couple weeks
ago and so we'll be reviewing that and
communicating back to the land owner
regarding our our observations of that
um new plan so at this stage as I
mentioned it's still too early to
determine how many land owners Statewide
will enroll in such a program and how
much this will affect uh Municipal tax
revenues Timber tax leving here's some
of the concerns leving a new tax on
Forest land owners could lead to
unintended outcomes such as conversion
to other uses that may be deemed less
beneficial to the public again I know
it's New Hampshire the Live Free or Die
State and uh you know taxes are looked
at very seriously in this state so this
would be a new this would be viewed as
potentially a new tax on Forest land
owners specifically and and that we
concern may be viewed as one more one
more um you know Death By A Thousand
Cuts to own Timberland in New Hampshire
again somewhat of an extreme view but we
do have to look at that as a potential
discouragement to Forest land
ownership moderate land use tax policy
has been the foundation of New
Hampshire's conservation community and
Alternate Revenue sources encourages
land owners to keep their forests as
forests if we really want to talk about
an effect on the carbon equation and the
environment is keeping Forest land in
Forest ultimately that's the engine
which converts CO2 to oxygen and helps
us lower the um the greenhouse gas
effect so that's really what what it's a
broad concern but it's a real concern
Forest loss is one of the the most uh
one of the largest issues we've
identified in our fa State Forest action
plan any new tax formula proposed for
carbon credits to offset the potential
loss of Municipal Timber tax revenue
must be proportional to the loss and
carefully conceived without discouraging
enrollment in such programs or
discouragement of forest land ownership
in
general the formula proposed in HB 1709
to quantify and assess the value of
carbon credits applies undefined metrics
and terms that make it impossible to
really understand it I and I respect the
fact that Aman Kelly representative
Kelly did a great job of of giving you
some insight onto the mechanics of how
he proposes that but there's still as he
mentioned and we would agree there's a
lot of work to do to understand the
terms that he used and how we would get
to that point if in fact there's
consensus we should go
there so I would say that more work
would need to be done in this form for
it to be practically
implemented and those are my concerns
thank you for the opportunity to testify
I'm happy to take any questions any any
questions for the speaker representative
rung then representative wil thank you
Mr chair and thank you Mr Hackley for uh
taking my question I actually have a
couple one um how much money are we
talking about so let's say somebody owns
a forest it's it's on their land
privately owned um how much money would
they get from selling a carbon credit
versus if they sold that you know the
timber to a logger right
the answer is it depends
unfortunately um and I and I don't
pretend to understand the the value of a
carbon credit um which is one metric ton
of carbon and it's there's a formula for
um measuring that but that's a that's a
market price question between the enrol
of the program and the carbon Market
that they've signed up with um but
clearly there are companies such as the
one in p Pittsburg that recently entered
um entered into New Hampshire in
2022 um where they're balancing the the
opportunity to harvest Timber with the
opportunity to generate carbon credits
and as they see it and I I'm not I don't
try to explain their business model but
they see an opportunity to to to make a
better margin off of carbon credits than
than harvesting and selling Timber
there's there's obviously some margin
there that's more appealing and probably
less complicated you don't have to do
logging contracts you don't have to deal
with loggers you don't have to worry
about environmental impacts of Timber
harvesting it's all just letting the
trees grow I mean there's more to it
than that there's modeling there's
monitoring but it is much there's less
moving parts to I would say growing a
carbon credit than growing timber that's
just my observation externally um so I
can't answer your question directly
represent wrong it's a good question
though and it's obviously a favor able
one a favorable equation when you can
buy a large large tracks of land which
companies are now doing and focusing on
the generation of carbon credits that
there's obviously something there that's
appealing one more question has has the
state considered selling carbon credits
on land they own we the question has
come up there are states in in the US
that are doing it Michigan in particular
very entrepreneurial with their forests
they're they're they're generating solar
energy they're selling carbon credits
um uh they're doing a lot of different
things and other states are I believe
considering it um we are not we are not
currently considering it yeah
representative
will thank you for taking my question
director um I guess
I wish I had the opportunity
representative Kelly
to understand a little bit more on the
uh fees that are coming but in regard to
to something that I think you can answer
if we start harvesting
Timber what effect is that're going to
have in the
socioeconomic life of the North Country
right it's a good question thank you for
that I
think it's a it's an important question
um so we're we're charting new territory
here representative wolf I mean this
this is um a circumstance that I don't
think any one predicted 20 years ago
certainly they did not when they crafted
the conservation easement and that's the
variable here um the particular owner in
the North Country um owns land in other
states that aren't where the land is not
necessarily encumbered by an easement
where there's there's not this
requirement for sustainable forestry and
um harvesting of wood products which is
language in the easement so um to and
just for the record for those of you who
studied this I'm sure representative
Kelly has the previous landowner
enrolled this program it's not the
current land owner that enrolled in a
carbon credit program the previous owner
the investment entity called the force
Land Group um they enrolled the program
the property in the program between 2013
and 2014 so almost for 10 years this
property has sold credits to some level
to some degree and harvested Timber so
that's another Point another takeaway
for the committee you can do both on the
same same property they can these two
values can coexist and
do um and the current landown has not
said they're not going to cut anywh
they're just going to they're going to
focus more on generating carbon credits
than than generating Timber so to get to
the to the point of your
question from the stakeholders we've
heard from this will have a a fairly
significant impact on certain values
that come from a more robust Timber
program um so and and those of you who
have read the articles there's a
substantial big enough hit to the town
of Pittsburgh where they've really come
to the four and they've come to the
citizens committee meetings and they're
concerned about how to replace the Lost
Timber tax revenue from this land that
has on average produced roughly 27 to
29,000 cords per year down to uh
proposed 12 to 14 so it's it is
literally half of what was traditionally
harvested from no one knew the wiser
when the previous land owner was
generating carbon and cutting wood they
were kind of balancing both the new
owner has a different business model
that's certainly their prerogative but
there are other values now being
impacted by the scale of this new plan
and that's that's why the state's really
looking at the easen and talking with
the land owner and trying to come up
with how we can still meet the social
economic needs of the the North country
and respect the property rights of of
the new owner there in Pittsburgh
so representative Derby thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um so first
I um I agree that there's a number of
terms in here that don't seem to be
defined and um probably uh
representative Kelly wants to add some
clarity there and get some feedback but
my real question is um regarding your
concern about um conversion from you
know uh Forest land to non-forest
land you know 79 RSA 795 says that if
you don't use the land if you don't cut
the cut the wood you can get taxed on it
anyway this bill seems to say that um
the tax is only going to be be assessed
on EST on um estimated stumpage above
Baseline of course that's one of the
terms that I don't think it's defined
well yeah but to me what it means is you
got a you got trees on on the property
now you've got this um this greenhouse
gas plant or whatnot and where are you
gonna be at some point in the future and
so it's only the the above and beyond
where you are so if you keep it where it
is it seems to me there's no tax except
for potentially that the fact that
you're not cutting the wood in the first
place which is which is already the the
threat of of Taxation there yeah so I
wonder if you read my question to you is
if you read it similarly which is that
if they maintain the Baseline then
there's really no difference um and it
would reduce the threat of um people
deciding to cut down their Force because
of an additional tax yeah thank you for
that question
you know I'll just I'll just say I don't
understand the terms in the in the the
legislation but but the way you framed
it that could be the case it again the
devil's in the details and the
definitions of how we get to the the
point of of taxing a carving credit um
I'm just I'm talking about the
perception of like you know he's a land
owner looking to well I'm going to still
going to cut some wood but hey I've got
500 Acres maybe I'd like to put a 100 in
the carbon credit program hey and I
don't have to pay Timber tax I'll just
generate some well you're going to maybe
you will be paying carbon
taxes not necessarily I you know there's
a threat of Merit to this idea because
we we don't want to see lost Municipal
tax revenue Which towns have come to
rely on through the timber tax program
so you know I think it's going to be an
evolving discussion as representative
Kelly already alluded to how how to get
there if if that is in fact a consensus
of what people want and so thank you for
that question
any other questions before we go back to
Mr Wolf representative wolf just to
follow up on my question we're all
talking about Timber tax for the
municipality yeah but nobody's talking
about the guy
that's going down to Ed Nash's place and
buying a you skitter or something like
that and where is that Revenue going to
come from and the ability to earn a
living up there yeah if they're just
sitting there watching trees grow yeah
yeah thank you represent wolf um yeah so
there's a chain reaction to A reduced
harvesting on on Forest land in general
I'm not going to just speak to the
Pittsburgh issue because I think we've
touched on that enough but let's just
say everyone jumped in on the party and
started selling carbon credits and that
is a real concern for some of the wood
processing facilities in New Hampshire
at the hearing yesterday there as you
some of you may know there were a few
Mills from the North Country who are
dealing with a lot of other issues that
uh affect their bottom line trucking
fuel costs
Labor uh wood markets not enough
low-grade wood markets we've those of
you who follow these issues in the
forest products industry know those and
that and so now they're saying oh now
our wood supply might be diminished
because there's this carbon credit thing
and everyone's running around trying to
get definitions of what a carb credit
program is but they see it as one more
hit to making a living in the
forest
so exactly right there's it's not just
um it's not just cutting wood it's
you're you're producing wood products
that provide a job to the logger that
cuts the wood to the trucker that
deliver delivers it to the mill The
Sawmill that makes products out of it
and employs their people and so we call
that the wood supply chain and the wood
supp supply chain is one of the
stakeholders in this concept of carbon
credits that we have to be mindful
of any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony next in opposition Blake
stanel Aurora sustainable
land
Blake
is it on okay there we go sorry about
that um my name is Blake stansil and I'm
the president of Aurora sustainable
lands I think we're the we're the
company with the Target on our back uh
that a lot of the carbon bills have been
uh drafted for I think at least
originally so I hope to be able to
explain a little bit about who we are
and what we're all about
um and and uh just comments on the bill
itself um well before I say that the uh
the company owns 1.65 million acres and
the Connecticut Lakes property here that
we manage is 146,000 so that's a
component of our of our
portfolio uh we became the owner of that
property in late 2022 through a merger
with the forest Land Group uh Patrick
mentioned Forest Land Group before I was
with the forest Land Group and have some
history with the property so I I uh been
around for a good bit of of time on the
property itself and we're we're opposed
to this bill um and I'll give a a few
reasons for it uh the first one is mean
we we pay New Hampshire business tax we
pay property tax we pay Severance tax we
pay Road use
fees and um out of our
1.65 million acre portfolio I believe
this property is likely the most
regulated in our portfolio um and it's
also worth noting that I believe a tax
of the kind we're we're talking about
here would be the first of its kind in
the country I don't think there's
another tax like this out there um who
is
Aurora uh we're we're a company that
focuses on buying and managing Forest
land in the US to remove and store
carbon from the atmosphere um we be and
and I mentioned how we became owners of
this property um uh but the thing the
the thing I also want to make clear here
today is we absolutely plan to continue
logging so we're we're focused on
generating carbon credits but recognize
that the way you generate carbon credits
is through a healthy Forest so a healthy
Forest is a managed Forest a managed
Forest means logging is occurring so I
want to just make sure that's clear um
just a few few facts about the property
itself uh the the Connecticut Lakes
property is the the largest privately
owned uh forest in the state that's open
to the public uh it's been managed under
this existing conservation easement
since
2003 and as Patrick mentioned before
it's uh also been enrolled in a carbon
project since 2013 so the the Project's
been around for a
while
um in terms of our management and the
things that we plan to do on the
property first off I would say that we
will absolutely manage per the letter
and the spirit of the conservation
easement uh we're actively engaged in
the process uh that's laid out of having
an approved Forest management plan we're
we're in active conversations with the
division of forest and land and and um
we also
um perhaps most importantly to to folks
in the North country as I mentioned
before we also plan to continue logging
and the the fact is um there's actually
logging going on on the property right
now actually maybe not today because of
the weather conditions but as of a few
days ago there were active uh crews out
on the property and while the the
overall volume of logging is going down
that was also discussed previously the
type of Forestry that we're practicing
is more precise it's more detailed and
will require uh a more labor intensive
process on a Timber sale by Timber sale
basis so we anticipate having more uh
need for Foresters GIS Specialists land
surveyors more Tech techncal kind of
folks on the ground as we implement this
new
strategy um and then also on the tax
side there we recognize that reduced
Timber volumes has an impact in the
North Country especially uh the town of
Pittsburgh where the majority of the
Timber Severance tax is paid uh so we
have reached an agreement in principle
with the town whereby um Aurora
will bridge the gap between what has
been paid in Timber Severance tax
revenue uh on average historically
compared to what will be paid during the
current fiscal year from this new
harvesting plan so we're we're in active
dialogue our Forester who's in charge of
the property has been to the town
meetings and uh has an active di
dialogue with the the selectman of
Pittsburgh
um in conclusion and and I'm happy to to
talk more about things obviously but uh
just want to say that we appreciate the
conversations we've had with local state
and federal
officials uh and we we absolutely
understand and respect uh our
responsibility as stewards of this
remarkable resource and we look forward
to continue to collaborate with the
local
community uh with State Legislature and
with public officials to make sure that
the property is not only protected but
also enhanced and the the continued use
and enjoyment is there for residents and
tourists thank you representative
Vale thank you Mr chair thank you for
the testimony um I just am wondering
what is the current price of a carbon
credit it
depends and not dodging the question but
it really does uh it depends on whether
the credit is sold in the compliance
Market all things that were mentioned
earlier whether it's sold in the
compliance Market the voluntary Market
uh whether it was generated from a
property uh somewhere outside the US so
there's a lot a lot of different issues
around that question um and the the
market itself has been in a bit of a
transition uh in
2023 as buyers of credits have taken a
step back to say how do we ensure that
this is an actual that that this credit
I'm buying has an actual environmental
impact so um it it's it's a difficult
question to to put an actual number
on thank you may I have a followup Mr
chair thank you um my followup question
is what is the duration of your credit
um contact
contracts so the uh the the property
that we manage here that has that
project on it that's been in place since
2013 that is a um project that's
registered in the compliance market and
the protocol there is 100
years one more followup Mr chair thank
you how many credits do you generate on
an average um Forest over a hundred-year
period
depends sorry for that answer but uh
yeah it it
um it depends on where the forest is so
how long's the growing season depends on
how it's managed Ed uh so a lot of
factors
involved thank you so much for taking my
question anyone representative rang
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I I actually have
just two one is um you mentioned that um
managing a force that's under carbon
credit agreement requires some
additional employees how does that like
what's the net employee um addition or
loss
with that let's say use that property in
Pittsburgh compared to if it was just um
in uh the timber industry I'll I'll
clarify my comments there so uh my
comments were specific to the type of of
Forestry that we're implementing on the
property so in some ways regardless of
whether there's a carbon project or not
the type of Forestry that we're
implementing under our new plan involves
more data collection on the front end of
the of the Timber sale process so we
have more folks out on the ground uh
measuring trees marking
trees um and then to speak specifically
to the carbon side of things uh the
requirements in a carbon project that
lead to more potential jobs at least
more man hours on the ground are again
collection of data so it's a much more
data intensive process to quantify how
much carbon you have standing in the
woods than it is to quantify the amount
of Timber standing so uh it I don't have
a number for you to say you know we're
we're losing X and gaining y because it
is such a transitional process but the
jobs that we anticipate in the future
will be more technical jobs more um
forestry related jobs uh and and
potentially uh less of the guys running
chainsaws but but that I mean that is
dependent on how folks manage properties
uh but I I see more technical transition
and uh that that is not just for New New
Hampshire where we're seeing that in all
the locations where we manage properties
thank you uh just one more question Mr
chair thank you you mentioned um Mr
stanel that you are you're in agreement
or you you've got some agreement going
with Pittsburgh um to pay the Delta
between what they were getting with the
timer tax and and then the loss can you
go into more details what that is sure
um so the without getting into numbers
uh what what we've agreed to do is to
make up the gap between what has been
paid to the town on average over the
last five years relative to what is
generated in in Severance tax during
their current fiscal
year any other questions for our
speaker thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question have you been
assessed that uh um the the tax under
795 which says that if you don't cut the
wood then you have to uh then the T the
municipality can uh enforce the
tax I I don't know the answer to that I
don't think so but I I need to check on
that
one any other questions for our
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you the last speaker card I have in
opposition Jason stock New Hampshire
temp land Owners
Association Mr
stock well good afternoon I'm good to
see you again uh Jason stock New
Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association we represent Timberland
owners in the forest products industry
and I did come to you today to to speak
in opposition to the bill and you know
as the sponsor requested this isn't
about Connecticut Lakes this is
about many many many many many many
other Timberland owners across the state
um and when I look at the bill and I
look at the
mechanics you know first thing that
struck me in in in our
committee was we're trying to create a
tax and insert it into a Timber tax an
existing Timber tax statute it's been
around since the
1940s and to me it's it's like putting
that the proverbial square peg in a
round hole it just doesn't seem to fit
an intent to generate it's one of those
terms it's not defined what is it um as
you know from last year the timber tax
law gets tweaked and modified regularly
in fact I had a bill before you last
year about that and so that's a law
that's evolved since the
1940s um so to to take a new tax and
kind of and try to insert it into seeven
you know the timber tax statute I think
is is is problematic um just
operationally right now there are towns
across the every town in across the
state and and it's important to note
that almost every town does a Timber
sale every year there's a Timber sale
that gets assessed the timber tax and
even when I have a ticket a receipt that
says Jason stocks White Pine stumpage
was worth
$250 per thousand board feet and I
provide that to the town and I say all
right I'm going to pay 10% I'm going to
pay $25 on that there are still
challenges with the assessment
process and so having said that when I
read lines 7 through n this tax shall be
assessed yearly B basis on the estimated
stumpage above Baseline at the end of
the crediting period divided by 50 years
or the length of the crediting period
whichever is
shorter ask a selectman to try and
figure out how to assess that tax when I
come in with my
$250 per thousand board feet and they
look at me and say what's a board foot
and so to me it's some of the language
it's just so conv uted and difficult I
appreciate what the sponsors trying to
do this is an issue we as an association
have studied we have done a deep dive
into this and as you can imagine I have
members on all sides of it I have land
owners that say Hey this is a property
right me selling carbon credits is no
different than me selling an easement a
right of way selling you know a a uh you
know anything one of these other kind of
intangible items how is it any different
and then I have members that are
Sawmills and loggers that are saying
wait I I I believe this is a a threat to
my this is a Potential Threat to my wood
supply and so we've looked at this we've
come up with some you know we we've come
up with some kind of guidelines or I'll
call them sideboards when we look at
this issue we recogn you have to
recognize the property rights aspect of
carbon credits um you also have to
recognize there's a there's a potential
there's a there's a potential impact on
the backside I have members um that
participate or planning to participate
in this program where selling carbon
credits fits perfect with their silver
culture they have a piece of land
they've gone through the land they've
done Timber sales they've done the
weeding they've done the thinning and
now that Timber stand is approaching a
growth mode all right I'm going to let
it grow for the next 15 15 to 20 years
let's get some nice big saw logs out
there let's get some
value at the same time I can sell some
carbon credits to help pay the bills
over the next 15 to 20 years and so
these carbon credits they're all unique
they're all very not only company
specific they're site specific and
ownership specific you heard from a
corporate private Equity company I have
members that are families that are
looking at this saying hey this is an
opportunity to kind of as as as Patrick
Hackley said this is an opportunity to
glean some Revenue while we're in that
growth mode to hold so again this is
incredibly complex there are a lot of
facets the bill I again I attempt that
the sponsor's efforts and what he's
trying to do what I would say is
795 provides that opportunity RS say
795 it it it allows a municipality it's
never to to my knowledge and the folks
at Dr it's never been
used um I've asked some folks and some
of these were Old Timber tax codger from
the going back a couple uh Generations
there and say has anyone ever used this
have you they said no but what it what
it says is that the town can assess the
tax if it's unreason if it feels their
unreasonably deprived of Revenue because
of the failure of an owner to cut
standing wood or Timber when it shall
when it shall have arrived at the degree
of maturity most suitable for its use I
think there's that's in statute to me
this debate should be at Dr I think the
the the point is have Dr ask them you
can adopt rules you have this you have
the statutory Authority
to to do this but that's the arena to do
it let the tax experts let the
biometricians let let those folks work
on this um this this particular bill I
think is it's just incredibly complex
and you start getting into dabbling into
systems and into programs and forms and
things that are IL defined and I I just
fear that it's just going to create a
bit of a mess um
and I guess I would just you know and
and there are other aspects of it the
the the effect of if you are if you have
a carbon program that looks at
comparable properties um
adjacent or comparable areas you use
comparable areas within 50 miles of your
property well if I'm a a timber land
owner and I happen to own a piece of
land that's adjacent to the White
Mountain National Forest
Wilderness Area very different ownership
very different very different type of
management there than say A you know a
typical typical tree farmer or
Timberland owner and so now to say all
right our solution for those types of
programs the comparable area programs
we're going to apply it to 50 you know
lands within 50 miles may not you may
not be comparing Apples to Apples in
terms of ownership but also ownership
objectives and management so again I
would I would urge um inexpedient to
legislate on this um and I would also
offer that if the committee is is really
excited about learning more about this
representative Kelly who comes from a
long family a long line of Timberman um
gave you a great kind of 101 but Charlie
LC who work who's a consultant out of
the Anum area he actually has a grant
from the state for a group of State
Forester associations has a carbon 101
presentation I think you may have seen
it representative Kelly I know he's
presented up north on several occasions
he can come and give you an explanation
of kind of how this works um how it
works I know he's later this month he's
going to be giving a similar pre that
presentation I should say to the Science
and Tech committee it might be um an
opportunity to either piggyback with
that or maybe have him kind of have a a
dual showing um have him come over but
it could give you an idea of kind of the
magnitude of this these markets kind of
how they work it is a new animal for
Timberland owners and I can tell you in
the forest products industry this seems
to be these days um be beyond the the
fact that it's been raining for 40 days
and 40 nights it seems this is the other
thing that people are talking about is
what's going on with these carbon price
project projects and how's that
affecting wood supply so I'm I'm happy
to try to answer questions um like I
said uh I I would urge if you're
interested um Avail yourself uh
representative harb knows Charlie from
the lowgrade
commission and he usually does a pretty
good job at mapping it laying out issues
particularly complex issues as this I'll
conclude my comments any questions for
Mr stock
representative Derby thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my question certainly
um yeah so you know uh along the lines
of what representative wolf was asking
earlier I I I get it now right like the
loss of the loss of wood um and I can
appreciate the um boss of you know wood
products and and all the secondary um
markets of that it's clear that you
you're talking about it with you know
people in your organization um we heard
testimony a minute ago um from uh an
organization that's actually you know
owns these that carbon credits are
coming and they're coming fast to New
Hampshire you know we're a very heavily
wooded State um and we have we provide
great tax breaks to you know
conservation areas with you know current
the current use rules right so what
would your recommendation be I I I
understand 795 right but
it it is gray and it's not clear it's
gray because it you said it hasn't been
used it's not clear how often you could
enforce that I think representative
Kelly's Bill about a yearly um credit to
basically spread out the cost makes
sense how would you um which which may
really encourage encourage the cutting
of wood because it actually costs more
to to grow these Force so what would you
do you have a suggestion do your members
have a suggestion as to how to keep that
wood supply um Market flowing to avoid
the whole state going to carbon credits
sure sure well I think first off carbon
credits are here so you made the comment
they're coming oh they're here they've
been here as you heard earlier for at
least 10 years and many time and in the
case of Connecticut Lakes no one really
knew about it so they are here you have
properties being managed or and that
have been managed that have carbon
programs on them so so that's point one
I think you know the other to get to the
your the other points of your question
is I think you know
795 is is yes it's very broad it's
broadly written but I think there's I
think you know I would I would again
suggest that's where let Dr develop some
rules and guidance around that I think
that would be that would be the
appropriate means of doing that um to
create a a new a new tax and try to
insert that um the other piece of this
is you know it's
um again I I just I I kind of come back
to the complexity of this and just the
ability to administer manage it and even
figure out how to produce a tax
bill you you know know when you look at
stumpage
values stumpage Valu is the value of
that tree and if you're using that as
part in comparing that to baselines well
that tree may be any number of species
which all have different values it may
be very nice veneer quality high quality
or it may be a scraggly tree that should
be chipped or sent to a bul wood and so
to try to do this kind of
wholesale across an entire ownership and
and then and then use that as a means of
assessing
attacks um kind of like we talked about
before you would have to almost annually
do cruises on property to kind of look
at the trees and say okay yeah this red
oak is really is really growing well
they're hitting the baseline or they're
above Baseline boy that that red you
know that black Birch isn't doing as
well and so let's modify it I just see
this is so complex I think I again I
come back I think there's a mechanism in
place I think that
mechanism is is Dr in 795 and I would I
would encourage that's the venue to do
it they are the they are the tax
assessment efforts experts and they're
the timber tax experts so I hope I hope
I answered your question I I that's that
you know to your point what was our
what's our
suggestion
any other
questions um I just have a quick one um
how do we know that every town has um
had a Timber cut in the last year great
question if you recall from our
testimony last year on the timber tax
bill so each so when I go to do the
timber Harvest I submit an intent to cut
that goes into the into the town a copy
goes to the state the state keeps that
and cataloges that and so I do my Timber
sale at the end of the Timber sale I
file what's called a reportive cut so I
give my intent to cut this is what we
think is out there this is what we think
we'll do I do my Timber sale then I file
my report and that based on that report
is what what I pay my taxes on the
report of cut also goes to the state so
that's why I can sit up here and say on
a typical year the state of New
Hampshire Hampshire about three to 3.2
million tons of wood all products all
species are harvested where Jason get
that number he got I look at those
Timber tax records and on a Town Bytown
basis and they list them by Harvest you
know project number they usually they
list them um by number like project
number so your town would be listed if
you it's an interesting exercise go go
Department of Revenue and you can look
and see right there what was what was
harvested and what and but that's all Dr
again they're the experts on this they
track this
stuff thank you okay you're welcome any
other
questions I don't see any thank you all
right thank you anyone else wish to
testify on hb1 1709
FN second time anybody want to testify
on hb17 09 FN I don't see anyone
approaching the table so I'll declare
this hearing
closed thank you members of the
committee um we are scheduled a week
from today at 9
o'l uh I was asked if in the future we
could schedule us at 10:00 so next week
will be our last 9:00 meeting unless
something comes up and in the future um
we're probably meeting every week and uh
unless it's the vacation week and we'll
start at 10:00 after next
week leave I
got